cognitive Computing machine learning and
natural language processing to
process the top machine learning
algorithms that are used to build
intelligent machines so here you will
look at linear regression logistic
regression decision tree k means
clustering KNN PCA and other techniques
such as regularization reinforcement
learning and Q learning moving forward
you will understand the working of
artificial neural networks and deep
learning algorithms such as
convolutional neural network recurrent
neural network GIS image classification
and sequential model so let's get
started picture this a machine that
could organize your cupboard just as you
like it or serve every member of the
House a customized cup of coffee makes
your day easier doesn't it these are the
products of artificial intelligence but
why use the term artificial intelligence
well these machines are artificially
Incorporated with human like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but AI may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact AI is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an AI do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the AI robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other Rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short AI provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide
Solutions well now that we know what AI
is let's have a look at the two broad
categories an AI is classified into weak
AI also called narrow AI focuses solely
on one task for example alphago is a
maestro of the game go but you can't
expect it to be even remotely good at
Jess this makes alphago a weak AI you
might say Alexa is definitely not a weak
AI since it can perform multiple tasks
well that's not really true when you ask
Alexa to play despacito it picks up the
key words play and despacito and runs a
program it is trained to Alexa cannot
respond to a question it isn't trained
to answer for instance try asking Alexa
the status of traffic from work to home
Alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to and
that brings BR us to our second category
of AI strong AI now this is much like
the robots that only exist in fiction as
of now Ultron from Avengers is an ideal
example of a strong AI That's because
it's self-aware and eventually even
develops emotions this makes the ai's
response
unpredictable You Must Be Wondering well
how is artificial intelligence different
from machine learning and deep learning
we saw what AI is machine learning is a
technique to achieve Ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning machine learning provides a
machine with the capability to learn
from data and experience through
algorithms deep learning does this
learning through ways inspired by the
human brain this means through deep
learning data and patterns can be better
perceived Ray kheel a well-known
futurist predicts that by the year 204
five we would have robots as smart as
humans this is called the point of
Singularity well that's not all in fact
Elon Musk predicts that the human mind
and body will be enhanced by AI implants
which would make us partly cyborgs so
here's a question for you which of the
below AI projects don't exist yet a an
AI robot with citizenship B a robot with
a muscular skeletal system C AI that can
read its owner's emotions D AI that
develops emotions over time give it a
thought and leave your answers in the
comment section below since the human
brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that AI too has a lot of
unventured domains for now ai is built
to work with humans and make our tasks
easier however with the maturation of
Technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of AI holds for us well
that is artificial intelligence for you
in short do not forget to leave your
answer to the quiz in the comment
section below also like share and
subscribe to our Channel if you enjoyed
this video stay tuned and keep
learning now let's look at the different
types of artificial
intelligence so AI can be classified
based on capabilities and
functionalities under capabilities there
are three types of artif arcial
intelligence they are narrow AI General
Ai and super AI under functionalities we
have four types of artificial
intelligence reactive machine limited
memory theory of mind and self-awareness
let's look at them one by
one first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on
capabilities so what is narrow AI narrow
AI also known as we AI focuses on one
narrow task and cannot perform Beyond
its limitations it aims at a single
subset of cognitive abilities and
advances in that Spectrum applications
of narrow AI are becoming increasingly
common in our day-to-day lives as
machine learning and deep learning
methods continue to
evolve Apple Siri is a simple example of
a narrow AI that operates with a limited
predefined range of functions Siri often
has challenges with tasks outside its
range of abilities IBM Watson
supercomputer is another example of
narrow AI which applies cognitive
Computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your
questions IBM Watson once outperformed
human contestant Ken Jenkins to become
the champion on the popular game show
Jeopardy other examples of narrow AI
include Google Translate image
recognition software recommendation
systems spam filtering and Google's page
ranking
algorithm
next we have General artificial
intelligence or general AI General AI
also known as strong AI has the ability
to understand and learn any intellectual
task that a human can General artificial
intelligence has received a$1 billion
investment from Microsoft through open
AI it allows the machine to apply
Knowledge and Skills in different
contexts AI researchers and scientists
have not achieved strong AI so far to
succeed they would need to find a way to
make machines conscious programming a
full set of cognitive
abilities Fujitsu built the K computer
which is one of the fastest computers in
the world it is one of the most notable
attempts at achieving strong AI it took
40 minutes to simulate a single second
of neural activity so it is difficult to
determine whether or not strong AI will
be achieved in the near
future tan 2 is a superc computer
created by China's national university
of Defense technology it currently holds
the record for CPS at 33.86 petaflops
although it sounds exciting the human
brain is estimated to be capable of one
exaflop now CPS means characters per
second that A system can
process third in the list of AI that is
based on capabilities we have super AI
super AI exceeds human intelligence and
can perform any task better than a
human the concept of Art artificial
super intelligence sees AI evolved to be
so akin to human emotions and
experiences that it doesn't just
understand them it evokes emotions needs
beliefs and desires of its own its
existence is still hypothetical some of
the key characteristics of super AI
include the ability to think solve
puzzles make judgments and decisions on
its
own now if you have enjoyed watching
this video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section our
team of experts will help you address
your
questions moving ahead now we will see
the different types of artificial
intelligence based on
functionalities in this category first
we have reactive machine a reactive
machine is the basic form of AI that
does not store memories or use past
experiences to to determine future
actions it works only with present data
they simply perceive the world and react
to it reactive machines are given
certain tasks and don't have
capabilities Beyond those
duties IBM's deep blue which defeated
chess Grandmaster Gary casprov is a
reactive machine that sees the pieces on
a chest board and reacts to them it
cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice deep blue can identify the
pieces on a chest book
and know how each moves it can make
predictions about what moves might be
next for it and its opponent it can
choose the most optimal moves from among
the possibilities deep blue ignores
everything before the present moment all
it does is look at the pieces on the
chessboard as it stands right now and
choose from possible next
moves up next we have limited memory
limited memory AI learns from past data
to make decisions the memory of such
systems is
shortlived while they can use this data
for a specific period of time they
cannot add it to a library of their
experiences this kind of technology is
used for self-driving Vehicles they
observe how other vehicles are moving
around them in the present and as time
passes that ongoing collected data gets
added to the static data within the AI
machine such as Lane markers and traffic
lights they're included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle Mitsubishi Electric is a
company that has been figuring out how
to improve such technology for
applications like self-driving
cars then we have theory of Mind theory
of Mind represents a very advanced class
of technology and exists as a concept
this kind of AI requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment can alter
feelings and
behaviors it should be able to
understand people's emotions sentiment
and
thoughts even though a lot of
improvements are there in this field
this kind of AI is not complete yet one
real world example of theory of Mind AI
is Kismet a robot head made in the late
'90s by a Massachusetts Institute of
Technology researcher Kismet can mimic
human emotions and recognize them both
abilities are key advancements in theory
of Mind AI but Kismet can't follow gazes
or convey attention to humans sopia from
Hansen robotics is another example where
the theory of Mind AI was implemented
cameras within Sophia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see seek and follow faces sustain eye
contact and recognized individuals she
is able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsist
system finally we have
self-awareness self-awareness AI only
exists
hypothetically such systems understand
that internal traits States and
conditions and perceive human
emotions these machines will be smarter
than the human
mind this type of AI will not only be
able to understand and evoke emotions in
those it interacts with but also have
emotions needs and beliefs of its own
while we are probably far away from
creating machines that are self-aware we
should focus our efforts towards
understanding memory learning and the
ability to base decisions on past
experiences I am K and today we shall be
talking about the top 10 artificial
intelligence Technologies before getting
into the video here's a gentle reminder
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon so that you wouldn't miss any
update from us so without further Ado
let's quick quickly jump into the topic
in the list we have natural language
generation smart devices virtual agents
speech recognition augmented reality
machine learning robotic process
automation decision management deep
learning and finally image recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular
order natural language and RCI
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication to say the right words in
the right sequence to convey the message
clearly humans often find it tricky and
when it comes to machines it's
trickier natural language generation is
a sub discipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structure data into a
native language the machines are
programmed in such a way that the
algorithms convert the data into a
desirable format for the
users this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights some of the sample vendors are
a view automated insights SAS Cambridge
semantics digital reason
narrative signs
Etc on the list next we have Smart
devices with every passing day smart
devices are becoming more popular and
more trendy technologies that people
were using Once Upon A Time are now
remodeled and modified as smart
devices they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the
operations smart devices are everyday
objects made intelligent with Advanced
computations which include artificial
intelligence and machine
learning they are electronic gadgets
that are able to connect share and
interact with its users and other smart
devices some of the smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smartphones
smart speakers Etc virtual agents they
are computer generated intelligence that
provides online customer assistance they
can effectively communicate with humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our
queries in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology which aims
to create an effective but digital
impersonation of humans virtual agents
can make reservations book an
appointment place an order and can even
Avail product information some of the
best examples of virtual agents are
Google assistant and Amazon Alexa and
the companies that provide virtual
agents are Microsoft Google Amazon and
assist
AI next we have speech recognition
speech spe recognition is yet another
subdiscipline of artificial intelligence
which is used to convert human speech
into a comprehensive and useful format
for Computer Applications to process it
can be said as a bridge between computer
interactions and humans it's presently
used in interactive voice response
systems and mobile applications some of
the companies offering speech
recognition services are Nuance
communication ations open text n and
weend
systems augmented reality yet another
trendy technology in the field of
artificial intelligence augmented
reality is an enhanced version of the
real physical world that is achieved
using sound digital visual elements and
other sensory stimuli delivered bya
technology augmented reality uses the
existing environment and adds
information to it to make a new
artificial environment it Alters the
perception of the real world environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and Furnishing much more fun
and interactive if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more machine
learning machine learning is an
application and an important branch of
artificial intelligence which refers to
machines being able to learn by
themselves without being explicitly
programmed it enables systems to learn
and improve from experience
automatically machine learning platforms
are becoming more and more popular with
the help of algorithms apis big data and
applications and training tools
Enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various
domains machine learning is widely used
for
categorization and prediction some of
the sample vendors are Amazon fractal
analytics Google Microsoft Etc robotic
process
automation configuring a robot to
interpret communicate and analyze data
is robotic process automation it uses
scripts and other methods to automate
the human actions which in turn supports
efficient business
processes robotic process automation is
widely used in those areas where the
physical presence of a human is
dangerous Fields like Warfare mining Etc
is where it's currently being used we
need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their AB ab ilities and reinforce human
Talent companies that are focusing on
robotic process automation are Pega
systems automation anywhere blue prism
Etc next on the list we have decision
management decision management is yet
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
Decisions by providing upto-date and
relevant information and Performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key
trends it also helps in making quick
decisions avoidance of risks and in the
automation of the process decision
management is widely used in the
healthcare sector financial sector
Insurance sector e-commerce and many
more some of the companies that provide
this service
are Informatica Advanced systems
Concepts piga systems Mana Etc deep
learning deep learning is a branch of
artificial intelligence that mimics the
workings of the human brain in
processing data this data is used for a
variety of purposes like recognizing
speech detecting objects translating
languages and making
decisions deep learning uses hierarchia
level of artificial neural networks for
carrying out the process of machine
learning which is used across several
Industries for various
applications some of the sample vendors
are deep Instinct fluid AI math Works
saffron technology
Etc at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video it can be used to
analyze clients and their opinions
verify users based on their faces detect
license plates and diagnos diseases the
present day image recognition is
comparable to human visual perception
many social media platforms like
Facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and Aid visually imper
users clarify gums and sste provide this
technology ology decades ago the term
artificial intelligence was just another
Frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door right from
his Genesis artificial intelligence was
programmed to probe into human life and
eliminate the fortifications of the
impossibilities in many areas like
Health Care Transportation communication
and much more there are hundreds and
thousands of organizations Tech
communities and engine worldwide working
Round the Clock to make Miracles a
reality and today we are going to
discuss the top 10 amongst those who are
contributing a significant part so here
we are the top 10 artificial
intelligence companies to watch in
2022 at number 10 we have VI AI this AI
is a revolutionary approach to
dramatically improvise the way
Healthcare is delivered wi AI focuses on
implementing artificial intelligence to
diagnose and detect abnormalities in the
human body via CT CTA MRI X-ray EKG
ultrasound
Etc this AI coordinates both the patient
and Healthcare professionals at the same
time the patient reports are shared Via
Mobile to all the concerned Medical
Teams results are astonishing with whz
AI there is a significant Improvement in
productivity and reduction of time
required for patient treatment and
discharge this AI was founded in 2016
and established in November
2021 the company runs with 223 employees
and the headquarters is in San
Francisco Vis aai mainly focuses on
improving and filling all the gaps
between patients and Health Care
Professionals Vis AI offers handsome
salaries to its employees in India the
salaries range from 4 lakhs to 18 lakhs
per anom and in America the wages range
from
$110,000 to $210,000 per anom so at
number nine we have Farm wise 10 years
ago an automated wheat killing Robo was
science fiction now it's rise of
practical weed killing Robos with
millimeter Precision thanks to farmwise
the first product of the Californian
based company was an automated Robo
weeder based on AI computer vision and
also robotics the robo would eliminate
weeds from the vegetable Fields Farm
intends to build Innovative systems and
efficient procedures that help farmers
streamline farming with efficiency
farmwise was established in the year
2020 the company functions with 50
employees on board and actively looking
for expansion the company follows the
procedure of paying farming equipment
employees and contract Personnel hourly
Farm buse makes an annual turnover of
8.5
million an average an AIML engineer at
Farm wise earns anywhere around
$133,000
perom up next we have amp robotics at
number eight we have amp robotics While
others are busy trying to revolutionize
mankind with AI EMP robotics came up
with an Innovative idea that happens to
be a kind gesture of gratitude towards
nature amp aai designed an artificial
intelligence Robo that recycles E-Waste
plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more the
robo precisely identifies paper Plastics
and metals by learning and recognizing
them via color size shape and a few more
factors the Colorado based company is
currently of operational with 137
employees in total and looking forward
to expand the idea globally a robotics
aims to reimagining recycling and to
create a world without waste through
artificial intelligence amp robotics
pays handsome salaries to their
employees with an average salary of an
employee robotics varies between
$96,000 to
$131,000 perom coming up next is a giant
at number seven we have automation
anywhere automation anywhere is a global
robotics Automation and software company
founded in the year 2003 the company's
headquarters is located in San Jose
California the global RPA leader offers
Cloud native web-based intelligent
automation solutions to the world's
leading Cloud companies automation
anywhere's automation 360 offers a
variety of intelligent tools and
self-learning systems to automate every
redundant task automation anywhere is
focusing on transforming the companies
to be RPA oriented and the current covid
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more a recent survey
States the RPA adoption rates will
increase by 57% in just one more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than
2,200 plus employees on board the
company pays decent salaries as well at
number six we have Microsoft AI
Microsoft integrated AI into cloud
computing Microsoft's AI platform
provides robust solutions to Cloud
related problems Microsoft's AI division
is headquartered in Redmond Washington
with around 5,000 employees specifically
in the AI Division and aims to tr train
and certify 15,000 employees by
2022 Microsoft AI is a robust framework
designed for developing AI Solutions
using machine learning data science
Robotics iot and more AI enable Services
accelerate productivity to a greater
level Microsoft aure uses AI to get best
of breed infrastructure with Enterprise
create security availability compliance
and manageability Microsoft also pays
handsome salaries to their employees the
average salary of an employee at the
Microsoft AI division earns up to
$160,000 perom at number five we have
data Robo data Robo has its headquarters
in Boston it is one of the AI Cloud
leaders providing a unified plat the
delivery of AI to the cloud data Robo
aims to understand and Leverage The
inherent capabilities of the platform
data Robo has the caliber to help
business analysts in building Predictive
Analytics with no knowledge of machine
learning it uses automated ml to build
and deploy accurate predictive models in
a short span of time the global Cloud
leader currently operates with more than
a thousand employees worldwide data Robo
compensates its employees with handsome
salaries an average employee at data
Robo earns up to 16 ,000 per year and up
to 3 400,000 rupees in
India at number four we have Amazon the
Alexa Maker Amazon is one of the tech
Giants interested in adopting AI into
its various divisions Amazon calls its
AI Services Amazon Lex Amazon poly
Amazon recognition and Amazon machine
learning these services are accessible
through a software API call or console
the Amazon AI suit of services can have
text or voice conversations with an end
user using a conversational chat Ops
interface the Seattle based Tech Giant
is currently using AI for its Smart Home
Solutions AI companies like Alexa and
its business intelligence needs Amazon
is also conducting trials on drone
delivery to save time and efforts to
deliver goods and services to remote
locations with e Amazon AI aims to
provide biometric payments to its
customers at cashfree stores the
approach is still in Trials Amazon calls
it just walk out
technology Amazon has enormous teams and
pays decent salaries to its employees
for example an employee at Amazon can
earn up to 20 lakh rupees perom in India
and about
$100,000 perom in United States of
America at number three we we have data
bricks data bricks is one of the best
datadriven companies data bricks
lakehouses combine data warehouses
reliability performance and governance
with the openness and flexibility of
data Leakes data brick is headquartered
in San Francisco California and has 15
office locations across 11 countries the
company announces plans on delivering
keynote on data and machine learning
product innovation and the rise of the
lakeh house architecture
advancements data bricks currently
operates with 2,000 plus employees
globally the organization compensates
its employees with handsome salaries an
average employee at data breaks makes
about $154,000 us and around 2.1 lakh
rupees perom in
India next we have meta at number two we
have Meta Meta formerly known as
Facebook is innovating an advanced way
of social interaction meta has
integrated artificial intelligence and
it's being called The Meta AI meta AI
has its headquarters in Toronto Canada
meta AI has redesigned a new material
and touch sensor with potential to boost
the development of meta War a team of
researchers at The Meta War have worked
jointly with Scientists at Cari melon
University to build reskin a plastic 3
mm thick membrane with Magnetic
particles capable of measuring touch and
sensation a thrilling experiment meta
has under its sleeve I would say meta
currently operates remotely with about
350 employees on board critics also
state that meta pays a vast salary to
its AI experts with an average salary of
$750,000 paid to the employees at meta
AI at number one we have Google AI
Google AI is the division of Google
dedicated to artificial intelligence CEO
Sundar Pai announced it at Google IO
2017 Google AI has its headquarters in
California Google AI is demonstrating
its Quantum Computing Supremacy with its
new and Powerful cinem more processor
Google's AI is one of the most most
widespread Technologies is almost
everywhere from your language
translations to helping people with
speech impairments to have a successful
conversation social media interactions
shopping lists and assisting users with
GPS sending alerts to its users about
natural calamities and saving them
Google AI has announced that its
research team is designing Next
Generation AI chips for a smart future
future in addition a new AI model allows
artificial intelligence to perform chip
design that more efficiently solves
unique aspects of any problem with an
artificial neural network Google AI
currently works with our four divisions
with massive teams we have come to an
end of this session on the top 10 AI
companies to watch out for in 2022 hello
and welcome to machine learning tutorial
part one this is part one of a machine
learning series put on by simply learn
my name is Richard kersner I'm with the
simplylearn team that's www.s simply
learn.com get certified get ahead what's
in it for you today well we'll start off
with a brief explanation of why machine
learning and what is machine learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms linear regression
decision trees support Vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe p
is of a cupcake or a muffin using the
spvm or the support Vector machine
sounds like a delicious way to explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machine can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with uh
Google's whmo and then Uber head their
program which unfortunately crashed they
know that this is huge this is going to
be the huge industry to change our whole
Transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that in some
areas where maybe not for eyes but for
other diseases where they're using the
camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnosed before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face I mean
that's just cool having at being able to
identify your face or your voice and be
able to turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation our world we live in and as
we dig in deeper we have a nice example
of Facebook as you can see here they
have the Facebook post with Halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam posts on Facebook that
annoy them into interacting with likes
shares comments and other actions I
remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here you will have
bad luck or some kind of Fear Factor
well this is a huge thing in a social
media when people are getting spammed
and so this tactic known as engagement
bait takes advantage of Facebook's news
feed algorithm by choosing engagement in
order to get the greater reach to
eliminate engagement bait the company
reviewed and categorized hundreds of
thousands of posts to train a machine
learning model that detects different
types of Engagement bait so in this case
we have we're using Facebook but this is
a course across all the different social
media they have different tools are
building and the Facebook scroll GIF
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there it notices that there's
a certain setup with Facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of General titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that takes over part of the Facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what Facebook did to eliminate this
is they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
Facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like like walking
through an airport and in a lot of
countries you have like hundreds of
people trying to sell you time share
come join us sign up for this eliminates
that annoyingness so now you can just
enjoy your Facebook and your cat
pictures or maybe it's your family
pictures mine is family certainly people
like their cat pictures too another good
example is Google's Deep Mind project
Alpha go a computer program that plays a
board game go has defeated the world's
number one go player and I hope I say
his name right keyg the ultimate go
chall game a three of three was on May
27th 2017 so that's was just last year
that this happened and what makes this
so important is that you know go is just
is a game so it's not like you're
driving a car or something in our real
world but they are using games to learn
how to get the machine learning program
to learn they want it to learn how to
learn and that is a huge step a lot of
this is still in its infant stage as far
as development as we saw what happened
with the um as referred to earlier the
Uber cars they lost their whole division
because they jumped ahead too fast so
it's still an infant stage but boy is
this like the beginning of just an
amazing world that is automated in ways
we can't even imagine what tomorrow is
going to look like we've looked at a lot
of examples of machine learning so let's
see if we can give a little bit more of
a concrete definition what is machine
learning machine learning is the science
of making computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and information
without being explicitly programmed we
see here we have a nice little diagram
where we have our ordinary system and
your computer nowadays it can even run a
lot of this stuff on a cell phone
because cell phones advance so much and
then with artificial intelligence and
machine learning it now takes the data
and it learns from what happened before
and then it predicts what's going to
come next and then really the biggest
part right now in machine learning
that's going on is it improves on that
how do we find a new solution so we go
from descriptive where it's learning
about stuff and understanding how it
fits together to predicting what it's
going to do to post scripting coming up
with a new solution and when we're
working on machine learning there's a
number of different diagrams that people
have posted for what steps to go through
a lot of it might be very domain
specific so if you're working on Photo
identification versus language versus
medical or physics some of these are
switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they very specific to
The Domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to Define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches you spend a lot of time in data
science collecting data and the next
step preparing the data you got to make
sure that your data is clean going in
there's the old saying bad data in bad
answer out or bad data out and then once
you've gone through and we cleaned all
this stuff coming in then you're going
to select the algorithm which algorithm
are you going to use you're going to
train that algorithm in this case I
think we're going to be working with svm
the support Vector machine then you have
to test the model does this model work
is this a valid model for what we're
doing and then once you've tested it you
want to run your prediction you want to
run your prediction or your choice or
whatever output it's going to come up
with and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing then you
want to go ahead and deploy the model
and remember I said domain specific this
is very general as far as the scope of
doing something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey I'm not
really getting the answers I need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words I'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no 01 do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors So based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is and then there are a lot
of domain specific things like do you
want to detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm I'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days another question that
comes up which is on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure in unexplored data
and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar Behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes goes shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to Market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to Market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any Arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're uh based on their
different areas and Investments and
financial background whether you're
going to give them a loan or not before
you even start looking at whether
they're valid customer for the bank you
might want to look at all these
different areas and group them together
based on unknown data so you're not you
don't know what the data is going to
tell you but you want to Cluster people
together that come together let's take a
quick DeTour for quiz time oh my
favorite so we're going to have a couple
questions here or quiz time and um we'll
be posting the answers in the part two
of this tutorial so let's go ahead and
take a look at these quiz times
questions and hopefully you'll get them
all right it'll get you thinking about
how to process data and what's going on
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases of course you're sitting
there with your cup of coffee and you
have your check box and your pen trying
to figure out what's your next step in
your data science analysis so the first
one is grouping documents into different
categories based on the topic and
content of each document very big these
days you know you have legal documents
you have uh maybe it's a Sports Group
documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings but certainly having
that automated is a huge thing in
today's world B identifying handwritten
digits in images correctly so we want to
know whether uh they're writing an A or
capital A B C what are they writing out
in their hand digit their handwriting C
behav avior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed D
predicting salary of an individual based
on his or her years of experience HR
hiring uh setup there so stay tuned for
part two we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
Simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it back to our regular content
and these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
supervised learning is a method used to
enable machines to classify predict
objects problems or situations based on
labeled data fed to the machine and in
here you see we have a jumble of data
with circles triangles and squares and
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on Al loan
cuz I was talking talking about Banks
earlier supervised learning on stock
market whether you're going to make
money or not that's always important and
if you are looking to make a fortune on
the stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very uh it
fluctuates in ways you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is and what a triangle
is and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
it'll group it by the number of corners
and it notices that a number of them all
have three corners a number of them all
have four corners and a number of them
all have no corners and it's able to
filter those through and group them
together we talked about that earlier
with looking at at a group of people who
are out shopping we want to group them
together to find out what they have in
common and of course once you understand
what people have in common maybe you
have one of them who's a customer at
your store or you have five of them are
customer at your store and they have a
lot in common with five others who are
not customers at your store how do you
Market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demograph of who's going to shop there
and You' like them to shop at your store
not the one next door of course this is
a simplified version you can see very
easily the difference between a triangle
and a circle which is might not be so
easy in marketing reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is an important
type of machine learning where an agent
learns how to behave in an environment
by performing actions and seeing the
result and we have here where the in
this case a baby it's actually great
that they used an infant for this slide
because the reinforcement learning is
very much in its infant stages but it's
also probably the biggest machine
learning demand out there right now or
in the future it's going to be coming up
over the next few years is reinforcement
learning on how to make that work for us
and you can see here where we have our
action in the action in this one it goes
into the fire hopefully the baby didn't
it was just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here when
the baby comes out and the News state is
the baby is sad and crying because they
got burned on the fire and then maybe
they take another action the baby's
called the agent because it's the one
taking the actions and in this case they
didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand understand because that's how
as humans that's one of the ways we
learn we learn whether it is you know
you burn yourself on the stove don't do
that anymore don't touch the stove in
the big picture being able to have a
machine learning program or an AI be
able to do this is huge because now
we're starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervised versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to come come up in
any project you're working on we have in
supervised learning we have labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said yes
that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised trading it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
they go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them hopefully this give you a little
flavor of what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support Vector machine let's start
with a closer look at linear regression
linear regression is perhaps one of the
most well-known and well understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning linear regression is a linear
model for example a model that assumes a
linear relationship between the input
variables X and the single output
variable Y and you'll see this if you
remember from your algebra classes y =
mx + C imagine we are predicting
distance traveled y from speed X our
linear regression model representation
for this problem would be y equal m * x
+ C or distance equal m * speed + C or M
m is the coefficient and C is the Y
intercept and we're going to look at two
different variations of this first we're
going to start with time is constant and
you can see we have a bicyclist he's got
a safety gear on thank goodness speed
equals 10 m/s and so over a certain
amount of time his distance equals 36
kilm we have a second bicyclist who's
going twice the speed or 20
m/s and you can guess if he's going
twice the speed and time is a constant
then he's going to go twice the distance
and that's easily to compute 36 * 2 you
get 72 kilm and so if you had the
question of how fast what somebody's
going three times that speed or 30 m/
second is you can easily compute the
distance in our head we can do that
without needing a computer but we want
to do this for more complicated data so
it's kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph so in a
linear regression model we have our
distance to the speed and we have our m
equals the ve slope of the line and
we'll notice that the line has a plus
slope and as speed increases distance
also increases hence the variables have
a positive relationship and so your
speed of the person which equals yal MX
plus C distance traveled in a fixed
interval of time and we could very
easily compute either following the line
or just knowing it's three times 10 m/s
that this is roughly 102 km distance
that this third bicep has traveled one
of the key definitions on here is POS
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive as distance
increase so does speed increase let's
take a look at our second example where
we put distance is a constant so we have
speed equals 10 m/ second they have a
certain distance to go and it takes them
100 seconds to travel that distance and
we have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 m/ second since he's going
twice the speed we can guess that he'll
cover the distance in about half the
time 50 seconds and of course you could
probably guess on the third one 100
divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you could easily guess
that this is
33333 seconds time we put that into a
linear regression model or a graph if
the distance is assumed to be constant
let's see the relationship between speed
and time and as time goes up the amount
of speed to go that same distance goes
down so now your m equals a minus ve
slope of the line as the speed increases
time decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this um and even a
significant amount of data Let's uh see
with the mathematical implementation of
linear regression and we'll take this
data so suppose we have this data set
where we have xyx = 1 2 3 4 5 standard
series and the Y value is 3
2243 when we take that and we go ahead
and plot these points on a graph you can
see there's kind of of a nice scattering
and you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it but we're going
to calculate that exact line for linear
regression and the first thing we do is
we come up here and we have the mean of
XI and remember mean is basically the
average so we added five plus 4 + 3+ 2 +
1 and divide by five and that simply
comes out as three and then we'll do the
same for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of I
equals 2. 8 where the XI references it's
an average or means value and the Yi
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in the Y = 2.8 and the xal 3 in there on
our graph we kind of gave it a little
different color so you could sort it out
with the dash lines on it and it's
important to note that when we do the
linear regression the linear regression
model should go through that dot now
let's find our regression equation to
find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our yal MX plus C so
we're looking for M and C so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of M and our coefficient
of c and we have y = mx + C where m
equals the sum of x - x average time y -
y aage or y means and X means over the
sum of x - x means squared that's how we
get the slope of the value of the line
and we can easily do that by creating
some columns here we have XY computers
are really good about iterating through
data and so we can easily compute this
and fill in a graph of data and in our
graph you can easily see that if we have
our x value of one and if you remember
the XI or the means value was three 1 -
3 equal a -2 and 2 - 3 = a -1 so on and
so forth and we can easily fill in the
column of x - x i y - Yi and then from
those we can compute x - x i^ 2 and x -
x i * y - Yi and you can guess it that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of 10 for our x -
x i^ 2 and a total of 2 for x - x i * y-
Yi and we plug those in we get 210 which
equals 0.2 so now we know the slope of
our line equals 0 2 so we can calculate
the value of c that'd be the next step
is we need to know where crosses the Y
AIS and if you remember I mentioned
earlier that the linear regression line
has to pass through the means value the
one that we showed earlier we can just
flip back up there to that graph and you
can see right here there's our means
value which is 3 xal 3 and yal 2.8 and
since we know that value we can simply
plug that into our formula y = 2x+ c so
we plug that in we get 2.8 = 2 * 3 + C
and you can just solve for C so now we
know that our coefficient equals 2.2 and
once we have all that we can go ahead
and plot our regression line Y = 2 * x +
2.2 and then from this equation we can
compute new values so let's predict the
values of Y using xal 1 2 3 4 5 and plot
the points remember the 1 2 3 45 was our
original X values so now we're going to
see what y thinks they are not what they
actually are and we plug those in we get
y of designated with Y of P you can see
that x = 1 = 2.4 x = 2 = 2.6 and so on
and so on so we have our y predicted
values of what we think it's going to be
when we plug those numbers in and when
we plot the predicted values along with
the actual values we can see the
difference and this is one of the things
is very important with linear regression
in any of these models is to understand
the error and so we can calculate the
error on all of our different values and
you can see over here we plot did um X
and Y and Y predict and we drawn a
little line so you can sort of see what
the error looks like there between the
different points so our goal is to
reduce this error we want to minimize
that error value on our linear
regression model minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc we keep moving this line through the
data points to make sure the best fit
line has the least Square distance
between the data points and the
regression line so to recap with a very
simple linear regression model we first
figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
Dimensions y = mx plus C but you can
take that out to x z i j Q all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems in the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree-shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spread sheet you
can see we have the Outlook whether it's
a rainy overcast Sunny temperature hot
mild cool humidity windy and did I like
to play golf that day yes or no so we're
taking a census and certainly I wouldn't
want a computer telling me when I should
go play golf or not but you could
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would uh fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next uh whatever you
know next mail out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in and so we
come up and let's uh determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our nor normal which is if
it's if you have a normal humidity
you're going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the Outlook and if the Outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf cuz you're going to be out there
miserable fighting off the mosquitoes
that are out joining you to play golf
with you maybe if it's rainy you
probably don't want to play in the rain
but if it's slightly overcast and you
get just the right Shadow that's a a
good day to play golf and be outside out
on the green now in this example you can
probably make your own tree pretty
easily CU it's a very simple set of data
going in but the question is how do you
know what to split where do you split
your data what if this is much more
complicated data where it's not
something that you would particularly
understand like studying cancer they
take about 36 measurements of the
cancerous cells and then each one of
those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but so that's the question is going
to come up is this the right decision
tree for that we should calculate
entropy and Information Gain two
important vocabulary words there are the
entropy and the Information Gain entropy
entropy is a measure of Randomness or
impurity in the data set entropy should
be low so we want the chaos to be as low
as possible possible we don't want to
look at it and be confused by the images
or what's going on there with mixed data
and the Information Gain it is a measure
of decrease in entropy after the data
set is split also known as entropy
reduction Information Gain should be
high so we want our information that we
get out of the split to be as high as
possible let's take a look at entropy
from the mathematical side in this case
we're going to denote entropy as I of P
of and n where p is the probability that
you're going to play a game of golf and
N is the probability where you're not
going to play the game of golf now you
don't really have to memorize these
formulas there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log s of P Over p+ N minus n / p+ n *
the log s of n of p plus n in but let's
break that down and see what actually
looks like when we're Computing that
from the computer script side enterp of
a target class of the data set is the
whole entropy so we have entropy play
golf and we look at this if we go back
to the data you can simply count how
many yeses and no in our complete data
set for playing golf days in our
complete set we find we have five days
we did play golf and nine days we did
not play golf and so our I equals if you
had those together 9 + 5 is 14 and so
our I equals 5 over 14 and 9 over 14
that's our p and N values that we plug
into that formula and you can go 5 over
14 = 36 9 over 14 = 64 and when you do
the whole equation you get the minus. 36
logun SAR of 36 -64 log sarun of 64 and
we get a set value we get
.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf in the Outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have P of
Sunny Times e of three of two and that
just comes out how many sunny days yes
and how many sunny days no over the
total which is five don't forget to put
the we'll divide that five out later on
equals P overcast = 4 comma 0 plus rainy
= 2A 3 and then when you do the whole
setup we have 5 over 14 remember I said
there was a total of five 5 over 14 *
the I of 3 of 2 + 4 over 14 times the 4
comma 0 and 514 over I of 23 and so we
can now compute the entp of just the
part it has to do with the forecast and
we get 693 similarly we we can calculate
the entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain Outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf Outlook and
we can take the original 0.94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
um rainy day in temperature and we end
up with a gain of. 247 so this is our
Information Gain remember we Define
entropy and we Define Information Gain
the higher the Information Gain the
lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way so we have our gain for temperature
equal
0.029 we have our gain for humidity
equals 0.152 and our gain for a windy
day equals
048 and if you do a quick comparison
you'll see the. 247 is the greatest gain
of information so that's the split we
want now let's build the decision tree
so we have the Outlook is it going to be
sunny overcast or rainy that's our first
split because that gives us the most
Information Gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest Information
Gain as the root node and then continue
to split each subn node with the largest
Information Gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our Outlook we split it three
different directions if the Outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the over Outlook is sunny but then
it's also windy if it's uh windy we're
not going to play if it's uh not windy
we'll play so we can easily build a nice
decision tree to guess what we would
like to do tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go Outlook sunny out look windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little Smartwatch pops up and says I'm
sorry tomorrow is not a good day for
golf it's going to be sunny and windy
and if you're a huge golf fan you might
go uhoh it's not a good day to play golf
we can go in and watch a golf game at
home so we'll sit in front of the TV
instead of being out playing golf in the
wind now that we looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
Vector machine support Vector machine is
a widely used Class ification algorithm
the idea of support Vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females a new data point arrives and
we want to know whether it's going to be
a male or a female so we start by
drawing a line we draw decision lines
but if we consider decision line one
then we will classify the individual as
a a male and if we consider decision
line two then it will be a female so you
can see this person kind of lies in the
middle of the two groups it's a little
confusing trying to figure out which
line they should be under we need to
know which line divides the classes
correctly but how the goal is to choose
a hyperplane and that is one of the key
words they use when we talk about
support Vector machines choose a
hyperplane with the greatest possible
margin between the decision line and the
nearest Point within the training set so
you can see here we have our support
Vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyper plane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equally distant between the two um
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line one has a maximum
distance margin so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and a result on
this one is going to be that the new
data point is Mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line is
that a lot of times we're not looking at
just weight and height we might be
looking at 36 different features or
dimensions and so when we cut it with a
hyper plane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data or
multi-dimensional it cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example
problem statement I always start with a
problem statement when you're going to
put some code together we're going to do
some coding now classifying muffin and
cupcake recipes using support Vector
machines so the cupcake versus the
muffin let's have a look at our data set
and we have the different recipes here
we have a muffin recipe that has so much
flour I'm not sure what measurement 55
is in but it has 55 maybe it's
ounces but uh has a certain amount of
flour certain amount of milk sugar
butter egg baking powder vanilla and
salt and So based on these measurements
we want to guess whether we're making a
muffin or a cupcake and you can see in
this one we don't have just two features
we don't just have height and weight as
we did before between the male and
female in here we have a number of
features in fact in this we're looking
at eight different features to guess
whether it's a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour while cupcakes have more
butter and sugar so basically the
cupcakes a little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
Python how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and I really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in Python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just just has so much stuff attached to
it and it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda and jupyter notebook the
Anaconda Navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the Anaconda
Navigator you can change environments I
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python 36
environment so this is in Python version
36 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use use I usually try
to stay with the 3x cuz they're current
unless you have a project that's very
specifically in version 2x 27 I think is
usually what most people use in the
version two and then once we're in our
um Jupiter notebook editor I can go up
and create a new file and we'll just
jump in here in this case we're doing
spvm muffin versus Cupcake and then
let's start with our packages for data
analysis and we almost always use use a
couple there's a few very standard
packages we use we use import oops
import
numpy that's for number python they
usually denoted as NP that's very comma
that's very common and then we're going
to import pandas as
PD and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy uh setup as far as
multiplying all the values in an array
in an numpy array data array pandas I
can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set I think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a nump array is that a data frame is
more like your Excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes you have
different ways of referencing it easily
viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there and then finally
where working with the support Vector
machine so from sklearn we're going to
use the sklearn model import svm support
Vector
machine and then as a data scientist you
should always try to visualize your data
some data obviously is too complicated
or doesn't make any sense to the human
but if it's possible it's good to take a
second look at it so you can actually
see what you're doing now for that we're
going to use two packages we're going to
import import matplot library. pyplot as
PLT again very common and we're going to
import caborn as SNS and we'll go ahead
and set the font scale in the SNS right
in our import line that's with this um
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the SNS and these are
great because the the caborn sits on top
of map plot Library just like pandas
hits on numpy so it adds a lot more
features and uses and control we're
obviously not going to get get into
matplot library and caborn it' be its
own tutorial we're really just focusing
on the svm the support Vector machine
from skk learn and since we're in
Jupiter notebook uh we have to add a
special line in here for our met plot
library and that's your percentage sign
or Amber sign matap plot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code Project A lot of times I
use like notepad++ and I'll run it from
there you don't have to have that line
in there because it'll just pop up as
its own window on your computer
depending on how your computer set up
because we're running this in the
Jupiter notebook as a browser setup this
tells it to display all of our Graphics
right below on the page so that's what
that line is for remember the first time
I ran this I didn't know that and I had
to go look that up years ago was quite a
headache so map plot library in line is
just because we're running this on the
web setup and we can go ahead and run
this make sure all our modules are in
they're all imported which is great if
you don't have them import you'll need
to go ahead and pip use the PIP or
however you do it there's a lot of other
install packages out there although pip
is the most common and you have to make
sure these are all installed on your
python setup the next step of course is
we got to look at the data can't run a
model for predicting data if you don't
have actual data so to do that let me go
aad and open this up and take a look and
we have our uh cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a CS v file or CSV meaning that
it's comma separated
variable and it's going to open it up in
a nice uh spreadsheet for me and you can
see up here we have the type we have
muffin muffin muffin cupcake cupcake
cupcake and then it's broken up into
flour milk sugar butter egg baking
powder vanilla and salt so we can do is
we can go ahead and look at this data
also in our
python let us create a variable recipes
equals we're going to use our pandas
module. read CSV remember is a comma
separated
variable and the file name happened to
be cupcakes versus muffins oops I got
double brackets
there do it this
way there we go cupcakes versus
muffins because the program I loaded or
the the place I saved this particular
Python program is in the same folder we
can get by with just the file name but
remember if you're storing it in a
different location you have to also put
down the full path on
there and then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually in line you can do this but let
me do the full print you can just type
in recipes. head in the Jupiter notebook
but if you're running in code in a
different script youd need to go ahead
and type out the whole print recipes.
head and Panda knows is that's going to
do the first five lines of data and if
we flip back on over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our CSV
file uh you can see where it starts on
line two this one calls it zero and then
2 3 4 5 6 is going to match go and close
that out because we don't need that
anymore and it always starts at zero and
these are it automatically indexes it
since we didn't tell it to use an index
in here so that's the index number for
the left hand side and it AO Al took the
top row as uh labels so Panda's using it
to read a CSV is just really slick and
fast one of the reasons we love our
pandas not just because they're cute and
cuddly teddy
bears and let's go ahead and plot our
data and I'm not going to plot all of it
I'm just going to plot the uh sugar and
flour now obviously you can see where
they get really complicated if we have
tons of different features and so you'll
break them up and maybe look at just two
of them at a time to see how they
connect and to plot them we're going to
go ahead and use caborn so that's our
SNS and the command for that is SNS dolm
plot and then the two different
variables I'm going to plot is flour and
sugar data equals recipes the Hue equals
type and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in so
this is one of the powerful things about
pandas mixed with Seaborn and
doing
graphing and then we're going to use a
pallet set one there's a lot of
different sets in there you can go look
them up for Seaborn we do a regular a
fit regular equals false so we're not
really trying to fit anything and it's a
scatter
kws a lot of these settings you can look
up in Seaborn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a Seaborn plot let's go ahead and
run that and because it does it in line
it just puts it right on the
page and you can see right here that
just based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split and we use
these models because you can actually
look at it and say hey if I drew a line
right between the middle of the blue
dots and the red dots we'd be able to do
an svm and and a hyperplane right there
in the middle
then the next step is to format or
pre process our
data and we're going to break that up
into two
parts we need to type label and remember
we're going to decide whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake well a computer
doesn't know muffin or cupcake it knows
zero and one so what we're going to do
is we're going to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
in P where and this is where we can do
some logic we take our recipes from our
Panda and wherever type equals muffin
it's going to be zero and then if it
doesn't equal muffin which is cupcakes
is going to be one so we create our type
label this is the answer so when we're
doing our training model remember we
have to have a a training data this is
what we're going to train it with is
that it's zero or one it's a muffin or
it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features and if you remember correctly
from right up here the First Column is
type so we really don't need the type
column because that's our muffin or
cupcake and in pandas we can easily sort
that
out we take our value
recipes do columns that's a pandas
function built into
pandas got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top and we don't want
the first one so what we do is since it
always starts at zero we want
one colon till the
end and then we want to go ahead and
make this a list and this converts it to
a list of
strings and then we can go ahead and
just take a look and see what we're
looking at for the features make sure it
looks right me go ahead and run that
and I forgot the S on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg baking powder
vanilla and salt and that matches what
we have up here where we printed out
everything but the type so we have our
features and we have our
label Now the recipe features is just a
titles of the columns and we actually
need the
ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could rent it over all
the
ingredients and when you're doing this
usually you do but for our example we
want to limit it so you can easily see
what's going on because if we did all
the ingredients we have you know that's
what um seven eight different
hyperplanes that would be built into it
we only want to look at one so you can
see what the svm is
doing and so we'll take our recipes and
we'll do just flour and sugar again you
can replace that with your recipe
features and do all of them but we're
going to do just flour and sugar and
we're going to convert that to values we
don't need to make a list out of it
because it's not string values these are
actual values on there and we can go
ahead and just
print ingredients and you can see what
that looks
like uh and so we have just the n oflow
and sugar just the two sets of
plots and just for fun let's go ahead
and take this over here and take our
recipe
features and so if we decided to use all
the recipe features you'll see that it
makes a nice column of different data so
it just strips out all the labels and
everything we just have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flour
and
sugar and we'll run that and you'll see
it's just the two
columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our
model we'll go a and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called
SVC in this case we're going to go ahead
and set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the
svm you'll see that there's about
there's eight of them here three of them
are for regression three re are for
classification the SVC support Vector
classification is probably one of the
most commonly used and then there's also
one for detecting outliers and another
one that has to do with something a
little bit more specific on the model
but SBC and SV are the two most commonly
used standing for support vector
classifier and support Vector regression
remember regression is an actual value a
float value or whatever you're trying to
work on and SBC is a classifier so it's
a yes know true
false but for this we want to know 01
muffin cupcake we go ahead and create
our model and once we have our model
created we're going to do model. fit and
this is very common especially in the
sklearn all their models are followed
with the fit
command and what we put into the fit
what we're training with it is we're
putting in the ingredients which in this
case we limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into a
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
where you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that and gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data and let's go ahead and run this and
now we have our model fit and I got a
error here so let me fix that real quick
it's Capital SVC it turns
out I did it
lowercase support
Vector classifier there we go let's go
ahead and run that and you'll see it
comes up with all this information that
it prints out automatically these are
the defaults of the model you notice
that we changed the kernel to linear and
there's our kernel linear on the
printout and there's other different
settings you can mess
with we're going to just leave that
alone for right now for this we don't
really need to mess with any of
those so next we're going to dig a
little bit into our newly trained model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a
graph and let's go ahead and get the
separating and we're going to say we're
going to use a W for our variable on
here we're going to do model
.
coefficient 0 so what the heck is that
again we're digging into the model so
we've already got a prediction and a
train this is a math behind it that
we're looking at right now and
so the W is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had yal mx + C so these
coefficients are connected to that but
in two-dimensional it's a plane we don't
want to spend too much time on this
because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math so if you're a
math Wiz this is great you can go
through here and you'll see that we have
AAL minus w0 over W of 1 remember
there's two different values there and
that's basically the slope that we're
generating and then we're going to build
an XX what is XX we're going to set it
up to a numpy array there's our np.
linespace so we're creating a
line of values between 30 and 60 so it
just creates a set of numbers for
x and then if you remember correctly we
have our formula y equal the slope X
X Plus The Intercept well to make this
work we can do this as y y equals the
slope times each value in that array
that's the neat thing about numpy so
when I do a time XX which is a whole
numpy array of values it multiplies a
across all of them and then it takes
those same values and we subtract the
model intercept that's your uh we had MX
plus C so that'd be the C from the
formula yal MX plus
C and that's where all these numbers
come from a little bit confusing because
it's digging out of these different
arrays and then we want to do is we're
going to take this and we're going to go
ahead and plot it so plot the parallels
to separating hyper plane that pass
through the support vectors and so we're
going to create b equals a model support
vectors pulling our support vectors out
there here's our YY which we now know is
a set of data and we have we're going to
create YY down equal a * XX + B1 - A * B
0 and then model support Vector B is
going to be set that to a new value the
minus one setup and y y up equals = a *
XX + B1 - A * B 0 and we can go ahead
and just run this to load these
variables up if you want to know
understand a little bit more of what's
going on you can see if we
print y y we just run that you can see
it's an array it's this is a line it's
going to have in this case between 30
and 60 so it's going to be 30 variables
in here and the same thing with y y up y
y down and we'll we'll plot those in
just a minute on a graph so you can see
what those look
like just go ahead and delete that out
of here and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate I'm just
going to copy this from before remember
this our SNS our caborn plot LM plot
flow
sugar and I'll just go and run that real
quick so you can see what remember what
that looks like it's just a straight
graph on
there and then one of the ne things is
because caborn sits on top of P plot
we can do the P plot for the line going
through and that is simply PLT do
plot and that's our xx and y y our two
corresponding values XY and then
somebody played with this to figure out
that the line width equals two and the
color black would look nice so let's go
ahead and run this whole thing with the
PIP plot on there and you can see when
we do this it's just doing flour and
sugar on
here corresponding line between the
sugar and the flour and the muffin
versus
Cupcake um and then we generated the um
support vectors the y y down and y y up
so let's take a look and see what that
looks
like so we'll do our P
plot and again this is all against XX
the our x value but this time we have y
y
down and let's do something a little fun
with this we can put in a k dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line and if we're going to do the down
one we also want to do the up one so
here's our y
y up and when we run that it adds both
sets
aligned and so here's our support and
this is what you expect you expect these
two lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dash lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cup cake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour which one's a muffin or
a
cupcake let's go ahead and create a
function to
predict muffin or
cupcake I've got my um recipes I pulled
off the um internet and I want to see
the difference between a muffin or a
cupcake and so we need a function to
push that through and create a function
with
deaf and let's call it muffin or cupcake
and remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients to know it's flour
and
sugar and let's go ahead and do an F
statement so if model
predict is a flour and sugar equals z so
we take our model and we do run a
predict it's very common in sklearn
where you have a DOT predict you put the
data in and it's going to return a value
in this case if it equals zero then
print you're looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe that's pretty straightforward
for function or def for definition DF is
how you do that in Python and of course
if you're going to create a function you
should should run something in it and so
let's run a cupcake and we're going to
send it values 50 and 20 a muffin or
cupcake I don't know what it is and
let's run this and just see what it
gives us and it says oh it's a muffin
you're looking at a muffin recipe so it
very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's plot this there we go plot this on
the graph so we can see what that
actually looks like and I'm just going
to copy and paste it from below where we
plotting all the points in there
so this is nothing different than what
we did before if I run it you'll see it
has all the points and the lines on
there and what we want to do is we want
to add another point and we'll do PLT
plot and if you remember correctly we
did for our test we did 50 and
20 and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do yo for yellow or it's
kind of a orangest yellow color is going
to come out marker size nine those are
settings you can play with somebody else
played with with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good and you
can see there it is graph um clearly a
muffin and this case in cupcakes versus
muffins the muffin has won and if you'd
like to do your own muffin cupcake
Contender series you certainly can send
a note down below and the team at simply
learn will send you over the data they
use for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data um we
didn't actually run a plot on it earlier
here we had men versus women you can
also request that information to run it
on your data setup so you can test that
out so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support Vector machine
code we did a predict 40 Parts flower 20
part sugar I think it was different than
the one we did whether it's a muffin or
a cupcake hence we have built a
classifier using SPM which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin today in our second
tutorial we're going to cover K means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had during
our first tutorial what's in it for you
we're going to cover clustering what is
clustering K means clustering which is
one of the most common used clustering
tools out there including a flowchart to
understand K means clustering and how
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands then we're going to
cover logistic regression what is
logistic regression logistic regression
curve in sigmoid function and then we'll
do another python code demo to classify
a tumor as malignant or benign based on
features and let's start with clustering
suppose we have a pile of books of
different genres now we divide them into
different groups like fiction horror
education and as we can see from this
young lady she definitely is into heavy
you can just tell by those eyes in
the maple Canadian leaf on her shirt but
we have fiction horror and education and
we want to go ahead and divide our books
up well organizing objects into groups
based on similarity is clustering and in
this case as we're looking at the books
we're talking about clustering things
with no one categories but you can also
use it to explore data so you might not
know the categories you just know that
you need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case uh we're going
to be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use K means
clustering K means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library K means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to Cluster into different
groups Define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an unanswer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and horror and history books but
a lot of times with data some of that
information isn't so easy to see right
when we first look at it and so K means
is one of those tools where we can start
finding things it connect that match
with each other suppose we have these
data points and want to assign them into
a cluster now when I look at these data
points I would probably group them into
two clusters just by looking at them I'd
say two of these group of data kind of
come together but in K means we pick K
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the K clusters represents
two different clusters we pick K
clusters inside random centroids to the
Clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances and
calculate the centroids so we figure out
what the best distances for the centroid
then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing their
positions and become Static repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing and the
positions become Static once the
Clusters become Static then K means
clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's conversed on an
answer shall we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy step by
step so we start we choose K we'll look
at the elbow method in just a moment we
assign random centroids to clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a in a
graph and say ah these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids we take that and we form new
clusters based on minimum distance and
calculate their centroids then we
compute the distance from objects to the
new centroids and then we go back and
repeat those last two steps we calculate
the distances so as we're doing it it
brings into the new centroid and then we
move the centroid around and we figure
out what the best which objects are
closest to each centroid so the objects
can switch from one centroid to the
other as the centroids are moved around
and we continue that until it is
converged let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics A and B so here's our subject in
this case referring to the person taking
the uh test and then we have subject a
where we see what they've scored on
their first subject and we have subject
B and we can see what they score on the
second subject now let's take two
farthest apart points as initial cluster
centroids now remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points one and one and
five and seven and now let's take the
two farthest apart points as initial
cluster centroids each point is then
assigned to the closest cluster with
respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
you can see that if we measured each of
those distances and you use the
Pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the X and the
Y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster uh the centroid
then moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3
so remember it was at one and one well
the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 22 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the
second one if we wanted to make the
overall mean Vector the average Vector
of all the different distances to that
centroid we come up with 4 comma 1 and
54 so we've now moved the centroids We
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and to the that of
the opposite cluster and we find can
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move that centr around we now have a
new different kind of clustering of
groups and using ukian distance between
the points and the mean we get the same
formula you see new formulas coming up
so we have our individual dots distance
to the mean centr of the cluster and
distance to the mean centr of the
cluster only individual three is nearer
to the mean of the opposite cluster
cluster two than its own cluster one and
you can see here in the diagram where
we've kind of circled that one in the
middle so when we've moved the clust the
centroids of the Clusters over one of
the points shifted to the other cluster
because it's closer to that group of
individuals thus individual 3 is
relocated to Cluster 2 resulting in a
new Partition and we regenerate all
those numbers of how close they are to
the different clusters for the new
clusters we will find the actual cluster
centroids so now we move the centroids
over and you can see that we've now
formed two very distinct clusters on
here on comparing the distance of each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean and to that of the opposite cluster
we find that the data points are stable
hence we have our final clusters now if
you remember I brought up a concept
earlier k mean on the K means algorithm
choosing the right value of K will help
in less number of iterations and to find
the appropriate number of clusters in a
data set we use the elbow method and
within sum of squares WSS is defined as
the sum of the squared distance between
each member of the cluster in its
centroid and so you see we've done here
is we have the number of clusters and as
you do the same K means algorithm over
the different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow of the graph is called as the
elbow method and on this we guessed at
two just by looking at the data but as
you can see the slope you actually just
look for right there where the elbow is
in the slope and you have a clear answer
that we want two different
to start with k means equals 2 A lot of
times people end up Computing K means
equals 2 3 4 5 until they find the value
which fits on the elbow joint sometimes
you can just look at the data and if
you're really good with that specific
domain remember domain I mentioned that
last time you'll know that that where to
pick those numbers or where to start
guessing at what that K value is so
let's take this and we're going to use a
use case using K means clustering to
Cluster cars into Brands using
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year Etc so we're going to
use the data set cars data having
information about three brands of cars
Toyota Honda and Nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the Anaconda Navigator
with the Jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter
notebook and in our Jupiter notebook I'm
going to go ahead and just paste the uh
basic code that we usually start a lot
of these off with we're not going to go
too much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
numpy being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and mat plot
for the graphing and don't forget uh
since if you're using the Jupiter
notebook you do need the matplot library
in line so that it plots everything on
the screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a popup
window on your computer and we'll go
ahead and run this just to load our
libraries and our setup into here the
next step is of course to look at our
data which I've already opened up in a
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
the miles per gallon cylinders cubic
inches horsepower weight pounds how you
know how heavy it is time it takes to
get to 60 my card is probably on this
one at about 80 or 90 what year it is so
this is you can actually see this is
kind of older cars and then the brand
Toyota Honda Nissan so the different
cars are coming from all the way from
1971 if we scroll down to uh the 80s we
have between the 70s and 80s a number of
cars that they've put out and let's uh
when we come back here we're going to do
importing the data so we'll go ahead and
do data set equals and we'll use pandas
to read this in and it's a from a CSV
file remember you can always post this
in the comments and request the data
files for these either in the comments
here on the YouTube video or go to
Simply learn.com and request that the
car CSV I put it in the same folder as
the code that I've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so I
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and uh We've chosen data
set arbitrarily because you know it's a
data set we're importing and we've now
imported our car CSV into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the X data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there is a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple Loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
for i n x. columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns and a lot of
times it's important I I'll make lists
of the columns and do this because I
might remove certain columns or there
might be columns that I want to be
processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take X of I and we want
to go fill in and that's a panda's
command but the question is what are we
going to fill the missing data with we
definitely don't want to just put in a
number that doesn't actually mean
something and so one of the tricks you
can do with this is we can take X of I
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into an integer
because a lot of these are integers so
we'll go ahead and keep it integers and
me add the bracket here and a lot of
editors will do this they'll think that
you're closing one bracket make sure you
get that second bracket in there if it's
a double bracket that's always something
that happens regularly so once we have
our integer of X of Y this is going to
fill in any missing data with the
average and I was so busy closing one
set of brackets I forgot that the mean
is also has brackets in there for the
pandas so we can see here we're going to
fill in all the data with the average
value for that column so if there's
missing data it's in the average of the
data it does have then once we've done
that we'll go ahead and loop through it
again and just check and see to make
sure everything is filled in correctly
and we'll print and then we take X is
null and this returns a set of the null
value or the how many lines are null and
we'll just sum that up to see what that
looks like and so when I run this and so
with the X what we want to do is we want
to remove the last column because that
had the models that's what we're trying
to see if we can cluster these things
and figure out the models there is so
many different ways to sort the X out
for one we could take the X and we could
go data set our variable we're using and
use the iocation one of the features
that's in pandas and we could take that
and then take all the rows and all but
the last column of the data set and at
this time we could do values we just
convert it to values so that's one way
to do this and if I let me just put this
down here and print X it's a capital x
we chose and I run this you can see it's
just the values we could also take out
the values and it's not going to return
anything because there's no values
connected to it what I like to do with
this is instead of doing the iocation
which does integers more common is to
come in here and we have our data set
and we're going to do data set dot or
data set. columns and remember that
lists all the columns so if I come in
here let me just Mark that as red and I
print data set.
columns you can see that I have my index
here I have my MPG cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data Columns of Everything But
the last one minus one so now if I print
this you'll see the brand disappears and
so I can actually just take data set
columns minus
one and I'll put it right in here for
the columns we're going to look
at and let's unmark this and unmark
this and now if I do an X do head I now
have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year and it turns out when you
start playing with the data set you're
going to get an error later on and it'll
say cannot convert string to uh float
value and that's because for some reason
these things the way they recorded them
must have been recorded as strings so we
have a neat feature in here on pandas to
convert and it is simply convert object
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert
underscore numeric numeric equals true
and yes I did have to go look that up I
don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if I'm working with a
lot of these things I remember them but
um depending on where I'm at what I'm
doing I usually have to look it up and
we run that oops I must have missed
something in here let me double check my
spelling and when I double check my
spelling you'll see I missed the first
underscore in the convert objects and
when I run this it now has everything
converted into a numeric value because
that's what we're going to be working
with is numeric values down
here and the next part is that we need
to go through the data and eliminate
null values most people when they're
doing small amounts working with small
data pools discover afterwards that they
have a null value and they have to go
back and do this so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it and that's
fine that's just part of exploring the
data and understanding what you
have and I should have done this earlier
but let me go ahead and increase the
size of my window one
notch there we go easier to
see so we'll do 4 I in working with x.
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take X of I and
we're going to change that we're going
to alter it and so with this we want to
go ahead and fill in X of I pandis Has
The Fill
Na and that just fills in any
non-existent missing data and we'll put
my brackets up and there's a lot of
different ways to fill this data if you
have a really large data set some people
just void out that data because if and
then look at it later in a separate uh
exploration of data one of the tricks we
can do is we can take our column and we
can find the
means and the means is in our our
quotation marks so when we take the
columns we're going to fill in the the
non-existing one with the means the
problem is that returns a decimal float
so some of these aren't decimals
certainly need to be a little careful of
doing this but for this example we're
just going to fill it in with the
integer version of this keeps it on par
with the other data that isn't a decimal
point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check A lot of times you
do this first part first to double check
then you do the fill and then you do it
again just to make sure you did it right
so we're going to go through and test
for missing data and one of the re ways
you can do that is simply go in here and
take our X of I column so it's going to
go through the x of I column it says is
null so it's going to return any any
place there's a null value it actually
goes through the all the rows of each
column is null and then we want to go
ahead and sum that so we take that we
add the sum value and these are all
pandas so is NS a panda command and so
is some and if we go through that and we
go ahead and run
it and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data and at this point we're actually
going to start using the elbow method to
find the optimal number of clusters so
we're now actually getting into the SK
learn part uh the K means clustering on
here I guess we'll go ahead and zoom it
up one more notot so you can see what
I'm typing in
here and then from sklearn going to or
sklearn cluster I'm going to import K
means I always forget to capitalize the
K and the M when I do this as say
capital K capital M K
means and we'll go and create a um array
wcss equals let me get an empty array if
you remember from the elbow method from
our
slide within the sums of squares WSS is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and
it's centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a square
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of K mean
values in fact let's go for I in range
we'll do 11 of
them range 0 of
11 and the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to create the actual
we'll do it all lower
case and so we're going to create this
object from the K means that we just
imported and the variable that we want
to put into this is in clusters and
we're going to set that equals to I
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters changes our answer
there are a lot of settings to the K
means our guys in the back did a great
job just kind of playing with some of
them the most common common ones that
you see in a lot of stuff is how you
init your K means so we have K means
plus plus plus this is just a tool to
let the model itself be smart how it
picks its centroids to start with its
initial centroids we only want to
iterate no more than 300 times we have a
Max iteration we put in there we have an
the infinit the random State equals zero
you really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this as you start digging in deeper you
start finding that these are shortcuts
that will speed up the process as far as
a setup but the big one that we're
working with is the in clusters equals I
so we're going to literally train our K
means 11 times we're going to do this
process 11 times and if you're working
with uh Big Data you know the first
thing you do is you run a small sample
of the data so you can test all your
stuff on it and you can already see the
problem that if I'm going to iterate
through a terabyte of data 11 times and
then K means itself is iterating through
the data multiple times that's a heck of
a process so you got to be a little
careful with this a lot of times though
you can find your elbow using the elbow
method find your optimal number on a
sample of data especially if you're
working with larger data sources so we
want to go ahead and take our K means
and we're just going to fit it if you're
looking at any of the SK learn very
common you fit your model and if you
remember correctly our variable we're
using is the capital x and once we fit
this value we go back to the um array we
made and we want to go and just to pin
that value on the
end and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so K means. inertia will
pull that specific value out that we
need and let's get a visual on this
we'll do our PLT plot and what we're
plotting
here is first the xaxis which is range 0
11 11 so that will generate a nice
little plot there and the wcss for our Y
axis it's always nice to give our plot a
title and let's see we'll just give it
the elbow method for the title and let's
get some labels so let's go ahead and do
PLT X
label and what we'll do we'll do number
of clusters for that and PLT y
label and for that we can do oops there
we go wcss since that's what we're doing
on the plot on there and finally we want
to go ahead and display our graph which
is simply PLT do
oops. show there we go and because we
have it set to inline it'll appear in
line hopefully I didn't make a type
error on
there and you can see we get a very nice
graph you can see a very nice elbow
joint there at uh two and again right
around three and four and then after
after that there's not very much now as
a data scientist if I was looking at
this I would do either three or four and
I'd actually try both of them to see
what the um output looked like and
they've already tried this in the back
so we're just going to use three as a
setup on here and let's go ahead and see
what that looks like when we actually
use this to show the different kinds of
cars and so let's go ahead and apply the
K means to the car's data set and
basically we're going to copy the code
that we looped through up above where K
means equals K means number of clusters
and we're just going to set that number
of clusters to three since that's what
we're going to look for and you could do
three and four on this and graph them
just to see how they come up
differently' be kind of curious to look
at that but for this we're just going to
set it to three go ahead and create our
own variable y k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there to K means
but we're not not going to do a fit
we're going to do a fit predict is the
setup you want to use and when you're
using untrained models you'll see um a
slightly different usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the K means
on this and that's fitcore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working
with and before we plot this data we're
going to do a little pandas trick we're
going to take our x value and we're
going to set X as Matrix so we're
converting this into a nice rows and
columns kind of set up but we want the
we're going to have columns equals none
so it's just going to be a matrix of
data in here and let's go ahead and run
that a little warning you'll see These
Warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions instead of Matrix now that it's
more common to set ITV values instead of
doing as Matrix but M Matrix works just
fine for right now and you'll want to
update that later on but let's go ahead
and dive in and plot this and see what
that looks like and before we dive into
plotting this data I always like to take
a look and see what I am plotting so
let's take a look at y k means I'm just
going to print that out down here and we
see we have an array of answers we have
2 1 0 2 one two so it's clustering these
different rows of data based on the
three different spaces it thinks it's
going to
be and then let's go ahead and print X
and see what we have for x and we'll see
that X is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first two or positions
zero and
one and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting you might actually do a little
different and and dig a little deeper
into the different aspects because this
is all the different columns we looked
at but we only look at columns one and
two for this to make it easy so let's go
ahead and clear this data out of here
and let's bring up our plot and we're
going to do a scatter plot here so PLT
scatter
and this looks a little complicated so
let's explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the X
values and we're only interested in y of
K means equals zero the first cluster
okay and then we're going to take value
zero for the x-axis and then we're going
to do the same thing here we're only
interested in K means equals zero but
we're going to take the second column so
we're only looking at the first two
columns in our answer or in the data and
then the guys in the back played with
this a little bit to make it
pretty and they discovered that it looks
good with as a size equals 100 that's
the size of the dots we're going to use
red for this one and when they were
looking at the data and what came out it
was definitely the Toyota on this we're
just going to go ahead and label it
Toyota again that's something you really
have to explore in here as far as
playing with those numbers and see what
looks good we'll go ahead and hit enter
in there and I'm just going to paste in
the next two lines which is the next two
cars and this is our Nissa and Honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where Yore K means equals
1 and we want the Z column and y k means
equals 2 again we're looking at just the
first two columns zero and one and each
of these rows then corresponds to Nissan
and
Honda and I'll go ahead and hit enter on
there and uh finally let's take a look
and put the centroids on there again
we're going to do a scatter
plot and on the centroids you can just
pull that from our K means the uh model
we created dot cluster centers and we're
going to just do um
all of them in the first number and all
of them in the second number which is 0o
one because you always start with zero
and
one and then they were playing with the
size and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them so it's good to have some good
labels
centroids and then we do want to do a
title PLT
title and pop up there PLT title so you
always make want to make your look
pretty we'll call it clusters of car
make and one of the features of the plot
library is you can add a legend it'll
automatically bring in it since we've
already labeled the different aspects of
the legend with Toyota Nissan and
Honda and finally we want to go ahead
and show so we can actually see it and
remember it's in line uh so if you're
using a different editor that's not the
Jupiter notebook you'll get a popup of
this and you should have a nice set set
of clusters here so we can look at this
and we have a clusters of Honda and
green Toyota and red Nissan and purple
and you can see where they put the
centroids to separate
them now when we're looking at this we
can also plot a lot of other different
data on here as far because we only
looked at the first two columns this is
just column one and two or 01 as as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have a nice clusters of
Carm make and we' able to pull out the
data and you can see how just these two
columns form very distinct clusters of
data so if you were exploring new data
you might take a look and say well what
makes he's different almost going in
reverse you start looking at the data
and pulling apart the columns to find
out why is the first group set up the
way it is maybe you're doing loans and
you want to go well why is this group
not defaulting on their loans and why is
the last group defaulting on their loans
and why is the middle group 50%
defaulting on their bank loans and you
start finding ways to manipulate the
data and pull out the answers you
want so now that you've seen how to use
K mean for clustering let's move on to
the next topic now let's look into
logistic regression the logistic
regression algorithm is the simplest
classification algorithm used for binary
or multiclassification problems and we
can see we have our little girl from
Canada who's into horror books is back
that's actually really scary when you
think about that with those big eyes in
the previous tutorial we learned about
linear regression dependent and
independent variables so to brush up y
equals MX plus C very basic algebraic
function of Y and X the dependent
variable is the target class variable we
are going to predict the independent
variables X1 all the way up to xn are
the features or attributes we're going
to use to predict the target class we
know what a linear regression looks like
but using the graph we cannot divide the
outcome into categories it's really hard
to categorize 1.5 3.6 9.8 uh for example
a linear regression graph can tell us
that with increase in number of hours
studied the marks of a student will
increase but it will not tell us whether
the student will pass or not in such
cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y =
mx + C and when we use the sigmoid
function we have P = 1/ 1 + eus y it
generates a sigmoid curve and so you can
see right here when you take the Ln
which is the natural logarithm I always
thought it should be n l not Ln that's
just the inverse of uh e here e to Theus
Y and so we do this we get Ln of p over
1 - p = m * x + C that's the sigmoid
curve function we're looking for and we
can zoom in on the function and you'll
see that the function as it deres goes
to one or to zero depending on what your
x value is and the probability if it's
greater than 0.5 the value is
automatically rounded off to one
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass
then you have a threshold value at the 0
five it automatically puts that right in
the middle usually and your probability
if it's less than 0. five the value
rented off to zero indicating the
student will fail so if they're not
studying very hard they're probably
going to fail this of course is ignoring
the outliers of that one student who's
just a natural genius and doesn't need
any studying to memorize everything
that's not me unfortunately have to
study hard to learn new stuff problem
statement to classify whether a tumor is
malignant or benign
and this is actually one of my favorite
data sets to play with because it has so
many features and when you look at them
you really are hard to understand you
can't just look at them and know the
answer so it gives you a chance to kind
of dive into what data looks like when
you aren't able to understand the
specific domain of the data but I also
want you to remind you that in the
domain of medicine if I told you that my
probability was really good it
classified things that say 90% or 95%
and I'm classified in whether you're
going to have a malignant or a B9 tumor
I'm guessing that you're going to go get
it tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with so why
would you want to do that if you know
you're just going to go get a biopsy
because you know it's that serious this
is like an all or nothing just
referencing the domain it's important it
might help the doctor know where to look
just by understanding what kind of tumor
it is so it might help them or Aid them
in something they missed from before so
let's let's go ahead and dive into the
code and I'll come back to the domain
part of it in just a minute so use case
and we're going to do our normal Imports
here we're importing numpy Panda Seaborn
the matplot library and we're going to
do matplot library in line since I'm
going to switch over to Anaconda so
let's go ahead and flip over there and
get this started so I've opened up a new
window in my anaconda Jupiter
notebook by the way jupyter notebook uh
you don't have to use Anaconda for the
Jupiter notebook I just love the
interface and all the tools Anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as in
P for our numpy number array we have our
pandas PD we're going to bring in caborn
to help us with our graphs as SNS so
many really nice Tools in both caborn
and matplot library and we'll do our met
plot library. pyplot as PLT and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set
up and we're just going to call our data
data not creative today uh equals PD and
this happens to be in a CSV file so
we'll use a pd. read CSV and I happen to
name the file I renamed it data for
p2.png spreadsheet and this is just a
CSV file comma separate variables we
have an ID so I guess they um
categorizes for reference of what id
which test was done the diagnosis M for
malignant B for B9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m andb and test it and then we have
like the radius mean or average the
texture average perimeter mean area mean
smoothness I don't know about you but
unless you're a doctor in the field most
of the stuff I mean you can guess what
concave means just by the term concave
but I really wouldn't know what that
means in the measurements they're taking
so they have all kinds of stuff like how
smooth it is uh the Symmetry and these
are all float values we just page
through them real quick and you'll see
there's I believe 36 if I remember
correctly in this
one so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth so so back in our data
and I put this in the same folder as a
code so I saved this code in that folder
obviously if you have any different
location you want to put the full path
in there and we'll just do um
Panda's first five lines of data with
the data. head and we run that we can
see that we have pretty much what we
just looked at we have an ID we have a
diagnosis if we go all the way across
you'll see all the different columns
coming across displayed nicely for our
data and while we're exploring the data
our caborn which we referenced as
SNS makes it very easy to go in here and
do a joint plot you'll notice the very
similar to because it is sitting on top
of the um plot Library so the joint plot
does a lot of work for us and we're just
going to look at the first two columns
that we're interested in the radius mean
and the texture mean we'll just look at
those two columns and data equals data
so that tells it which two columns we're
plotting and that we're going to use the
data that we pulled in let's just run
that and it generates a really nice
graph on here and there's all kinds of
cool things on this graph to look at I
mean we have the texture mean and the
radius mean obviously the axes you can
also
see and one of the cool things on here
is you can also see the histogram they
show that for the radius mean where is
the most common radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is that's
looking at the tech the on each growth
its average texture and on each radius
its average uh radius on there guess a
little confusing because we're talking
about the individual objects average and
then we can also look over here and see
the the histogram showing us the median
or how common each measurement is and
that's only two columns so let's dig a
little deeper into Seaborn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat Maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map I guess the original ones
were plotting heat density on something
and so ever sens it's just called a heat
map and we're going to take our data and
get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map and that's simply
data. RR for that that's a pandas
expression remember we're working in a
pandas data frame so that's one of the
Cool Tools in pandas for our data and
this's just pull that information into a
heat map and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're we're now
looking at all the different features we
have our ID we have our texture we have
our area our compactness concave points
and if you look down the middle of this
chart diagonal going from the upper left
to bottom right it's all white that's
because when you compare texture to
texture they're identical so they're
100% or in this case perfect one in
their
correspondence and you'll see that when
you look at say area or right below it
it has almost a black on there when you
compare it to texture so these have
almost no corresponding data They Don't
Really form a linear graph or something
that you can look at and say how
connected they are they're very
scattered data this is really just a
really nice graph to get a quick look at
your data doesn't so much change what
you do but it changes verifying so when
you get an answer or something like that
or you start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not not correlate
with each other and if it is you're
going to have to start asking well why
what's going on what else is coming in
there but it does show some really cool
information on here mean we can see from
the ID there's no real one feature that
just says if you go across the top line
that lights up there's no one feature
that says hey if the area is a certain
size then it's going to be B9 or
malignant it says there's some that sort
of add up and that's a big hint in the
data that we're trying to ID this
whether it's malignant or B9 that's a
big hint to us as data scientist to go
okay we can't solve this with any one
feature it's going to be something that
includes all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data dois
null we want to check for null values in
our data if you remember from earlier in
this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we add added stuff up
and summ them up you can actually with
pandas do it really quickly data. is
null and Summit and it's going to go
across all the columns so when I run
this you're going to see all the columns
come up with no null
data so we've just just to reash these
last few
steps we've done a lot of exploration we
have looked at the first two columns and
seeing how they plot with the caborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram and the data plotted on the X
Y coordinates and obviously you can do
that more in detail with different
columns and see how they plot together
and then we took and did the Seaborn
heat map the SNS do heat map of the data
and you can see right here where it did
a nice job showing us some bright spots
where stuff correlates with each other
and forms a very nice combination or
points of scattering points and you can
also see areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on if you forget to do this step
it will remind you when you get that
nice error code that says null values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but it it's no fun having to go back
when you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you got to go
remember where you were pulling the data
in so we need to go ahead and pull out
our X and our y so we just put that down
here and we'll set the x equal to and
there's a lot of different options here
certainly we could do x equals all the
columns except for the first two because
if you remember the first two is the ID
and the diagnosis so that certainly
would be an option but what we're going
to do is we're actually going to focus
on the worst the worst radius the worst
texture parameter area smoothness
compactness and so on
one of the reasons to start dividing
your data up when you're looking at this
information is sometimes the data will
be the same data coming in so if I have
two measurements coming into my model it
might overweigh them it might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measur it's basically taking that
information in twice that's a little bit
past the scope of this tutorial I want
you to take away from this though is
that we are dividing the data up into
pieces and our team in the back went
ahead and said hey let's just look at
the work worst so I'm going to create a
an array and you'll see this array
radius worst texture worst perimeter
worst we've just taken the worst of the
worst and I'm just going to put that in
my X so this x is still a pandas data
frame but it's just those columns and
our y if you remember correctly is going
to be oops hold on one second it's not X
it's data there we go so x equals data
and then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst and if
we're going to take that then we have to
have our answer for our Y for the stuff
we know and if you remember correctly
we're just going to be looking
at the diagnosis that's all we care
about is what is it diagnosed is it Bine
or malignant and since it's a single
column we can just do diagnosis oh I
forgot to put the brackets the there we
go okay so it's just diagnosis on there
and we can also real quickly do like x.
head if you want to see what that looks
like and Y do head
and run this and you'll see um it only
does the last one I forgot about that if
you don't do print you can see that the
the Y do head is just Mmm because the
first ones are all malignant and if I
run this the x. head is just the first
five values of radius worst texture
worst parameter worst area worst and so
on I'll go ahead and take that out so
moving down to the next step we've built
our two data sets our answer and then
the features we want to look
at in data science it's very important
to test your
model so we do that by splitting the
data and from sklearn model selection
we're going to import train test split
so we're going to split it into two
groups there are so many ways to do this
I noticed in one of the more modern ways
they actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the sklearn
uh model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this where you just randomly
divide the data up into two groups but
they do it for us
nicely and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables capital x train capital X test
so we have our training data we're going
to use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model and we'll go ahead and
take our train test split that we just
imported and we're going to do X and our
y our two different data that's going in
for our split and then the guys in the
back came up and wanted us to go ahead
and use a test size equals. 3 that's
testore size random State it's always
nice to kind of switch to random State
around but not that important what this
means is that the test size is we're
going to take 30% of the data and we're
going to put that into our test
variables our y test and our X test and
we're going to do 70% into the X train
and the Y train so we're going to use
70% of the data to train our model and
30% to test it let's go ahead and run
that and load those up so now we have
all our stuff split up and all our data
ready to go now we get to the actual
Logistics part we're actually going to
do our create our model so let's go
ahead and bring that in from sklearn
we're going to bring in our linear model
and we're going to import logistic
regression that's the actual model we're
using and this we'll call it log
model the real model and let's just set
this equal to our logistic regression
that we just imported so now we have
variable log model set to that class for
us to use and with most the uh models in
the SK learn we just need to go ahead
and fix it fit do a fit on there and we
use our X train that we separated out
with our y train and let's go ahead and
run this so once we've run this we'll
have a model that fits this data that
70% of our training
data uh and of course it prints this out
that tells us all the different
variables that you can set on there
there's a lot of different choices you
can make but for word do we're just
going to let all the defaults set we
don't really need to mess with those on
this particular example and there's
nothing in here that really stands out
as super important until you start
fine-tuning it but for what we're doing
the basics will work just fine and then
let's we need to go ahead and test out
our model is it working so let's create
a variable y predict and this is going
to be equal to our log model and we want
to do a predict again very standard
format for the sklearn library is taking
your model and doing a predict on it and
we're going to test why predict against
the Y test so we want to know what the
model thinks it's going to be that's
what our y predict is and with that we
want the capital x x test so we have our
train set and our test set and now we're
going to do our y predict and let's go
ahead and run
that and if we uh
print y predict let me go ahead and run
that you'll see it comes up and it PRS a
prints a nice array of uh B and M for B9
and
malignant for all the different test
data we put in there so it does pretty
good we're not sure exactly how good it
does but we can see that it actually
works and it's functional was very easy
to create you'll always discover with
our data science that as you explore
this you spend a significant amount of
time prepping your data and making sure
your data coming in is good uh there's a
saying good data in good answers out bad
data in bad answers out that's only half
the thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using so
we come in here we want to know how good
this came out so we have our y predict
here log model. predict X
test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the sklearn docs
we're going to import classification
report and that just reports how good
our model is doing and then we're going
to feed it the uh model data and let's
just print this out and we'll take our
classification
report and we're going to put into
there our test our actual data so this
is what we actually know is true and and
our prediction what our model predicted
for that data on the test side and let's
run that and see what that
does so we pull that up you'll see that
we have um a Precision for B9 and
malignant B&M and we have a Precision of
93 a 91 a total of 92 so it's kind of
the average between these two of 92
there's all kinds of different
information on here your F1
score your recall your support coming
through on this and for this I'll go
ahead and just flip back to our slides
that they put together for describing it
and so here we're going to look at the
Precision using the classification
report and you see this is the same
print out I had up above some of the
numbers might be different because it
does randomly pick out which data we're
using so this model is able to predict
the type of tumor with
91% accuracy so we look back here that's
you will see where we have a B9 inant it
actually is 92 coming up here here but
we're looking about a 92 91% precision
and remember I reminded you about domain
so we're talking about the domain of a
medical domain with a very catastrophic
outcome you know at 91 or 92% Precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it very
different than if you're investing money
and there's a 92% chance you're going to
earn 10% and 8% chance you're going to
lose 8% you're probably going to bet the
money because at that odds it's pretty
good that you'll make make some money
and in the long run you do that enough
you definitely will make money and also
with this domain I've actually seen them
use this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate so that wraps up
this section we're finally we're going
to go in there and let's discuss the
anwers to the quiz asked in machine
learning tutorial part one can you tell
what's happening in the following cases
grouping documents into different
categories based on the topic and
content of each document this is an
example of clustering where K means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using bag of words
approach so if You' gotten in there that
you're looking for clustering and
hopefully you had at least one or two
examples like K means that are used for
clustering different things then give
yourself a two thumbs up B identifying
handwritten digits in images correctly
this is an example of classification the
traditional approach to solving this
would be to extract digit dependent
features like curvature of different
digits Etc and then use a classifier
like svm to distinguish between images
again if you got the fact that it's a
classification example give yourself a
thumb up and if you're able to go hey
let's use svm or another model for this
give yourself those two thumbs up on it
C behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed this
is an example of anomaly detection in
this case the algorithm learned what is
normal and what is not normal usually by
observing the logs of the website give
yourself a thumbs up if you got that one
and just for a bonus can you think of
another example of anomaly detection one
of the ones I use for my own business is
detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very fickel and they
behave very ertical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic was
something released in social media was
something released you can see we're
knowing where that an
is can help you to figure out what the
answer is to it in another area D
predicting salary of an individual based
on his or her years of experience this
is an example of regression this problem
can be mathematically defined as a
function between independent years of
experience and dependent variables
salary of an individual and if you guess
that this was a regression model give
yourself a thumbs up and if you're able
to remember that it was between
independent and dependent variables and
that ter terms give yourself two thumbs
up summary so to wrap it up we went over
what is K means and we went through also
the chart of choosing your elbow method
and assigning a random centroid to the
Clusters Computing the distance and then
going in there and figuring out what the
minimum centroids is and Computing the
distance and going through that Loop
until it gets the perfect centroid and
we looked into the elbow method to
choose K based on running our clusters
across a number of variables and finding
the best location for that we did a nice
example of clustering cars with K means
even though we only looked at the first
two columns to make it simple and easy
to graph we can easily extrapolate that
and look at all the different columns
and see how they all fit together and we
looked at what is logistic regression we
discussed the sigmoid function what is
logistic regression and then we went
into an example of classifying tumors
with Logistics I hope you enjoyed part
two of machine learning thank you for
joining us today for more information
visit www.ss simply learn.com again my
name is Richard kersner a member of the
simplylearn team get certified get ahead
if you have any questions or comments
feel free to write those down below the
YouTube video or visit us at simply
learn.com we'll be happy to supply you
with the data sets or other information
as
[Music]
requested hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click
here today we're going to cover the K
nearest neighbors L referred to as knnn
and KNN is really a fundamental place to
start in the machine learning it's a
basis of a lot of other things and just
the logic behind it is easy to
understand and Incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need KNN
what is KNN how do we choose the factor
k
when do we use
knnn how does KNN algorithm work and
then we'll dive into my favorite part
the use case predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model model Builds on those
inputs of what we already know and then
we use that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there and watching the black cat cross
their path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats cats have sharp
claws uses to climb smaller length of
ears meows and purrs doesn't love to
play around dogs they have dull claws
bigger length of ears barks loves to run
around around you usually don't see a
cat running around people although I do
have a cat that does that where dogs do
and we can look at these we can say we
can evaluate the sharpness of the claws
how sharp are their claws and we can
evaluate the length of the ears and we
can usually sort out cats from dogs
based on even those two
characteristics now tell me if it is a
cat or a dog odd question usually little
kids know cats and dogs by now unless
they live a place where there's not many
cats or dogs so if we look at the
sharpness of the claws the length of the
ears and we can see that the cat has
smaller ears and sharper claws than the
other animals its features are more like
cats it must be a cat sharp claws length
of ears and it goes in the cat group
because KNN is based on feature
similarity we can do classification
using KNN classifier so we have our
input value the picture of the black cat
it goes into our trained model and it
predicts that this is a cat coming out
so what is knnn What is the Ann
algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or it's not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how its
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine K and in
stores all available cases and
classifies new cases based on a
similarity measure and here you see we
have a measurement of sulfur dioxide
versus the chloride level and then the
different wines they've tested and where
they fall on that graph based on how
much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride K and K&N is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equal 5
we'll talk about K in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose K
how do we know k equals five I mean
that's what the value we put in there so
we're going to talk about it how do we
choose the factor K KN andn algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of K is a process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy so at k = 3 we can
classify we have a question mark in the
middle as either a as a square or not is
it a square or is it in this case a
triangle and so if we set k equals to 3
we're going to look at the three nearest
neighbors we're going to say this is a
square and if we put k equals to 7 we
classify as a triangle depending on what
the other data is around and you can see
as the K changes depending on where that
point is that drastically changes your
answer and uh we jump here we go how do
we choose the factor of K you'll find
this in all Mach Mach learning choosing
these factors that's the face you get
it's like oh my gosh did I choose the
right K did I set it right my values in
whatever machine learning tool you're
looking at so that you don't have a huge
bias in One Direction or the other and
in terms of KNN the number of K if you
choose it too low the bias is based on
it's just too noisy it's it's right next
to a couple things and it's going to
pick those things and you might get a
skewed answer and if your K is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
also if it's an even number so if you're
using uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of N and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use KNN we can use KNN when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a High
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where I you might
get into gig of data if it's really
clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because KNN is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get a idea of what that looks
like using the KNN and also just using
for smaller data sets KNN works really
good how does the KNN algorithm work
consider a data set having two variables
height in centimeters and weight in
kilograms and each point is classified
as normal or underweight so we can see
right here we have two variables you
know true false they're either normal or
they're not they're underweight on the
basis of the given data we have to
classify the below set as normal or
underweight using KNN so if we have new
data coming in that says 57 kilog and
177 cm is that going to be normal or
underweight to find the nearest
neighbors we'll calculate the ukian
distance according to the ukian distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates XY and
ab is given by distance D equals the
square root of x- a^ 2 + y - b^ 2 and
you can remember that from the two edges
of a triangle where Computing the third
Edge since we know the X side and the
yide let's calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red and we have
our other points where the data is
scattered around the distance D1 is a
square root of 170 - 167 2 + 57 - 51 2ar
which is about 6.7 and distance 2 is
about 13 and distance three is about
13.4 similarly we will calculate the
ukan distance of unknown data point from
all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do and
it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated Mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the ukian
distance hence we have calculated the
ukian distance of unknown data point
from all the points as shown where X1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the ukian
distance
who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals 3 and we
can see the three closest neighbors puts
them at normal and that's pretty
self-evident when you look at this graph
it's pretty easy to say okay what you
know we're just voting normal normal
normal three votes for normal this is
going to be a normal weight so majority
of neighbors are pointing towards normal
hence as per KNN algorithm the class of
57170 should be normal so recap of knnn
positive integer K is specified along
Ong with a new sample we select the K
entries in our database which are
closest to the new sample we find the
most common classification of these
entries this is the classification we
give to the new sample so as you can see
it's pretty straightforward we're just
looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in Python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes the objective predict
whether a person will be diagnosed with
diabetes or not we have a data set of
768 people who were or were not
diagnosed with diabetes and let's go
ahead and open that file and just take a
look at that data and this is in a
simple spreadsheet format the data
itself is comma separated very common
set of data and it's also a very common
way to get the data and you can see here
we have columns a through I that's what
1 2 3 four five six seven eight um eight
columns with a particular tribute and
then the ninth column which is the
outcome is whether they have diabetes as
a data scientist the first thing you
should be looking at is insulin well you
know if someone has insulin they have
diabetes because that's why they're
taking it and that could cause issue on
some of the machine learning packages
but for a very basic setup this works
fine for uh doing the KNN and the next
thing you notice is it didn't take very
much to open it up um I can scroll down
to the bottom of the data there's
768 it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into to my ram on my computer I can look
at it I can manipulate it and it's not
going to really tax just a regular
desktop computer you don't even need an
Enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what IDE I'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing uh very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the Jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the an Konda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python 36 I have a couple
different uh versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where I can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
uh the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm it's
going to open up Chrome because that's
my default that I use and since the
script is pre-done you'll see you have a
number of windows open up at the top the
one we're working in and uh since we're
working on the KNN predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and I'm
also going to go up here and click on
Cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert insert a cell below and
then I'm going to go back up to the top
cell and I'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if I run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice REM mind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our Imports
we're going to import the pandas as PD
import numpy as NP pandas is the pandas
data frame and numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have of our Imports so we've brought in
our pandas our numpy our two general
python tools and then you can see over
here we have our train test split by now
youed to be familiar with splitting the
data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data just
see how good it is pre-processing a
standard scaler pre-processor so we
don't have a bias of really large
numbers remember in the data we had like
number pregnancies isn't going to get
very large where the amount of insulin
they take and get up to 256 so 256
versus 6 that will skew results so we
want to go ahead and change that so
they're all uniform between minus one
and one and then the actual tool this is
the K neighbors classifier we're going
to use and finally the last three are
three tools to test all about testing
our model how good is it me just put
down test on there and we have our
confusion Matrix our F1 score and our
accuracy so we have our two general
python modules we're importing and then
we have our six module specific from the
sklearn setup and then we do need to go
ahead and run this so these are actually
imported there we go and then move on to
the next step and so in this set we're
going to go ahead and load the database
we're going to use pandas remember
pandas is PD and we'll take a look at
the data in Python we looked at it in a
simple spreadsheet but usually I like to
also pull it up so that we can see what
we're doing so here's our data set
equals pd. read CSV that's a pandas
command and the diabetes folder I just
put in the same folder where my IPython
script is if you put in a different
folder youd need the full length on
there we can also do a quick length of
uh the data set that is a simple python
command Len for length we might even
let's go ahead and print that we'll go
print and if you do it on its own line
link. data set in the jupyter notebook
it'll automatically print it but when
you're in most of your different setups
you want to do the print in front of
there and then we want to take a look at
the actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there if you put a bunch of
these in a row you know the data set one
head data set two head it only prints
out the last one so I usually always
like to keep the print statement in
there but because most projects only use
one data frame Panda's data frame doing
it this way doesn't really matter the
other way works just fine and you can
see when we hit the Run button we have
the 768 line which we knew and we have
our pregnancies it's automatically given
a label on the left remember the head
only shows the first five lines so we
have zero through four and just a quick
look at the data you can see it matches
what we looked at before we have
pregnancy glucose blood pressure all the
way to age and then the outcome on the
end and we're going to do a couple
things in this next step we're going to
create a list of columns where we can't
have zero there's no such thing as zero
skin thickness or or zero blood PR
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
Factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that cuz
we're going to start replacing that
information with a couple of different
things and let's see what that looks
like so first we create a nice list as
you can see we have the values talked
about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness uh and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the na but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column.
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do it direct there's also one that
that you look for your n a lot of
different options in here but the Nan
nump Nan is what that stands for is is
non doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to replace zeros
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hopefully they just didn't get the
data the next thing we want to do is
we're going to create the mean which is
the in integer from the data set from
the column do mean where we skip Nas we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip na so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the
npn with the means why did we do that
and we could have actually just uh taken
this step and gone right down here and
just replace zero and Skip anything
where except you could actually there's
a way to skip zeros and then just
replace all the zeros but in this case
we want to go ahead and do it this way
so you can see that we're switching this
to a non-existent value then we're going
to create the mean well this is the
average person so if we don't know what
it is if they did not get the data and
the data is missing one of the tricks is
you replace it with the average what is
the most common data for that this way
you can still use the rest of those
values to do your computation and it
kind of just brings that particular
value or those missing values out of the
equation let's go ahead and take this
and we'll go ahead and run it doesn't
actually do anything so we're still
preparing our data if you want to see
what that looks like we don't have
anything the first few lines so it's not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with a printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones it shows you can see it skipped
a bunch in the middle because that's
what it does if you have too many lines
in Jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and
and go on to the next in a data set let
me go and remove this and we'll just
zero out that and of course before we do
any processing before proceeding any
further we need to split the data set
into our train and testing data that way
we have something to train it with and
something to test it on and you're going
to notice we did a little something here
with the panda database code there we go
my drawing tool we've added in this
right here off the data set and what
this says is that the first one in
pandas this is from the PD pandas it's
going to say within the data set we want
to look at the iocation and it is all
rows that's what that says so we're
going to keep all the the rows but we're
only looking at zero column 0 to 8
remember column 9 here it is right up
here we printed in in here is outcome
well that's not part of the training
data that's part of the answer yes
column nine but it's listed as eight
number eight so 0o to eight is nine
columns so uh eight is the value and
when you see it in here zero this is
actually 0 to 7 it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to Y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column 8 and you can do it
this way with this particular notation
and then if you remember we imported the
train test split that's part of the SK
learn right there and we simply put in
our X and our y we're going to do random
State equals zero you don't have to
necessarily seed it that's a seed number
I think the default is one when you see
it I'd have to look that up and then the
test size test size is 02 that simply
means we're going to take 20% of the
data and put it aside so that we can
test it later that's all that is and
again we're going to run it not very
exciting so far far we haven't had any
print out other than to look at the data
but that is a lot of this is prepping
this data once you prep it the actual
lines of code are quick and easy and
we're almost there with the actual
writing of our KNN we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data if you remember
correctly we're fitting the data in a
standard scaler which means instead of
the data being from you know 5 to 303 in
one column and the next column is 1 to
six we're going to set that all so that
all the data is between minus one and
one that's what that standard scaler
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scaler with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the X test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scaler we're going to call it scor X for
the scaler and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our X train equals scor x. fit
transform so we're creating the scaler
on the X train variable and then our X
test we're also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the X
train and then the X test isn't part of
that training it isn't part of that of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to go and run this if you
look at this we've now gone through
these steps all three of them we've
taken care of replacing our zeros for
key columns that shouldn't be zero and
we replace that with the means of those
columns that way that they fit right in
with our data models we've come down
here and we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we scaled the
data so all of our data going in now no
we don't tra we don't train the Y part
the Y train and Y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then Define the model using K neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about Python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math. square root do y train
there we go it's actually supposed to be
X train before we do this let's go ahead
and do import math and do math square
root length of Y test and when I run
that we get
12.49 I want to see show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11 let
me delete this out of here this one of
the reasons I love Jupiter notebook
because you can flip around and do all
kinds of things on the fly so we'll go
ahead and put in our classifier we're
creating our classifier now and it's
going to be the K neighbors classifier n
neighbors equal 11 remember we did 12
minus 1 for 11 so we have an odd number
of neighbors P equals 2 because we're
looking for is it are they diabetic or
not and we're using the ukian metric
there are other means of measuring the
distance you could do like square square
means value there's all kinds of measure
this but the UK is the most common one
and it works quite well it's important
to evaluate the model let's use the
confusion Matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion Matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the F1 score and finally accuracy score
which is probably the most commonly used
quoted number when you go into a meeting
or something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ah and run that and print it out and
the way you interpret this is you have
the Y predicted which would be your
title up here we could do uh let's just
do p r predicted across the top and
actual going down actual it's always
hard to to write in here actual that
means that this column here down the
middle that's the important column and
it means that our prediction said 94 and
prediction in the actual agreed on 94
and 32 this number here the 13 and the
15 those are what was wrong so you could
have like three different if you're
looking at this across three different
variables instead of just two you'd end
up with the third row down here in the
column going down the middle so in the
first case we have the the and I believe
the zero is a 94 people who don't have
diabetes the prediction said that 13 of
those people did have diabetes and were
at high risk and the 32 that had
diabetes had correct but our prediction
said another 15 out of that 15 it
classified as incorrect so you can see
where that classification comes in and
how that works on the confusion Matrix
then we're going to go ahead and print
the F1 score let me just run that and
you see we get a 69 in our F1 score the
F1 takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives where if we
go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the F1 score the F score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the U decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the F1 score but the F1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on G here but 82% not too bad
for a quick flash look at people's
different statistics in running an SK
learn and running the KNN the K nearest
neighbor on it so we have created a
model using KNN which can predict
whether a person will have diabetes or
not or at the very least whether they
should go get a checkup and have their
glucose checked regularly or not the
print accurate score we got the
0818 was pretty close to what we got and
we can pretty much round that off and
just say we have an accuracy of 80%
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model the principal component uh
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principal
component analysis what is it important
PCA terminologies and you'll see it
abbreviated uh normally as PCA principal
component analysis PCA properties PCA
example and then we'll pull up some
python code in our jupyter notebook and
have some Hands-On demo on the PCA and
how it's used diens dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company uh bpex isomax and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
ID a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis that we just need three
attributes therefore we have reduced the
number of attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number I don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought um and even the store
who's buying them probably does not have
an effect on that in this case that's
what they've actually done is remove
those and we just have the item the tire
the price and the quantity one of the
things you should be taking away away
from this is in the scheme of things we
are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up why dimensionality
reduction well number one less
dimensions for a given data set means
less computation or training time that
can be really important if you're trying
a number of different models uh and
you're rerunning them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models so this is huge this is probably
the hugest part as far as reducing um
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing similar entries from the data
set again pre-processing some of our
models like a neural network if you put
into the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just want so we want to get rid of that
redundancy it also increases the
processing time if you have multiple uh
data coming in space required to store
the data is
reduced so if we're committing this into
a big data uh pool we might not send the
company that bought it why would we want
to store two whole extra columns when we
added into that pool of data makes the
data easy for plotting in 2D and 3D
plots this is my favorite part very
important you're in your shareholder
meeting you want to be able to give them
a really good um clear and simp
simplified version you want to reduce it
down to something people can take in it
helps to find out the most significant
features and skip the rest which also
comes in in
postcript that kind of goes with number
four what makes data easy for plotting
you have a better interpretation when
we're looking at it principal component
analysis so what is it uh principal
component analysis is a technique for
reducing the dimensionality of data sets
increasing interpretability but at the
same time minimizing information loss so
we take some very complex data set with
lots of variables we run it through the
PCA we reduce the variables we end up
with a reduced variable
setup this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here uh
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some Toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle uh we get the back
of a lot of heads not many
faces uh so we'll do it from here we
might get the one person up front
smiling a lot of the people in the class
are missing so we have a huge amount off
to the right of blank space Maybe from
up here again we have the back of
someone's head and uh it turns out that
the best angle to click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it and you say hey that makes sense
it's a a good um configuration of all
the people in the picture now when we're
talking about data it's not you really
can't do it by what you think is going
to be the best we need to have some kind
of mathematical formula so it's
consistent and so it makes s in the back
end one of the projects I worked on many
years ago uh has something similar to
the iris and if you've ever done the
iris data set it's probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower and they're measuring
the stammen uh in the petals and they
have width and they have length of the
petal instead of putting through the
width and the length of the petal we
could just as easily do the um width to
length ratio we can divide the width by
the length and you get a single number
where you had two that's the kind of
idea that's going on into this in
pre-processing and looking at what we
can do to bring the data down the very
simplified example on my uh Iris pedal
example
when we look at the similarity in PCA we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points and so we look down at
from one angle we've drawn a line down
there uh we can see these data points
based on in this case just two variables
now keep in mind we're usually talking
about 36 40 variables um almost all of
your business models usually have about
26 to 27 different variables they're
looking at uh same thing with like a
bank loan model we're talking 26 to 36
different variables they're looking at
that are going in so what we want to do
is we want to find the best view in this
case we're just looking at the
XY we look down at it and we have our
second um idea PC2 and again we're
looking at the X side this XY this time
from a different direction here for our
ease we can consider that we get two
principle components namely pc1 and
PC2 comparing both both the principal
components we find the data points are
sufficiently spaced in
pc1 so if you look at what we got here
we have uh pc1 you can see along the
line how the data points are spaced
versus the spacing in PC2 and that's
what they're coming up with what is
going to give us the best look for these
data points when we combine them and
we're looking at them from just a single
angle whereas in PC2 they are less
spaced which makes the observation and
further calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
PC2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the backend calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more
valuable this gives you an idea though
that when we're talking about this we're
talking about the perspective uh which
would help in understanding how PCA
analysis
works we want to go ahead and do is dive
into the important terminologies under
PC CA and important terminologies are
views the perspective through which data
points are
observed and so you'll hear that if
someone's talking about a PCA
presentation and they're not taking the
time to reduce it to something that the
average person shareholders can
understand you might hear them refer to
it as the different views what view are
we taking Dimension number of columns in
a data set are called the dimensions of
that data set we talked about you'll
hear features Dimensions um I was
talking about features there's usually
when you're running a business you're
talking 25 26 27 different features
minimal and then you have the principal
component new variables that are
constructed as linear combinations or
mixtures of the initial
variables principal component is very
important it's a combination if you
remember my flower example it would be
the width over the length of the petal
as opposed to putting both width and
length in you just put in the um ratio
instead which is a single number versus
two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component and the
data
points and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those Point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of
attributes that just makes Common Sense
uh you're not going to do 10 principal
properties with only three features
you're trying to reduce them so that's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw weird
code out there and just randomly do
stuff with instead of really thinking it
through principal components are
orthagonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line we when
we do pc1 we're looking at how those
points fall onto that line uh same thing
with PC2 we want to make sure that pc1
does not equal PC2 we don't want to have
the same two two principal points uh
when we do two
points the priority of principal
components decreases as their numbers
increase this is important to understand
if you're going to
create uh one
principle component everything is
summarized into that one component as we
go to two components the priority um how
much it holds value decreases as we go
down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it how PCA works I said there was more
in the back end we talk about the math
this is what we're talking about is how
does it actually work so now we have
understanding that you're you're looking
at a perspective uh now we want to see
how that math side Works PCA performs
the following operations in order to
evaluate the principal components for a
given data
set first we start with the
standardization then we have a
covariance matrix
computation and we use that to generate
our ige vectors and igene
values which is the feature vector and
if you remember the IG Vector is like a
translation for um moving the data from
xal 1 to xal 2 or whatever altering it
and the IG value is the final value that
we
generate when we talk about
standardization the main aim of this
step is to standardize the range of the
attribute so that each one of them lie
within similar boundaries this process
involves removal of the mean from the
variable values and scaling the data
with respect to the standard
deviation and you can see here we have Z
equals the variable values minus the
mean over the standard
deviation The covariance Matrix mat
computation covariance Matrix is used to
express the correlation between any two
or more attributes in multi-dimensional
data set the co-variance Matrix has the
entries as the variance and the
co-variance of the attribute values the
variance is denoted by VAR and the
covariance is denoted by Cove on the
right we can see the covariance Matrix
for two attributes and their
values when we do a Hands-On look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like for now you can
just notice that this is a matrix that
we're generating with the variance and
then the co-variance of x to Y on the
right side we can see the co-variance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data
set this is what I was talking about we
usually are looking at uh not just one
feature or two features we're usually
looking at 25 30 features going
on and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different
variables covariance Matrix tells us how
the two or more variables are related
positive covariant indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariant indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not and then we have the ige
values and the igene vectors IG values
and IG vectors are the mathematical
value that are extracted from the
co-variance table they are responsible
for the generation of a new set of
variables from the old set of variables
which further lead to the construction
of the principal components igene
vectors do not change directions after
linear transformation igene values are
the scalers or the magnitude of the IGN
vectors and again this is just change
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector B to the B Prime as
denoted on the chart and so when we have
like multiple variables how do we
calculate that new variable and then we
have feature vectors feature vectors is
simply a matrix that hasing vectors of
the components that we decide to keep as
the columns here we decide whether we
must keep or discard the less
significant principal components that we
have generated in the above steps this
becomes really important as we start
looking at uh the back end of this and
we'll do this in the demo uh but one of
the more important steps to understand
and so we have the PCA example consider
Matrix x with n rows or observations and
K columns are variables now for this
Matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable but for our Simplicity let's
consider this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the Matrix X
is placed in the K dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the
plot the first principle component is a
line that best accounts for the shape of
the point swarm it represents a maximum
variance Direction in the data each
observation may be projected onto this
line in order to get a coordinate value
along the pc1 this value is known as a
score usually only one principal
component is insufficient to model the
systematic variation for a data set thus
a second principal axis is
created the second principal component
is oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthagonal to pc1
PC2 also passes through the average
Point let's go ahead and pull this up
and just see what that means uh inside
our python scripting I'm going to use
the Anaconda Navigator and I will be in
Python
3.6 for this example I believe there's
even like a 3.9 out I tend to stay in
3.6 because a lot of the models I use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in
36 and then we open up our uh Jupiter
I'm in Chrome and we go ahead and create
a new Python
3 and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me and we'll go and start
with the libraries the first thing I
like to do whenever I'm looking at any
new setup uh well you know what Let's do
let's do the libraries first we're going
to do our basic libraries which is Matt
plot Library uh the PLT from the map
plot Library pandas our data frame uh PD
numpy our numbers array NP caborn for
graphing SNS that goes with the plot
that actually sits on Matt plot Library
so the caborn sits on there and then we
have our Amber sign because we're in
Jupiter notebook M plot library in line
the newer version actually doesn't
require that um but I put it in there
either anyway just because I'm so used
to
it and then we going to go ahead and
take a look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull in uh certainly you can have lots
of fun with different data but we're
going to use the cancer data set u one
of the reasons a cancer data set is is
it has like 36 35 different features so
it's kind of fun to use that as our base
for this and we'll go ahead and run this
and look at our
keys and the first thing we notice in
our keys for the cancer data set uh is
we have our data we have our Target our
frame Target names description feature
names and file
name so what we're looking for and all
this is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on
here I'm not going to spend a huge
amount of time on the description um
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our PCA setup uh what's important is
you start looking at what the different
attributes are what they mean um if you
were in the medical field you'd want to
note all these different things whether
what they're measuring where it's coming
from you can actually see the actual
different um measurements are
taking no missing
attributes we page all the way to the
bottom and you're going to have your
data in this case our
Target and if you dig deep enough to the
Target uh let's actually do this let's
go ahead and print Target
names real quick here I always like to
to just take a look and see what's on
the other end of this uh
Target
names run
that and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it B9 um so in other
words is this uh dangerous growth or is
it something we don't have to worry
about that's the bottom line with the
cancer in this
case and then we can go ahead and load
our data and you know what let me go up
a just a notch here for easy of
reading it's hard to get that just right
I guess I'll be have to do uh so let's
go ahead and look at our data uh our our
we're going to use our pandas and we're
going to go ahead and uh do our data
frame is going to equal cancer data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we we
already loaded the the um names up of
our of the features in there what is
going to come out of this let me just
see if I can get to
that it's at the top of Target names um
that's just this list of names here in
the
setup and we can go ahead and run this
code and it'll print the head and you
can see here we have the mean radius the
mean texture mean perimeter I don't know
about you this is a wonderful data set
if you're playing with it because like
many of the data that most of the data
that comes in half the time we don't
even know what we're looking at uh we're
just handed a bunch of stuff as a data
scientist going what the heck is this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there and we have no idea
what these feature means or where they
come from we want to just look at the
data and figure that
out and now we actually are getting into
the PCA side of it as we've noticed
before is difficult to visualize how
High dimensional data we can use PCA to
find the first two principal components
and visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space with a single
scatter plot uh before we do this we
need to go ahead and scale our
data now I haven't run this to see if
you really have to scale the data on
this um but as just a
general runtime I almost do that as the
first step of any modeling even if it's
pre modeling as we're doing here um in
neural networks that is so important
with PCA visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the PCA uh but just
in case it's always good to scale
it and then we're going to take our PCA
with the pyit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come withit learn we
instantiate a PCA object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to keep when creating
the PCA
object and so the code for
this oops getting a little bit
ahead let me go and run this code uh so
the code for
this is from sklearn decomposition
import PCA PCA equals PCA in components
equals two and that's really important
to note that um because we're only going
to want to look at two
components I would never go over four
components uh especially if you're going
to demo this with somebody else if
you're showing this to the
shareholders the whole idea is to reduce
it to something people can
see uh and then the PCA fit we're going
to uh is going to take the scale data
that we generated up here and then you
can see we've created our PCA model with
in components equals
2 now whenever I use a new tool I like
to go in there and actually see what I'm
using so let's go to the S kit uh web
page for the
PCA and you can see in here here's our
call statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on
there probably the biggest one to look
at would be um well the biggest one is
your components how many components do
you want uh which you have to put in
there pretty much and then you also
might look at the SVD solver it's on
auto right now but you can override that
and do different things with it it does
a pretty good job as it
is and if we go down all the way down
to
um there we go to our methods if you
notice we have fit we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction uh it's used
to look at the data again we're in the
describe setup we're fitting the data
we're taking a look at it uh we've
already looked at our minimum maximum
we've already looked at what's in each
quarter we've done a full description of
the data this is part of describing the
data um that's the biggest thing I take
away when I come zooming in here and of
course they have examples of it down
here if you
forget
um and the biggest one of course is the
number of components and then uh I mean
the rest you can play with um the actual
solver whether you're doing a full
randomize there's different things it
does pretty good on the
auto and now we can transform this data
to its first two principal
components and so we have our X
PCA we're going to set that equal to PCA
train transform scaled
data uh so there we go there's our first
transformation and let's just go ahead
and print the scaled data shape and the
xpc data
shape and the reason we want to do this
is just to show us uh what's going on
here we've taken 30 features I think I
said 36 or something like that but it's
30 and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from we still have 569 data sets I mean
data rows not data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two
features so let's go ahead and uh uh
plot these and take a look and see
what's going
on and
uh we're just going to use our PLT
figure we're going to set the the figure
size on here here's our scatter plot um
X
PCA xcore PCA of uh of one these are two
different perceptions we're using uh and
then you'll see right here C for color
cancer equals Target and so remember we
have zero we have one and if I remember
correctly zero was malignant one was
B9 uh so everything in the zero column
is going to be one col color and the
other color is going to be one and then
we're going to use the plasma map just
kind of telling you what color it is add
some labels first principal component
second principal component we'll go and
run this and you can see here instead of
having a chart one of those heat maps
with 30 different columns in it we can
look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good
job of separating the
data and a couple things when I'm I'm
looking at this that I notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped
together um where it's going to be
benign and we have a huge area it's
still clumped together more spread out
where it's going to be uh malignant or I
think I had that backwards and then in
the middle because we're dealing with
something in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate I would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out in other words which is an
area where everything overlaps and we're
not going to have a clear result on it
uh just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body absorbs it
and it dissipates versus uh actively
going in there removing it testing it
going through chemo and all the
different things that's a big difference
you know as far as what's going to
happen here and that middle line where
they overlap is going to be huge that's
domain specific uh going back to the
data we can see here uh clearly by using
these two components we can easily
separate these two classes so the next
step is what does that mean interpreting
the
components unfortunately with this great
power of dimensionality reduction comes
the cost of not being able to easily
understand what these components
represent I don't know what principal
component one looks represents or second
principle the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered PCA object and
so when we t look at that we can go
ahead and do uh look at the PCA
components this is in our model we built
we've trained it we can run that and you
can see here's the actual components uh
it's the two components have each have
their own
array and within the array you can see
the um what the scores they're using and
these actually give weight to what
features are doing
what so in this numpy Matrix array each
row represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features what's really neat about this
is we can now go in
reverse and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down oops I already got it down
here uh we'll go ahead and put this in
here we're going to use our um DF comp
data frame and we do our PCA
components and I want you to notice how
easy this is uh we're going to set our
columns equal to cancer feature
names that just makes it really easy and
we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to Seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and uh and set it up for us
where we want and so we're just going to
do the CN the caborn heat map
of our data frame uh composition and
we'll use the plasma
coloring and it creates a nice little
color graph here you can see we have the
mean radius and all the different
features along the bottom on the right
uh we have a scale so we can see we have
the dark colors all the way to the
really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look
at so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component
itself so you know very powerful map to
look at and then you can go in here and
we might notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is um on some of this uh so you have
some interesting correlations here that
change the variations on that and what
means what this is more when you get to
uh
postribosomal try to guess as what these
things mean and what you want to change
to get a better result regularization in
machine
learning so our agenda on this one is
fitting the data understanding linear
regression bias and variance what is
overfitting what is underfitting and
those are like the biggest things right
now in data science is overfitting and
underfitting what does that mean and
what is regularization and then we'll do
a quick Hands-On demo to take a look at
this so fitting the data let's start
with fitting the data and we talk about
uh what is data fitting it's a process
of plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called Data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
uh so we might have in this case just a
two Dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1,000
km and so what is data fitting well it's
a linear relationship and a linear
relationship very specifically linear
means line uh the line used to represent
the relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear
relationship linear
regression so let's start with uh how
linear regression Works a linear
regression uh find the line that best
fits the data point and gives a
relationship between the two
variables and so you can see here we
have the efficiency of the car um versus
the distance traveled and you can see
this nice straight line drawn through
there and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane it gets a little more complicated
with multiple variables but they all
come down to this linear kind of uh
drawing a line through your data and
finding what fits the the data the the
best and so we can consider an example
uh let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how uh
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store and suppose we have two lines
we're going to draw L1 and L2 and we're
going to kind of guess which one we
think is the best fit and which claim to
describe the relationship between the
variables and so first we find the
square of the distance between the line
L1 and each data point and add them all
and find the mean
distance and I want you to think about
that when we um uh Square something if
it's a negative or positive number it no
longer matters because a minus 2^2 is 4
2^2 is four so we're removing what side
of the line it's on and we're just
looking looking for the error in this
casee the mean distance of each of the
little dotted lines you see
here this way of calculating the square
of the distance adding them and then
taking the mean is called mean square
error or loss function and we talk about
loss how far off are we that's what
we're really talking about what did we
miss uh and we have a positive distance
and a negative distance and of course
when we Square it it is neither it just
becomes a positive
error and so we take the
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as MSE uh if I look
in a code and I'm going through my
python code and I see MSE I know that's
a mean squared error and we take all the
dotted lines and we calculate this error
we add them all together and then we
average it or find the
means and in this case they ran a demo
on this and it was uh 1,1
127.23 uh for our L1 line now we find
the loss function function for line L2
in a similar fashion and we get the mean
square error to be
6,397 and it's computed the same way so
maybe you put this line just way outside
the data range and this is the error you
get by analyzing our results we find
that the loss function or the mean
square error is less for L1 than L2
hence L1 is the best fit
line uh this process describes a lot of
machine learning
processes we're going to keep guessing
and get as close as we can to find the
right answer we have to have some way to
invi to um calculate this and figure out
which one's the best and the mean square
error is one of the better fits to doing
for doing this and most commonly
used we really want to talk about bias
and variance very important terms to
know in machine learning and with linear
regression
so bias bias occurs when an algorithm
has limited flexibility to learn from
data variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have um the two
different setups uh bias you can think
is very generalized where variance is
very
specific uh and so when we talk about
bias such models pay very little
attention to the training data and
oversimplify the model therefore the
validation error or prediction error and
training error follow similar
Trends and uh with bias if you
oversimplify it so much you're going to
miss your um local uh if if you have
like a really good fit you're going to
miss it you're you're going to just kind
of guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to
be with variance a model with the high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other such models always lead to a high
error on training and test data as a
bias does where variance such models
usually perform very well on training
data but have high error rates on test
data and I want you to think about this
um when we're talking about a bias uh
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an average we're not really fitting it
close with variance we're fitting it so
close that the test data does really
good it's going to nail it every time uh
if you're doing categorical testing
that's a car that's a truck that's a
bicycle um but with variant suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it might have to be red uh because you
had so many red pictures so if it has if
it's an 18-wheeler it has to be red if
it's uh blue then it has to be a bicycle
that's a kind of variance we're talking
about where it picks up on something and
it it cannot get the right answer unless
it gets a very specific data and we see
that so that as you're testing it your
models and you programmed it you got to
look for how I trained it what is coming
out and if it's not if it's not looking
good on either bias or or if it's not
looking good on the training or on the
test data than your bias uh than your
bias in your data if it really looks
good on the training data then that's
going to be your variance you've
overfitted the data and those are very
important things to know when you are
building your models uh in regression of
any kind or any kind of uh setup for
predicting so in dark games if all the
data fall a particular pointer this can
be considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score for
variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores uh again
the bias sums everything up in one point
kind of averages it together where the
variance really looks for the individual
uh predictions coming
out so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting uh when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve uh you can see that
um if you plug in your coordinates
you're just going to get the whatever
it's fited every point on the data
stream there's no average there's no two
points that might have the me know y
might have two different answers because
the if the wind blows a certain way um
and your efficiency of your car maybe
you have a headwind so your car might
alter how efficient it is as it goes and
so there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance what's you know the this is
it's going to be exactly this it can't
be any you can't be the same speed or
the same car and have a slightly
different
efficiency so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the
prediction uh so you'll get like a
really high error on here
here and so uh reasons for overfitting
uh data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of something wrong with the
data coming in it needs to be addressed
whether it's a source of the data maybe
they use in medical different measuring
tools uh so you now have to adjust for
data that came in from hospital a a
versus Hospital b or even off of machine
a and machine B that's testing something
and those those numbers are coming in
wrong the model has a high variance uh
again wind is a good example I was
talking about that with the car you may
have 100 tests but because the wind's
blowing it's all over the
place uh size of training data used is
not enough so a small amount of data is
going to also cause this problem you
only have a few points and you try to
plot everything the model is too complex
uh this comes up a lot we put too many
pieces together and how the interact
can't even be tracked um and so you have
to go back break it up and find out
actually what correlates and what
doesn't so what is underfitting a
scenario where machine learning models
can neither
learn the relationship between the data
points nor predict or classify a new
data point and you can see here we have
our efficiency of our car and our line
drawn and it's just going to be way off
for both the training and the predicting
data as the model doesn't fully learn
the patterns it accepts every new data
point during the prediction so instead
of looking for a general pattern uh we
just kind of accept
everything data used for training is not
cleaned and contains noise garbage and
values again underfitting and
overfitting same issue you got to clean
your
data the model has a high bias uh we've
seen this in all kinds of things
from uh the mo the most common is the
driving cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have um five people from India and 10
people
from um Africa and 20 people from the US
you've created a bias uh because it's
looking at the 20 people and you only
have a small amount of data to work
with size of training data used is not
enough uh that goes with the size I was
just talking about so we have a model
with a high bias we have size of
training data used it's not enough the
model is too
simple again this a one straight line
through all the data when it needs has a
slight shift to it for other
reasons so what is a good fit uh a
linear curve that best fits the data is
neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right and of course
we have the nice examples here where we
have overfitting lines going up and down
every Point's starting to be include
glued
underfitting um the line really is off
from where the data is and then a good
fit is got to get rid of that minimized
that um error coming through
regularization is taking the guess work
out you're looking at this graph and
you're going oh which one is that really
overfit or is that underfit that's
pretty hard to
tell so we talk about
regularization regularization techniques
are used to calibrate the linear
regression models and to minimize the
adjusted loss function and prevent
overfitting or
underfitting so what that means uh in
this case we're going to go ahead and
take a look at a couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model we
look at the Ridge regularization and the
lasso
regularization and these models are just
like uh just like we did the um MLP the
multi-layered positron in the SK learn
module you could bring in the ridge
module and you can bring in the lassle
module so when we talk about um Ridge
regression it modifies the over over
fitted or underfitted models by adding
the penalty equivalent to the sum of the
squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients and so we have a cost
function equals loss equals uh Lambda
times the sum of W squared or the
absolute value of w depending on how
you're doing it now remember we talked
about error where we either Square it or
we absolute value it uh because it
removes a plus or minus sign on there
and there's reasons to do it either way
but is more common to square the
value and then we have our uh um in this
case the Lambda is going to be the
penalty for the errors we've thrown in a
Greek character for you just to confuse
everybody and W is the slope of the
curve of the
line so uh we're going to look at this
and we're going to draw a line this is
going to be like a linear regression
model so if you had in sklearn you could
import just a standard linear regression
model uh it would plot this line across
whatever data we're working
on and we look at this and of course
we're just extrapolating this um I'm I
know they use some specific data but you
don't want to get into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the
line and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equal zero uh considering the two points
on the line we'll go and do Lambda
equals 1 we'll set our W is going to be
1.4 then the cost function equals 0 + 1
* 1.4 2 which equal
1.96
uh so really don't get caught up too
much in the math on this other than
understanding um that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the Lambda time W the sum
of w
^2 and then let's say we have a ridge uh
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data and for the rid
regression let's assume a loss equals
3^2 +2 squ equal .13 so when they put
all the calculations through of the two
points we end up with the 0.0
62 uh so we now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model and the ridge regression model
plots a little differently than the
standard linear regression
model and comparing the two models with
all the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line and I find this true on
a lot of data I work with I'll end up
using either the ridge regression model
or the lasso uh Mars regression model
for fitting um especially dealing with a
lot of like uh stock markets daily um
setup they come out slightly better uh
you get a slightly better um
fit and so we have our lasso we just
talked about lasso coming in
here and the cost function equals uh um
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute abute value and
so if you remember this is where Ridge
regression changes where's my Ridge
regression model uh we're squaring the
value
here and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of the of the squared
individuals um and here is
our Lambda symbol again penalty for
errors and W equals the slope of the
curve and comparing the two mod with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression
line and this is like I said I I use
these two models a lot uh the Ridge and
this is important this is this is kind
of the meat of the matter how do you
know which one to use some of it is you
just do it a bunch of times and then you
figure it out uh Ridge regularization is
useful when we have many variables with
relatively smaller data samples the
bottle does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent
overfitting the Lasser regularization
model is preferred when we are fitting a
linear model with fewer
variables so in the LA in the iris thing
we had four or five variables as they
measured the different Leaf pieces uh
you might be doing the measurements on
the cancer project which has 36
different
variables um so as we get down to the
with four variables lassar will probably
uh work pretty good where you might use
the ridge regularization with more model
with if you have something uh
significantly larger and it encourages
the coefficients of the variables to go
toward zero because of the shape of the
constraint which is an absolute
value and with any of this we want to go
ahead and uh do a demo and lasso and
ridge regression so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in our code
and bring up our Jupiter notebook well
we'll start with our Imports pandas as
PD import numpy as NP import M plot
Library as PLT um sklearn we're going to
import our data sets it's kind of more
generic um we usually just import one
data set instead of all of them but you
know quick and dirty when you're putting
some of these together uh we have our
sklearn model selection we're going to
import our train test split for
splitting our data up and then we'll
bring in our linear regression
model and we'll go ahead and run these
just to load them up and then load our
data set we're just talking about that
uh you could just um um have imported
the load Boston and Boston data set in
there instead of loading all the data
sets
um and then once we've loaded our data
set we want to go ahead and take a look
at that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go and run it and so we've gone
ahead and taken our uh boss Boston uh
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame um the Boston data
set and then the Boston columns so we
want to see what's going on with them um
we have our Target we have the house
price uh Etc and so our x equals Boston
um
iocation now remember in pandas the new
updates to pandas they want iocation if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off but it does
something different it creates a slice
versus a direct um setup so make sure
you're using that iocation and the I the
output so this is all just bringing our
data
together and we can see here if we do uh
we print the Boston um Panda's head we
can see here all of our different um
aspects we're looking
for and if you're following the X and
the Y the x is um
everything except for the last column
where Y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then Y is all the rows
but just the last column so Y is our
house price and the x is the crimzan
industry Chaz Knox and all these other
different um statistics they've
collected for house sales in
Boston there we go oops
control
ah so so we'll go ahead and split our
data uh X train and our x uh test YT
train y test equals the train test split
which we
imported and we have our Boston um you
could have easily used the X and Y on
here as opposed to Boston um
iocation and we'll create our test size
we're going to take 25% of the data and
put it in as a
test uh and then we'll go ahead and run
this
uh need an extra drink there uh so we
have our train and test and then of
course the print the train data
shape I love doing this kind of thing
whenever I'm working with this data
print out the shape make sure everything
looks correct uh so that we have 127 by
13 and 127 by 1 379 by 13 they should
match and if there're if the the data
sets are not quite matching then you
know something's wrong and you're going
to get all those errors I don't know how
many times I've gone through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when I'm cleaning the data this
is pretty straightforward and simple
because the data comes in a nice
prepackage it's all clean for
you so let's go ahead and apply apply
the multiple linear regression
model and uh we'll call this l r lreg
linear regression and we're going to go
ahead and fit that linear regression
model to X train and Y
train then we'll generate the prediction
on the test Set uh so here's our lre y
predict with our X test going into the
prediction and let's calculate that mean
square error MSE I told you you'll see
MSE used a lot um people use it in
variables and things like that it's
pretty common and we get our mean
squared error equals uh this is just the
basic formula we've already been talking
about what's the difference squared
uh then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run
this and you can see when we get through
the end of this we have our mean square
error on
test we have our total and then we have
each column coming
down and at this point unless you really
know the data you're working with it's
not going to mean a whole lot so if it's
in your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see see these
kinds of numbers coming up uh but if
it's not it's just a bunch of numbers
and that's okay at least that's okay for
this demo uh and then we're going to go
ahead and plot these so we can see
what's going on and this is always kind
of fun it's always nice to have a nice
visual of what you're looking at and you
can see here um when we plot the
coefficient scores on here and we the
guys in the back did a great job putting
some pretty colors together making it
look nice and setting up the
columns you can see here uh your nox has
like just a huge coefficient um when I
look at a table like this I look for
what has very
little um different coefficients they're
not using a huge change and what has
huge changes and that Flags you for all
kinds of things as you're working with
the data but it depends so much on the
domain you're working with these are
great things though as a just a quick
look to see what's going on with your
data and what you're looking
for and of course once we look at this
now our our motive is to reduce the
coefficient score so now we want to take
these and and uh bring them down as much
as we can and for that we're going to
work with the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going ahead and we're
going to import our Ridge model the
ridge regression from the sklearn
library or the S kit and we're going to
go ahead and train the model so here's
our Ridge um r equal Alpha equals 1 and
I mentioned that earlier um when when I
work with the ridge model you'll see
Alpha equals 1 if you set Alpha equal to
zero that's a standard linear regression
model so you have Alpha equal 1 2 3 4
and you usually use 1 2 or 3 4 and a
standard integer on there and we'll go
ahead and fit the ridge model on there
with our X train and our YT train data
generate a prediction for that um for
our X test and we'll calculate the mean
square error uh just like we did before
this should all look
familiar and we'll go ah and print that
out and we'll look at the uh Ridge
coefficients for our data and see what
that looks
like now if I jump up and down between
these
two you'll get a headache
uh you'll still see the nox value let's
just look at the nox because that was
the biggest value was a minus 99 here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18 so right off the bat I'm
seeing a huge change
um in the biggest coefficient
there uh so if we're going to do that
nice setup we want to go ahead and just
print it and see what that looks
like here we go and we've uh set up our
um plot subplots and again the team put
together some nice colors so it makes it
look good we're doing an xar based on
the
columns and our um l coefficients color
equals color X spine bottom and so forth
uh so just puts together a nice little
graph and you're starting to see uh one
this when you compare this if you put on
the same graph as this one up here this
is up here at minus 18 this is at minus
9 and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above uh the same thing with
these values here they might look the
same but they're actually all um almost
half the value on
here and then finally you can do the
same thing for the lasso
regression this will all look uh very
similar as far as what we worked on
before and I'm just going to ahead and
print that on here and run it and again
let's go up to uh nox look where nox is
it's all the way down to zero and if we
look at our next biggest coefficient is
minus8 and really here's are
22.73 we go up
here um
16.7 and we go up here and we look at
the same number uh
16.69% 69 is better than 78 uh so from
the very beginning we might start
looking at this first model for
overall
predicting but there's other factors
involved uh we might know that uh the
knock value is Central and the other
ones aren't quite as good and so we
might start looking at just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have a certain meaning to us and so
forth and so you got look at all those
different things um items in there again
but the bottom dollar is our first model
did better than our other two models our
mean square error on the test set um
continues to come down on this we're
going to cover reinforcement learning
today and what's in it for you we'll
start with why reinforcement learning
we'll look at what is reinforcement
learning we'll see what the different
kinds of learning strategies are that
are being used today in computer models
under supervised versus unsupervised
versus rein
enforcement we'll cover important terms
specific to reinforcement learning we'll
talk about markov's decision process and
we'll take a look at a reinforcement
learning example well we'll teach a
tic-tac-toe how to play why
reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem and you
can see here we have the robot learning
to walk um very complicated setup when
you're learning how to walk and you'll
start asking questions like if I'm
taking one step forward and left what
happens if I pick up a 50 PB object how
does that change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until the it's
actually tried out learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular
problem and we'll see here it learned
how to walk this is going to slow the
growth that technology is capable of
machines need to learn to perform
actions by themselves and not just learn
off
humans and you see the objective climb a
mountain real interesting point here is
that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore play
with it most of the models the
non-reinforcement models in computer uh
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well uh there's a couple of them
that can be used or integrated see how
it goes is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is a subbranch of machine
learning that trains a model to return
an Optimum solution for a problem by
taking a sequence of decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another the robot is given a
scenario and must arrive at a solution
by itself the robot can take different
paths to reach the
destination it will know the best path
by the time taken on each path it might
even come up with a unique solution all
by itself and that's really important is
we're looking for Unique Solutions uh we
want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it so we're
looking at uh our different system
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment uh we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks um there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees the
data provided is labeled data with
output values specified and this is
important because when we talk about
supervised learning you already know the
answer for all this information you
already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that um the
outcome for tomorrow for you know going
back a week you're looking at stock you
can already have like the graph of what
the next day looks like so you have an
answer for
it and you have labeled data which is
used you have an external supervision
and solves Problems by mapping labeled
input to No One output so very
controlled unsupervised learning and
unsupervised learning is really
interesting because it's now taking part
in many other models they start with an
you can actually insert an unsupervised
learning model um in almost either
supervised or reinforcement learning as
part of the system which is really cool
uh data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions used to solve
association with clustering problems
unlabeled data used no supervision
solves Problems by understanding
patterns and discovering output
uh so you can look at this and you can
think um some of these things go with
each other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this um when you
start getting into those are some really
cool images that come up of what
unsupervised learning is how it can pick
out say uh the area of a donut one model
will see the area of the doughnut and
the other one will divide it into three
sections based on this location versus
what's next to it so there's a lot of
stuff that goes in with unsupervised
learning and then we're looking at
reinforcement learning probably the
biggest industry in today's market uh in
machine learning or growing Market it's
very it's very infant stage uh as far as
how it works and what it's going to be
capable of the machine learns from its
environment using rewards and errors
used to solve reward based problems no
predefined data is used no supervision
follows Trail and error problem solving
approach
uh so again we have a random first you
start with a random I try this it works
and this is my reward doesn't work very
well maybe or maybe doesn't even get you
where you're trying to get it to do and
you get your reward back and then it
looks at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route so let's take a look at
important terms in today's reinforcement
model and this has become pretty
standardized over the last uh few years
so these are really good to know we have
the agent uh agent is the model that is
being trained via reinforcement learning
so this is your actual U entity that has
however you're doing it whether you're
using a neural network or a q table or
whatever combination thereof this is the
actual agent that you're using this is
the
model and you have your environment uh
the training situation that the model
must optimized to is called its
environment uh and you can see here I
guess we have a robot who's trying to
get a chest full of gyms or whatever and
that's the output and then you have your
action this is all possible steps that
can be taken by the model and it picks
one action and you can see here it's
picked three different uh routes to get
to the chest of diamonds and
gems we have a state the current
position condition returned by the
model and you could look at this uh if
you're playing like a video game this is
the screen you're looking at uh so when
you go back here uh the environment is a
whole game board so if you're playing
one of those Mobius games you might have
the whole game board going on uh but
then you have your current position
where are you on that game board what's
around that what's around you um if you
were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard where it is in the yard and what it
can see what input it has in that
location that would be the current
position condition returned by the model
and then the reward uh to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so yeah you
did good or if uh didn't do as good
trying to maximize the reward and have
the best reward
possible and then policy policy
determines how an agent will behave at
any time it acts as a mapping between
action and present State this is part of
the model what what is your action that
you're you're going to take what's the
policy you're using to have an output
from your agent one of the reasons they
separate uh policy as its own entity is
that you usually have a prediction um of
a different options and then the policy
well how am I going to pick the best
based on those predictions I'm going to
guess at different options and we'll
actually weigh those options in and find
the best option we think will work uh so
it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works let's go Ahad and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example and just
in looking at this we're going to take a
look uh consider what a dog um that we
want to train uh so the dog would be
like the agent so you have your your
puppy or whatever uh and then your
environment is going to be the whole
house or whatever it is where you're
training them and then you have an
action we want to teach the dog to
fetch so action equals fetching uh and
then we have a little biscuit so we can
get the dog to perform various actions
by offering incentives such as a dog
biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself uh so you have B
you know so we start off with fetching
it goes oh I get a biscuit for that it
tries something else and you get a
handshake or begging or something like
that and it goes oh this is also
reward-based and so it kind of explores
things to find out what will bring it is
biscuit and that's very much like how a
reinforced model goes is it uh looks for
different rewards how do I find can I
try different things and find a reward
that
works the dog also will want to run
around and play and explorers
environment uh this quality of model is
called exploration so there's a little
Randomness going on in
Exploration and explores new parts of
the house climbing on the sofa doesn't
get a reward in fact it usually gets
kicked off the
sofa so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process uh markov's
decision process is a reinforcement
learning policy used to map a current
state to an action where the agent
continuously interacts with the
environment to produce new Solutions and
receive rewards and you'll see here's
all of our different uh uh vocabulary we
just went over we have a reward our
state or agent our environment
interaction and so even though the
environment kind of contains everything
um that you you really when you're
actually writing the program you're
environment is going to put out a reward
in state that goes into the agent uh the
agent then looks at this uh state or it
looks at the reward usually um first and
it says okay I got rewarded for whatever
I just did or I didn't get rewarded and
then it looks at the state then it comes
back and if you remember from policy the
policy comes in um and then we have a
reward the policy is that part that's
connected at the bottom and so it looks
at that policy and says hey what's a
good action that will probably be
similar to what I did or um sometimes
they're completely random but what's a
good action that's going to bring me a
different
reward so taking the time to just
understand these different pieces as
they go is pretty important in most of
the models today um and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using um
pretty straightforward as far as because
once you start seeing how it works uh
you can see your environment send says
hey this is the agent did this if you're
a character in a game this happened and
it shoots out a reward in a state the
agent looks at the reward looks at the
new state and then takes a little guess
and says I'm going to try this action
and then that action goes back into the
environment it affects the environment
the environment then changes depending
on what the action was and then it has a
new state and a new reward that goes
back to the agent so in the diagram
shown we need to find the shortest path
between node A and D each path has a
reward associated with it and the path
with the maximum reward is what we want
to choose the nodes a b c d denote the
nodes to travel from node uh A to B is
an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path
taken and you can see here a can go uh
to b or a can go to C right off the bat
or it can go right to D and if you
explored all three of these uh you would
find that a going to D was a zero reward
um a going to C and D would generate a
different reward or you could go AC BD
there's a lot of options here um and so
when we start looking at this diagram
you start to
realize that even though uh today's
reinforced learning models do really
good uh um finding an answer they end up
trying almost all the different
directions you see and so they take up a
lot of work uh or a lot of processing
time for reinforcement learning they're
right now in their infant stage and
they're really good at solving simple
problems and we'll take a look at one of
those in just a minute in a tic tac toe
game uh but you can see here uh once
it's gone through these and it's
explored it's going to find the
ACD is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it so let's go ahead and take
a look at a reinforcement learning
demo uh in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game Against the Machine learning
model and we'll go ahead we're doing it
in Python so let's go ahead and go
through um I always uh not always
actually have a lot of python tools
let's go through um Anaconda which will
open up a Jupiter notebook seems like a
lot of steps but it's worth it to keep
all my stuff separate and it's also has
a nice display when you're in the
Jupiter notebook for doing
python so here's our an cond to
navigator I open up the notebook which
is going to take me to a web page and
I've gone in here and created a new uh
python folder in this case I've already
done it and enabled it to change the
name to tic-tac-toe uh and then for this
example uh we're going to go ahead
and import a couple things we're going
to um import numpy as NP we'll go ahead
and import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then uh pickle is just
a nice way sometimes for storing uh
different information uh different
states that we're going to go through on
here uh and so we're going to create a
class called State we're going to start
with
that and there's a lot of lines of code
to this uh class that we're going to put
in here don't let that scare you too
much there's not as much here um it
looks like there's going to be a lot
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class date
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it um we have our board um
it's a tic teac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board uh
we have player one player
two uh is in we're going to create a
board hash uh we'll look at that in just
a minute we're just going to stir some
information in there symbol of player
equals one um so there's a few things
going on as far as the
initialization uh then something simple
we're just going to get the hash um of
the board we're going to get the
information from the board on there
which is uh columns and rows we want to
know when a winner occurs uh so if you
get three in a row that's what this
whole section here is for uh me go ahead
and scroll up a little bit and you can
get a copy of this code if you send a
note over to Simply learn we'll send you
over um this particular file and you can
play with it yourself and see how it's
put together I don't want to spend a
huge amount of time on this uh because
this is just some real General python
coding
uh but you can see here we're just going
through um all the rows and you add them
together and if it equals three three in
a row same thing with
columns um diagonal so you got to check
the diagonal that's what all this stuff
does here is it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and
put there we
go um and then it comes down here and we
do our sum and it says true uh minus
three just says did somebody win or is
it a tie so you got to add up all the
numbers on there anyway just in case
they're all filled up and next we also
need to know available positions um
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before this way when you try
something or the computer tries
something uh it's not going to give it
an illegal move that's what the
available positions is doing uh then we
want to update our state and so you have
your position going in we're just
sending in the position that you just
chose and you'll see there's a little
user interface we put in there you P
pick the row and colum in
there and again I mean this is a lot of
code uh so really it's kind of a thing
you'd want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it uh great way to understand
how this works and here is a given
reward um so we're going to give a
reward result equals self winner this is
one of the hearts of what's going on
here uh is we have a result self. winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result if the result equals one here's
our
feedback uh if it doesn't equal one then
it gets a zero so it only gets a reward
in this particular case if it
wins and that's important to know
because different uh systems of
reinforced learning do rewarding a lot
differently depending on what you're
trying to do this is a very simple
example with a a 3X3 board imagine if
you're playing a video game uh certainly
you only have so many actions but your
environment is huge you have a lot going
on in the environment and suddenly a
reward system like this is going to be
just um it's going to have to change a
little bit it's going to have to have
different rewards and different setup
and there's all kinds of advanced ways
to do that as far as weighing you add
weights to it and so they can add the
weights up depending on where the reward
comes in so it might be that you
actually get a reward in this case you
get the reward at the end of the game
and I'm spending just a little bit of
time on this because this is an
important thing to note but there's
different ways to add up those rewards
it might have like if you take a certain
path um the first reward is going to be
weighed a little bit less than the last
reward because the last reward is
actually winning the game or scoring or
whatever it is so this reward system
gets really complicated on some of the
more advanced uh
setups um in this case though you you
can see right here that they give a um a
0.1 and a 0.5
reward um just for getting a picking the
right value and something that's
actually valid instead of picking an
invalid value so rewards again that's
like key it's huge how do you feed the
rewards back in uh then we have a board
reset that's pretty straightforward it
just goes back and resets the board to
the beginning because it's going to try
out all these different things while
it's learning it's going to do it by
trial and error so you have to keep
resetting it and then of course there's
the play we want to go ahead and play uh
rounds equals 100 depends on what you
want to do on here um you can set this
different you obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here uh
that we have player one and player two
this is this is the computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game or even learn
something that isn't a game is to have
two of these
models that are basically trying to beat
each other and so they they keep finding
explore new things this one works for
this one so this one tries new things it
beats this we've seen this in um chess I
think was a big one where they had the
two players in chess with reinforcement
learning uh was one of the ways they
train one of the top um computer chess
playing
algorithms uh so this is just what this
is it's going to choose an action it's
going to try something and the more it
tries stuff
um the more we're going to record the
hash we actually have a board hash where
they self get the hash setup on here
where it stores all the
information and then once you get to a
win one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is uh we're going
to play with a human so we'll get a
chance to come in here and see what that
looks like when you put your own
information in and then it just comes in
here does the same thing it did above it
gives it a reward for its things um or
sees if it wins or ties um looks at
available positions all that kind of fun
stuff and then finally we want to show
the board uh so it's going to print the
board out each
time really um as an integration is not
that exciting what's exciting uh in here
is one looking at this reward system
whoops Play One More up the reward
system is really the heart of this how
do you reward the different uh setup and
the other one is when it's playing it's
got to take an action and so what it
chooses for an action is also the heart
of reinforcement learning how do we
choose that action and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is um in today's uh technology
is uh figuring this out how do we reward
it and how do we guess the next best
action so we have our uh environment and
you can see the environment is we're
going to be or the state uh which is
kind of like what's going on we're going
to return the state depending on what
happens and we want to go ahead and
create our agent uh in this CL our
player so each one is let me go and grab
that and so we look at a class player
um this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
uh that it can look at and a reward uh
so we want to take a look at this we
have a name uh self State this is class
player and when you say class player
we're not talking about a human player
we're talking about um just a uh the
computer players and this is kind of
interesting so remember I told you
depending on what you're doing there's
going to be a Decay gamma um explore
rate uh these are what I'm talking about
is how do we train it um as you try
different moves it gets to the end the
first move is important but it's not as
as important as the last one and so you
could say that the last one has the
heaviest weight and then as you as you
get there the first one let's see the
first move gives you a five reward the
second gives you a two reward and the
third one gives you a 10 reward because
that's the final ending you got it the
10's going to count more than the first
step uh and here's our uh we're going to
you know get the board information
coming in and then choose an action this
was the second part that I was talking
about that was so important uh so once
you have your training going on we have
to do a little Randomness and you can
see right here is our NP random um
uniform so it's picking out a random
number take a random action this is
going to just pick which row and which
column it is um and so choosing the
action this one you can see we're just
doing random States um Choice length of
positions action position and then it
skips in there and takes a look at the
board uh for p in positions you get it's
actually storing the different boards
each time you go through so it it has a
record of what it did so it can properly
weigh the values and this simply just
depins a hash State what's the last
state pin it to the uh um to our states
on here here's our
feedback reward so the reward comes in
and it's going to take a look at this
and say is it none uh what is the reward
and here is that formula remember I was
telling you about up here um that was
important because it has Decay gamma
times the reward this is where as it
goes through each step and this is
really important this is this is kind of
the heart of this of what I was talking
about earlier uh you have step
one and this might have a a reward of
two you have step two I should probably
should have done ABC this has a step
three uh step
four so on till you get to step in and
this might have a reward of
10 uh so reward a
10 we're going to add that but we're not
adding uh let's say this one right here
uh let's say this reward here right
before 10 was um let's say it's also 10
that just makes a the math easy so we
had 10 and 10 we had 10 this is 10 and
10 in whatever it is but it's time it's
0. n uh so instead of putting a full 10
here we only do n that's a 0.9
times
10 and so this
formula um as far as the Decay times the
reward minus the cell State value uh it
basically adds in it says here's one or
here's two I'm sorry I should have done
this AB BC would have been easier uh so
the first move goes in here and it puts
two in
here uh then we have our self uh setup
on here you can see how this gets pretty
complicated in the math but this is
really the key is how do we train our
states and we want the the final State
the win to get the most points if you
win you get most points um and the first
step gets the least amount of points so
you're really training this almost in
Reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now where I
need to sum up my rewards and I want to
sum them up going in reverse and I want
to find the answer in Reverse kind of an
interesting uh uh play on the mind when
you're trying to figure this stuff
out and of course we want to go ahead
and reset the board down here uh and
save the policy load
policy these are the different things
that are going in between the agent and
the state to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up up and
then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human
player and the human player is going to
be a little different uh in that uh you
choose an action row and column here's
your action uh if action is if action in
positions meaning positions that are
available uh you return the action if
not it just keeps asking you until you
get an action that actually works and
then we're going to go ahead a PIN to
the hash state which we don't need to
worry about because it Returns the
action up
here and feed forward uh again this is
because it's a
human um at the end of the game bat
propagate and update State values this
part isn't being done because it's not
programming uh the model uh the model is
getting its own rewards so we've gone
ahead and loaded this in here uh so
here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up uh P1 player one uh P2 player
two and then we're going to send our
players to our state so now it has P1 P2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50,000 rounds now we can probably
do a lot less than this and it's not
going to get the full results in fact
you know what uh let's go ahead and just
do five um just to play with it because
I want to show you something
here oops somewhere in there I forgot to
load something
there we go I must have start forgot to
run this
run oops forgot a reference there for
the board rows and columns
3x3 um there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning uh so now I've only set this
up with um see where are we going here
I've only set this up to
train five times and the reason I did
that is we're going to uh come in and
actually play it and then I'm going to
change that and we can see how it
differs on
there there we go and I didn't even make
it through a run and we're going to go
ahead and save the
policy um so now we have our player one
and our player two policy uh the way we
set it up it has two separate policies
loaded up in
there and then we're going to come in
here and we're going to do uh player one
is going to be the computer experience
rate zero load policy one human player
human and we're going to go ahead and
play this I remember I only went through
it um uh just one round of training in
fact minimal training and so it puts an
X there and I'm going to go ahead and do
row zero column one you can see this is
very uh basic on here and so I put in my
zero and then I'm going to go zero block
it zero
Zer and you can see right here it let me
win uh just like that I was able to win
zero two and woo human winds so I only
trained it five times we're going to run
this again and this time uh instead of
five let's do 5,000 or 50,000 I think
that's what the guys in the back had and
this takes a while to train it this is
where reinforcement learning really
falls apart look how simple this game is
we're talking about uh 3x3 set of
columns and so for me to train it on
this um I could do a q table which would
take which would go much quicker um you
could build a quick Q table with almost
all the different options on there and
uh you would probably get a the same
result much quicker we're just using
this as an example so when we look at at
reinforcement learning you need to be
very careful what you apply it to it
sounds like a good deal until you do
like a large neural network where you're
doing um you set the neural network to a
learning increment of one so every time
it goes through it
learns and then you do your action so
you pick from the learning uh setup and
you actually try actions on the learning
setup until you get the what you think
is going to be the best action so you
actually feed what you think is right
back through the neural network there's
a whole layer there which is really fun
to play
with and then it has an output well
think of all those processes I mean that
is just a huge amount of work it's going
to do uh let's go ahead and Skip ahead
here give it a moment it's going to take
a a minute or two to go ahead and
run now to train it uh we went ahead and
let it run and it took a while this this
took um I got a pretty powerful
processor and it took about 5 minutes
plus to run it and we'll go ahead and
uh run our player setup on here oops I
brought in the last whoops I brought in
the last round so give me just a moment
to redo the policy save there we go I
forgot to save the policy back in
there and then go ahead and run our
player again so we we've saved the
policy then we want to go ahead and load
the policy for P1 as the computer and we
can see the computer's gone in the
bottom right corner I'm going to go
ahead and go uh one one which is the
center and it's gone right up the top
and if you have ever played tic-tac-toe
you know the computer has me uh but
we'll go ahead and play it out row zero
column
two there it is and then it's gone here
and so I'm going to go ahead and go row
01 two no 01 there we go and column zero
that's where I wanted oh and it says I
okay you your action there we go boom uh
so you can see here we've got a didn't
catch the win on this it said Tai um
kind of funny they didn't catch the win
on
there but if we play this a bunch of
times you'll find it's going to win more
and more the more we train it the more
the reinforcement
happens this lengthy training process uh
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning as this changes reinforcement
learning will be one of the more
powerful uh packages evolving over the
next decade or two in fact I would even
go as far as to say it is the most
important uh machine learning tool and
artificial intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple Tic Tac
Toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language if you're
translating a language or something from
one language to the other so much of it
is lost if you don't know the context
it's in what's the environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together is going to require
reinforcement learning to
do so again if you want to get a copy of
the Tic Tac Toe board it's kind of fun
to play with uh run it you can test it
out you can do um you know test it for
different uh uh values you can switch
from P1
computer um where we loaded the policy
one to load the policy 2 and just see
how it varies there's all kinds of
things you can do on there so what is Q
learning Q learning is reinforcement
learning policy which will fill the next
best action given a current state it
chooses this action at random and aims
to maximize the reward and so you can
see here's our standard reinforcement
learning graph um by now if you're doing
any reinforcement learning you should be
familiar with this where you have your
agent your agent takes an action the
action affects the environment and then
the environment sends back the reward or
the feedback and the state the new state
the agents in where is it at on the
chest board where's it at in the video
game um if your robots out there picking
trash up off the side of the road where
is it at on the road consider an ad
recommendation system usually when you
look up a product
online you get ads which will suggest
the same product over and over
again using Q learning we can make an ad
recommendation system which will suggest
related products to our previous
purchase the reward will be if user
clicks on on the suggested
product and again you can see um you
might have a lot of products on uh your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using Q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads and you
click on one of the ads it might go in
there and say okay this person clicked
on this ad what is the best set of ads
based on clicking on this ad or these
two ads afterwards based on where they
are browsing so let's go a and take a
look at some important terms when we
talk about Q learning uh we have States
the state s represents the current
position of an agent in an
environment um the action the action a
is the step taken by the agent when it
is particular State rewards for every
action the agent will get a positive or
negative
[Music]
reward and again uh when we talk about
States we're usually not with when you
using a q table you're not usually
talking about float variables you're
talking about true false um and we'll
take a closer look at that in a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating State and can't take a new
action uh this might be if you're
playing a video game your character
stepped in and is now dead or whatever
uh Q values used to determine how good
an action a taken at a particular State
s is QA of s and temporal difference a
formula used to find the Q value by
using the value of the current state and
action and previous state and action and
very I mean there's bellman's equation
which basically is the equation that
kind of uh covers what we just looked at
in all those different terms the Bellman
equation is used to determine the values
of a particular State and deduce how
good it is to be in take that state the
optimal the optimal state will give us
the highest optimal value in Factor
influencing Q values the current state
and action that's your saay so your
current state and your
action uh then you have your previous
date in action which is your s um I
guess Prime I'm not sure how they how
they reference that S Prime a prime so
this is what happened before uh then you
have a reward for Action so you have
your R reward and you have your maximum
expected future
reward and you can see there's also a a
learning rate put in there and a
discount rate uh so we're looking at
these just like any other model we don't
want to have an absolute um final value
on here we don't want it to if you do
absolute values instead of taking
smaller steps you don't really have that
approach to the solution you just have
it jump and then pretty soon if you jump
one solution out that's what's going to
be the new solution whichever one jumps
up really high first um kind of ruining
the whole idea of doing a random
selection and I'll go into the random
selection in just a second steps in Q
learning step one create an initial Q
table with all values initialized to
zero again we're looking at 0o one uh so
are you you know here's our action we
start we're an idol we took a wrong
action we took a correct action and int
and then we have our um actions fetching
sitting and running and of course we're
just using the dog example and choose an
action and perform it update values in
the table and of course when we're
choosing an action we're going to kind
of do something random and just randomly
pick one so you start out and you sit
and you have then a um then depending on
that um um action you took you can now
update the value for sitting after you
start from start to
sitting get the value of the reward and
calculate the Val the value Q value
using the Bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to
sitting and when we attach all those
rewards we continue the same until the
table's filled with or an episode
ends and and my IM is going to come back
to the random side of this and there's a
few different formulas they use for the
random um setup to pick it I usually let
whatever Q model I'm using do their
standard one because someone's usually
going in and done the math uh for the
optimal uh spread uh but you can look at
this if I had have running has a reward
of 10 sitting has a reward of seven
fetching has a reward of five um just
kind of without doing like a a a means
you know using the bell curve for the
means value and like I said there's some
math you can put in there to pick um so
that you're more like so that running
has even a higher chance um but even if
you were just going to do an average on
this you could do an average a random
number by adding them all together uh so
you get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is 22 you could
do 0 to 22 and or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22
one to five would be fetching uh and so
forth you know the last 10 so you can
just look at this as what percentage are
you going to go for that particular
option um and then that gets your random
setup in there and then as you slowly
increment these up uh you see that uh um
if you're idle um where's one here we go
sitting at the end if you're at the end
of wherever you're at that sitting gets
a reward of one um where's the good one
on here oh wrong action running for a
wrong action gets almost no reward so
that becomes very very less likely to
happen but it still might happen it
still might have a percentage of coming
up and that's where the random
programming and Q learning comes in the
below table gives us an idea of how many
times an action has been taken and how
positively correct action or negatively
wrong action it is going to affect the
next state so let's go ahead dive in and
pull up a little piece of code and see
what this looks like um in
Python uh in this demo we will use Q
learning to find the shortest path
between two given points if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more if
you've seen my videos before um I like
to do it in the uh Anaconda Jupiter
notebook
um setup just because it's really easy
to see and it's a nice demo uh and so
here's my anaconda this one I'm actually
using uh python 36 environment that I
set up in here and we'll go ahead and
launch the Jupiter Notebook on this and
once we in our Jupiter notebook uh which
has the kernel loaded with Python 3
we'll go ahead and create a new Python 3
uh folder in
here and we'll call this uh
Q learning
and to start this
demo let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's import
it and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together um and then you end up with
this really short answer at the
end uh and we'll we'll take a look at
that as we come into it so we we go
ahead and start with our location to
State uh so we have um L1 L2 these are
are nine locations 1 to n and then of
course the state is going to be 0 1 2 3
4 it's just a mapping of our location to
a integer on there and then we have our
actions our actions are simply uh moving
from um One
location to another so I can go to I can
go to location zero I can go to location
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 uh so these are my
actions I can choose these are the
locations of our
state
and if you remember earlier I mentioned
uh um that the limitation is that you
you don't want to put in um a
continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic Q table
where you continually add in new values
as they
arise because um if you have float
values this just becomes infinite and
then your memory in your computer's gone
or you know does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the Q uh
T learning setup but there are ways to
use it in conjunction with other systems
and so you might look
at uh well I do um been doing some work
in stock um and one of the questions
that comes out is to buy or sell the
stock and the stake coming in might be
um you might take it in create what
called
buckets um where anything that you
predict is going to return more than a
certain amount of money um the error for
that stock that you've had in the past
you put those in buckets and suddenly as
you start putting the creating these
buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have um bucket one two three and
four and then you can take those buckets
put them through a a q learning table
and come up with the best action which
stock should I buy it's like gambling
stock is pretty much gambling if you're
doing day trading you're not doing
long-term um Investments and so you can
start looking at it like that a lot of
the um current feeds say that the best
algorithms used for day Traders where
you're doing it on your own is really to
ask the question do I want to trade the
stock yes or no and now you have it in a
q learning table and now you can take it
to that next level and you can see where
that can be a really powerful tool at
the end of doing a basic linear
regression model or something um what is
the best investment and you start
getting the best reward on
there uh and so if we're going to have
rewards these rewards we just
create um it says uh if basically if
you're um this should match our Q table
because it's going to be uh you have
your state and you have your action
across the top if you remember from the
dog and so we have whatever state we're
in going down and then the next action
and what the reward is for it um and of
course if you were actually doing a um
something more connected your reward
would be based on um the actual
environment it's in and then we want to
go ahead and create a state to location
uh so we can map the
indexes so just like we defined our
rewards uh we're going to go and do
state to location um and you can see
here it's a a dictionary setup for
location State and location to state
with
items and we also need to um Define what
we want for learning rates uh you
remember we had our two different rates
um as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to uh 75 and the
alpha set to 0.9 and we'll see that when
we do the formula and of course any of
this code uh send a note to our simply
learn team they'll get you a copy of
this code on here let's go ahead and
pull there we go
the new next two
sections um since we're going to keep it
short and
sweet here we go so let's go ahead and
create our agent um so our agent is
going to have our initialization where
we send it all the information uh we'll
Define our s gamma equals gamma we could
have just set the gamma rate down here
instead of uh submitting it it's kind of
nice to keep them separate because you
can play with these numbers uh our self
Alpha um then we have our location State
we'll set that in here uh we have our
choice of actions um we're going to go
ahead and just embed the rewards right
into the agent so obviously this would
be coming from somewhere else uh instead
of from uh self-generated and then a
self state to location equals our state
to location uh dictionary and we go
ahead and create a q learning table and
I went ahead and just set the Q learning
table up to uh
0o to zero what what what the setup is
location to State how many of them are
there this just creates an array of zero
to zero setup on
there and then the big part is the
training we have our rewards new equals
a copy of self.
rewards ending State equals the
self-location state in location so this
is whatever we end up at rewards new
equals ending State plus ending State
equals 999 just kind of goes
to a dead end and we start going through
iterations and we'll go ahead um let's
do this uh so this we're going to come
back and we're going to call call it on
here uh let me just erase that switch it
to an
arrow there we go uh so what we're doing
is we're going to send in here to train
it we're going to say hey um I want to
iterate through this a thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be instead of iterating you
might have your external environment and
they're going back and forth and you
iterate through outside of here uh but
just for ease of use our agent's going
to come in here and iterate through this
sometimes I'll put this iteration in
here and I'll have it call the
environment and say hey this is what I
did what's the next state and the
environment does its thing right in here
as I iterate through
it uh and then we want to go ahead and
pick a random state to start with that's
what's going on here you have to start
somewhere um and then you have your
playable actions we're going to start
with just an empty thing for playable
actions and we'll fill that up so that's
what choices I have and so we're going
to iterate through the rewards Matrix to
get the states uh directly reachable
from the randomly chosen current state
assign those states to a list named
playable
actions and so you can see here we have
uh range nine I usually use length of
whatever I'm looking at uh which is our
locations or States as they are uh we
have a reward so we want to look at the
current the rewards uh the new
reward is our uh is in our chart here of
rewards uncore new uh current state um
plus J uh J being what is the next date
we want to try and so we goe and do our
playable actions and we append J
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better
reward and then of course we go ahead
and choose our next State uh so we have
our random Choice playable actions and
if you remember I mentioned on this let
me just go ahead and uh whoops let's do
a free form when we were talking about
the next State uh this right here just
does a random selection instead of a
random uh selection ction you might do
something where uh whatever the best
selection is which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops and we start looking at
these averages and these spreads um or
we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those uh so those are some of the
options we have in here we just go with
a random Choice uh that's usually where
you start play with it um and then we
have our reward section down here and so
we want to go ahead and find well in
this case a temporal difference uh so
you have your rewards new plus the self
gamma and this is the formula we were
looking at this is bellman's equation
here uh so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that um and we can add it all together
this is of course our uh uh maximum
expected future setup in here uh so this
is all of our our bellman's equation
that we're looking at here and then we
come up in here and we update our Q
table that's all this is on this one
that's right here we have um self Q
current state next state and we add in
our um Alpha because we don't want to we
don't want to train all of it at once in
case there's slight differential coming
in there we want to slowly approach the
answer uh and then we have our route
equals a start
location and next location equals start
location so we're just incrementing we
took a step forward and then finally
remember I was telling you how uh we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path we're going to
go ahead and and get the optimal route
we want to find the best route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here just scroll
down for that and we get the optimal
route route we go ahead and put the
information in including the Q table
self uh start location in location next
location route q and it says while next
location is not equal to in location so
while we can still go our start location
equals self location to State start
location so we already have our best
value for the start
location uh the next state looks at the
Q table and says hey what's H the next
one with the best value and then the
next location we go ahead and pull that
in and we just append it that's what's
going on down
here and then our start location equals
the next location and we just go through
all the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this and now that we have our Q table
our um Q agent loaded we're going to go
ahead and uh take our Q agent load them
up with our Alpha Gamma that we set up
above um along with the location step
action reward state to
location and uh our goal is to plot a
course between L9 and
L1 and we're going to go through aund a
thousand iterations on here and so when
I run that it runs pretty quick uh why
is this so fast um if youve been running
neural networks and you've been doing
all these other models you sit here and
wait a long time well we're a very small
amount of data these are all integers
these aren't float values there's not a
the math is not heavy on the on the
processing end and this is where Q
tables are so powerful if you have a
small amount of information coming in
you very quickly uh get an answer off of
this even though we went through it a
thousand times to train it and you'll
see here we have l985 2 and one and
that's based on our reward table we had
set up on there and this is the shortest
path going between these different uh
setups in here and if you remember in
our reward table uh you can see that if
you start here you can go to here
there's places you can't go that's how
this reward table was set up so I can
only go to certain
places uh so kind of a little maze setup
in there and you can play with it this
is really fun uh setup to play with uh
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like I was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup in model and predictions where you
put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action long as you can
take that course of action and and uh uh
reduce it down to a yes no um or if
you're using text you can use a one hot
encoder which word is next there's all
kinds of things you can do with a Q
table uh depending on just how much
information you're putting in there so
that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've uh found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point A to point B and what
available actions there are hello and
welcome to this tutorial on deep
learning my name is moan and in the next
about 1 one and a half hours I will take
you through what is deep learning and
into tensorflow environment to show you
an example of deep learning now there
are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
Innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network work
with millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or or U
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have Tred
it can be completely different that is
the whole idea of training it will be
able to recognize for example that this
is a picture from Paris because it is
able to recognize the eiel T so the way
it works internally if we have to look a
little bit under the H is these images
are nothing but this is digital
information in the form of pixels so
each image could be a certain size it
can be 256x 256 pixel kind of a
resolution and then each pixel is either
having a certain grade of color and all
that is fed into the neural network and
it then gets trained in and it's able to
based on these pixels pixel information
it is able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural network so we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or nor and so on using
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural
networks works so how do we do the
training of neural networks and at the
end we will end up with a small demo
code which will take you through intens
of flow now in order to implement deep
learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tens oflow flow
is one of them so the focus at the end
of this would be on how to use tensor
flow to write a piece of code using
python as a programming language and we
will take up a an example which is a
very common one which is like the hollow
world of deep learning the handwriting
number recognition which is a mnist
commonly known as mnist database so we
will take a look at memus database and
how we can train a neural network to
recognize handwritten number
so that's what you will see in this
particular video so let's get started
what is deep learning deep learning is
like a subset of what is known as a high
level concept called artificial
intelligence you must be already
familiar must have heard about this term
artificial intelligence so artificial
intelligence is like the high level
concept if you will and in order to
implement artificial intelligence
applications we use what is known as
machine learning and within machine
learning a subset of machine learning is
deep learning machine learning is a
little bit more generic concept and deep
learning is one type of machine learning
if you will and we will see a little
later in maybe the following slides a
little bit more in detail how deep
learning is different from traditional
machine learning but to start with we
can mention here that deep learning uses
one of the differentiators between deep
learning and traditional machine
learning is that deep learning uses
neural networks and we will talk about
what are neural networks and how we can
Implement neural networks and so on and
so forth as a part of this tutorial so a
little deeper into deep learning deep
learning primarily involves working with
complicated unstructured data compared
to traditional machine learning with
where we normally use structured data in
deep learning the data would be
primarily IM images or Voice or maybe
text file so and it is large amount of
data as well and deep learning can
handle complex operations it involves
complex operations and the other
difference between traditional machine
learning and deep learning is that the
feature extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists v data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens autom
atically and of course deep learning for
large amounts of data complicated
unstructured data deep learning gives
very good performance now as I mentioned
one of the secret sources of deep
learning is neural networks let's see
what neural networks is neural networks
is based on our biological neurons the
whole concept of deep learning and
artificial intelligence is based on
human brain brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how about
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dries and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what what exactly
weights and biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic units is a
perceptron so what is a perceptron A
perceptron can be considered as one of
the fundamental units of neural networks
it can consist at least one neuron but
sometimes it can be more than one neuron
but you can create a perceptron with a
single neuron and it can be used to
perform certain functions it can be used
as a basic binary class classifier it
can be trained to do some basic binary
classification and this is how a basic
perceptron looks like and this is
nothing but a neuron you have inputs X1
X2 X to xn and there is a summation
function and then there is what is known
as an activation function and based on
this input what is known as the weighted
sum the activation function either gets
gives an output like a zero or a one so
we say the neuron is either activated or
not so that's the way it works so you
get the inputs these inputs are each of
the inputs are multiplied by a weight
and there is a bias that gets added and
that whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjust the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like X1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that sum wi
ixi Sigma of that which is the sum of
all these product of X and W is added up
and then a bias is added to that the
biases not dependent on the input but or
the input values but the bias is common
for one neuron however the bias value
keeps changing during the training
process once the training is completed
the values of these weights W1 W2 and so
on and the value of the bias gets fixed
so that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this wixi
summation plus b is passed through
activation function and then the neuron
gets either fired or not and based on
that there will be an output that output
is compared with the actual or expected
value which is also known as labeled
information so this is the process of
supervised learning so the output is
already known and um that is compared
and thereby we know if there is an error
or not and if there is an error the
error is fed back and the weights and
biases are updated accordingly till the
error is reduced to the minimum so this
iterative process is known as perceptron
Lo learning or perceptron learning Rule
and this error needs to be minimized so
till the error is minimized this
iteratively the weights and biases keep
changing and that is what is the
training process so the whole idea is to
update the weights and the bias of the
perceptron till the error is minimized
the error need not be zero Terror may
not ever reach zero but the idea is to
keep changing these weights and bias so
that the error is minimum the minimum
possible that it can have so this whole
process is an iterative process and this
is the iteration continues till either
the error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
Within These given conditions now in
1943 two scientists Warren mik and
Walter pittz came up with an experiment
with where they were able to implement
the logical functions like and or and
nor using neurons and that was a
significant breakthrough in a sense so
they were able to come up with the most
common logical Gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical Gates which could take two
inputs Like A and B and then give a
corresponding result so for example in
case of an an gate A and B and then the
output is a in case of an R gate it is a
plus b and so on and so forth and they
were able to do this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these Gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for XR and we will see
why that is in a little bit so this is
how an endgate works the inputs A and B
the output should be fired or the neuron
should be fired only only when both the
inputs are one so if you have 0 0 the
output should be zero for 0 1 it is
again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1 one the output
should be one so how do we implement
this with a neuron so it was found that
by changing the values of Weights it is
possible to achieve this logic so for
example if we have equal weights like 7
7 and then if we take the sum of the
weighted product so for example 7 into 0
and then 7 into 0 will give you 0er and
so on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are one you get a
value which is greater than one which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
there is an output in all the other
cases there is no output because the
threshold value is one so this is
implementation of an and gate using a
single perceptron or a single neuron
similarly an orgate in order to
implement an orgate in in case of an
orgate the output will be one if either
of these inputs is one so for example 01
will result in one or rather in all the
cases it is one except for 0 0 so how do
we implement this using a perceptron
once again if you have a perceptron with
weights for example 1.2 now if you see
here if in the first case when both are
zero the output is zero in the second
case when it is 0 and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0
and then 1.2 into 1 is 1 1 and in the
second case similarly the output is 1.2
in the last case when both the inputs
are one the output is 2.4 so during the
training process these weights will keep
changing and then at one point where the
weights are equal to W1 is equal to 1.2
and W2 is equal to 1.2 the system learns
that it gives the correct output so that
is implementation of orgate using a
single neuron or a single layer
perceptron now Exar gate this was one of
the challenging ones they tried to
implement an Exar gate with a single
level perceptron but it was not possible
and therefore in order to implement an
XR so this was like a a roadblock in the
progress of U neural network however
subsequently they realize that this can
be implemented an XR gate can be
implemented using a multi-level
perceptron or MLP so in this case there
are two layers instead of a single layer
and this is how you can Implement an XR
gate so you will see that X1 and X2 are
the inputs and there is a hidden layer
and that's why it is denoted as H3 and
H4 and then you take the output of that
and feed it to the output at 05 and
provide a threshold here so we will see
here that this is the numerical
calculation so the weights are in this
case for X1 it is 20 and- - 20 and once
again 20 and minus 20 so these inputs
are fed into H3 and H4 so you will see
here for H3 the input is 0 1 1 1 and for
H4 it is 1 1 1 and if you now look at
the output final output where the
threshold is taken as one if we use a
sigmoid with the threshold one you will
see that in these two cases it is zero
and in the last two cases it is one so
this is a implementation of XR in case
of XR only when one of the inputs is one
you will get an output so that is what
we are seeing here if we have either
both the inputs are one or both the
inputs are zero then the output should
be zero so that is what is an exclusive
orgate so it is exclusive because only
one of the inputs should be one and then
only you'll get an output of one which
is Satisfied by this condition so this
is a special implementation XR gate is a
special implementation ation of
perceptron now that we got a good idea
about perceptron let's take a look at
what is the neural network so we have
seen what is a perceptron we have seen
what is a neuron so we will see what
exactly is a neural network so neural
network is nothing but a network of
these neurons and there are different
types of neural networks there are about
five of them these are artificial neural
network convolutional neural network
then recursive neural network or
recurrent neural network nwork deep
neural network and deep belief Network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas RNN are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphao
which is a game created by a startup
called Deep Mind which got acquired by
Google and alphago is an AI which
defeated the human world champion lead
all in this game of Go so keep gaming is
an area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of research
happens in the area of gaming as well in
addition to that nowadays there are
neural networks or special type called
generative adversarial networks which
can be used for synthesizing either
images or music or text and so on and
they can be used to compose music so the
neural network can be trained to compose
a certain kind of music and and
autonomous cars you must be familiar
with Google Google's self-driving car
and today a lot of Automotive companies
are investing in this space and uh deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous Cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road the the
lane markings on the road signals any
objects that are in front any
obstruction and so on and so forth so
all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including Sofia you may be familiar with
Sophia who was given a citizenship by
Saudi Arabia and there are several such
robots which are very humanlike and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
Diagnostics and healthc Care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used used and within Healthcare
Diagnostics again there are multiple
areas where deep learning and image
recognition image procing can be used
for example for cancer detection as you
may be aware if cancer is detected early
on it can be cured and one of the
challenges is in the availability of
Specialists who can diagnose cancer
using these diagnostic images and
various scans and and so on and so forth
so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the load on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologist
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be lung
cancer it can be breast cancer and so on
and so forth so Healthcare is a major
area where deep learning is being
applied let's take a look at the inner
working of a neural network so how does
an artificial neural network let's say
identify can we train a neural network
to identify the shapes like squares and
circles and triangles when these images
are fed so this is how it works any
image is nothing but it is a digital
information of the pixels so in this
particular case let's say this is an
image of 28x 28 pixel and this is an
image of a square there's a certain way
in which the pixels are lit up and so
these pixels have a certain value maybe
from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of 784 pixels so all the
information what is inside this image
can be kind of compressed into the 784
pixels the way each of these pixels is
lit up provides information about what
exactly is the image so we can train
neural networks to use that information
and identify the images so let's take a
look how this works so each neuron the
value if it is close to one that means
it is white whereas if it is close to
zero that means it is black now this is
a an animation of how this whole thing
works so these pixels one of the ways of
doing it is we can flatten this image
and take this complete 784 pixels and
feed that as input to our neural network
the neural network can consist of
probably several layers there can be a
few hidden layers and then there is an
input layer and an output layer now the
input layer take the 784 pixels as input
the values of each of these pixels and
then you get an output which can be of
three types or three classes one can be
a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process we
then send that error back and the
weights and the biases of these neurons
are adjusted till it correctly
identifies that this is a square that is
the whole training mechanism that
happens out
here now let's take a look at a circle
same way so you feed these 784 pixels
there is a certain pattern in which the
pixels are lit up and the neural network
is trained to identify that pattern and
during the training process once again
it would probably initially identify it
incorrectly saying this is a square or a
triangle and then that error is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct so that is the training process
so now we will take a look at same way a
triangle so now if you feed another
image which is consisting of triangles
so this is the training process now we
have trained our neural network to
classify these images into a triangle or
a circle and a square so now this neural
network can identify these three types
of objects now if you feed another image
and it will be able to identify whether
it's a square or a triangle or a circle
now what is important to be observed is
that when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that the image or the the
triangle is exactly in this position now
the neural network actually identifies
the patterns so even if the triangle is
let's say positioned here not exactly in
the middle but maybe at the corner or in
the side it would still identify that it
is a triangle and that is the whole idea
behind pattern Rec ition so how does
this training process work this is a
quick view of how the training process
works so we have seen that a neuron
consists of inputs it receives inputs
and then there is a weighted sum which
is nothing but this XI wi summation of
that plus the bias and this is then fed
to the activation function and that in
turn gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed Fe these images when you
send maybe a square it will identify it
as a triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights W1 W2 up to WN keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values could
be
0.525 35 and so on it could be positive
or it could be negative and the value
that is coming here is the pixel value
as we have seen it can be anything
between 0 to 1 you can scale it between
0 to 1 or 0 to 256 whichever way 0 being
black and 256 being white and then all
the other colors in between so that is
the input so these are numerical values
this multiplication or the product W ixi
is a numerical value and the bias is
also a numerical value you need to keep
in mind that the bias is fixed for a
neuron it doesn't change with the inputs
whereas the weights are one per input so
that is one important point to be noted
so but the bias also keeps changing
initially it will again have a random
value but as a part of the training
process the weights the values of the
weights W1 W2 WN and the value of B will
change and ultimately once the training
process is complete these values are
fixed for this particular neuron W1 W2
up to WN and plus the value of the B is
also fixed for this particular neuron
and in this way there will be multiple
neurons and each there may be multiple
levels of neurons here and that's the
way the training process works so this
is another example of multi-layer so
there are two hidden layers in between
and then you have the input layer values
coming from the input layer then it goes
through multiple layers hidden layers
and then there is an output layer and as
you can see there are weights and biases
for each of these neurons in each layer
and all of them gets keeps changing
during the training process and at the
end of the training process all these
weights have a certain value and that is
a trained model and those values will be
fixed once the training is completed all
right then there is something known as
activation function neural networks
consists of one of the components in
neural networks is activation function
and every neuron has an activation
function and there are different types
of activation functions that are used it
could be a relu it could be sigmoid and
so on and so forth and the activation
function is what decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not so whether
the output should be zero or one is
decided by the activation function and
the activation function in turn takes
the input which is the weighted sum
remember we talked about wixi + B that
weighted sum is fed as a input to the
activation function and then the output
can be either a zero or a one and there
are different types of activation
functions which are covered in an
earlier video you might want to watch
all right so as a part of the training
process we feed the inputs the labeled
data or the training data and then it
gives an output which is the predicted
output by the network which we indicate
as y hat and then there is a labeled
data because we for supervised learning
we already know what should be the
output so that is the actual output and
in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and U
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so and then all the errors are
added which can sometimes be called as
sum of squares some of square errors or
SSC and that is then fed as a feedback
in what is known as backward propagation
or back propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function is minimum now
there is a optimization technique which
is used here called gradient descent
optimization and this algorithm Works in
a way that the error which is the cost
function needs to be minimized so
there's a lot of mathematics that goes
behind this for example they find find
the uh local Minima the global Minima
using the differentiation and so on and
so forth but the idea is this so as a
training process as a as a part of
training the whole idea is to bring down
the error which is like let's say this
is the function the cost function at
certain levels it is very high the cost
value of the cost function the output of
the cost function is very high so the
weights have to be adjusted in such a
way and also the bias of course that the
cost function is minimized so there is
this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent you need to specify
what should be the learning rate and the
learning rate should be optimal because
if you have a very high learning rate
then the optimization will not converge
because at some point it will cross over
to to the side on the other hand if you
have very low learning rate then it
might take forever to convert so you
need to come up with the optimum value
of the learning rate and once that is
done using the gradient descent
optimization the error function is
reduced and that's like the end of the
training process all right so this is
another view of gradient descent so this
is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient desent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached the minimum value
and it will kind of try to stay here
this is known as the global Minima now
sometimes these curves may not be just
for explanation purpose this has been
drawn in a nice way but sometimes these
curves can be pretty erratic there can
be some local Minima here and then there
is a peak and then and so on so the
whole idea of gradient desent
optimization is to identify the global
Minima and to find the weights and the
bias at that particular point point so
that's what is gradient descent and then
this is another example so you can have
these multiple local minimum as you can
see at this point when it is coming down
it may appear like this is a minimum
value but then it is not this is
actually the global minimum value and
the gradient desent algorithm will make
an effort to reach this level and not
get stuck at this point so the algorithm
is already there and it knows how to
identify this Global minimum and that's
what it does during the training process
now in order to implement deep learning
there are multiple platforms and
languages that are available but the
most common platform nowadays is tensor
flow and so that's the reason we have uh
this tutorial we've created this
tutorial for tensorflow so we will take
you through a quick demo of how to write
a tensorflow code using Python and tlow
is uh an open source platform created by
Google so let's just take a look at the
details of tens oflow and so this is a a
library a python Library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like Java
and R and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so it is a
library for developing deep learning
applications especially using neural
networks and it consists of primarily
two parts if you will so one is the the
tensors and then the other is the graphs
of the flow that's the way the name
that's the reason for this kind of a
name called tensor flow so what are
tensors tensors are like
multi-dimensional arrays if you will
that's one way of looking at it so
usually you have a onedimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a onedimensional array
something like this which means this is
like a set of numbers so that is a one
dimension array then you can have a
two-dimensional array which is like a
matrix and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three-dimensional
array but tens of flow can handle many
more Dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tens of flow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tens oflow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensorflow is a
deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually execute that
particular graph in the form of what is
known as a session we will see this in
the tensor flow code as we move forward
so all the data is managed or
manipulated in tensors and then the
processing happens using this graph
there are certain terms called like for
example ranks of a tensor the rank of a
tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one-dimensional vector in which case the
rank is supposed to be one and then you
can have a
two-dimensional Vector typically like a
matrix then in that cas case we say the
rank is two and then if it is a
three-dimensional array then it rank is
three and so on so it can have more than
three as well so it is possible that you
can store multi-dimensional arrays in
the form of tensors so what are some of
the properties of tensor flow I think
today it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or Library it is
open source it's developed by Google
developed and maintained by Google but
it is open source one of the most
important things about tensorflow is
that it can run on CPUs as well as gpus
GPU is a graphical Processing Unit just
like CPU is central processing unit now
in earlier days GPU was used for
primarily for graphics and that's how
the name has come and one of the reasons
is that it cannot perform generic
activities very efficiently like CPU but
it can per perform iterative actions or
computations extremely fast and much
faster than a CPU so they are really
good for computational activities and in
deep learning there is a lot of
iterative computation that happens so in
the form of matrix multiplication and so
on so gpus are very well suited for this
kind of computation and tensor flow
supports both GPU as well as CPU and
there's a certain way of writing code in
tensor flow we will see as we go into to
the code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an Overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tens of flow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is um just a suggestion
but if you're already familiar with how
tensor FL works then probably yeah you
can go straight into the neural networks
part so so in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hollow world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
Ms database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and and with
amness database we can avoid that you
already have the data in the right
format which can be directly used for
training and amnest also offers a bunch
of built-in utility functions that we
can straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why amness database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensor flow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70,000 handwritten digits
and a large part of them are for
training then you have test just like in
any machine learning process and then
you have validation and all of them are
labeled so you have the images and they
label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are
handwritten images collected from a lot
of individual
people have these are samples written by
human beings they have handwritten these
numbers these numbers going from 0 to 9
so people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is amness
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our tensor flow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with the the label
information and uh the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for Simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two-dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it is a
28 by 28 so there are
7484 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our neural network and this is a
what is known as a softmax layer what it
does is once it is trained it will be
able to identify what digit this is so
there are in this output layer there are
10 neurons each signifying a digit and
at any given point of time when you feed
an image only one of these 10 neurons
gets activated so for example if this is
strained properly and if you feed a
number nine like this then this
particular neuron gets activated so you
get an output from this neuron let me
just use uh a pen or a laser to show you
here okay so you're feeding a number
nine let's say this has been trained and
now if you're feeding a number nine this
will get activated now let's say you
feed one to the trained Network then
this neuron will get activated if you
feed two this neuron will get activated
and so on I hope you get the idea so
this is one type of a neural network or
an activation function known as softmax
layer so that's what we will be using
here this is one of the simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and uh
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
uh let me run you through briefly here
and then we will go into the Jupiter
notebook where the actual code is and we
will run that as well so as a first step
first of all we are using python here
and that's why the syntax of the
language is Python and the first step is
to import the tensorflow library so and
we do this by using this line of code
saying import tens of flow as TF TF is
just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this TF is
tens flow is available as an object in
the name of TF and then you can run its
uh methods and accesses its attributes
and so on and so forth and Mist database
is actually an integral part of
tensorflow and that's again another
reason why we as a first step we always
use this example mnist database example
so you just simply import mnist database
as well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
uh let me just uh use pen to show what
exactly it is so when you do this one
hot true what happens is each label is
stored in the form of an array of 10
digits and let's say the number is uh 8
okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position zero this
is at position one position two and so
on and so forth let's say this is
position 7 then this is position 8 that
will be one because our input is eight
and again position 9 will be zero okay
so one hot encoding this one H encoding
true will kind of load the data in such
a way that the labels are in such a way
that only one of the digits has a value
of one and that indicat so based on
which digit is one we know what is the
label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a two here let's say then
the labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as zero the zeroth position
the first position is also zero the
second position is one because this
indicates number two and then you have
third as zero and so on okay so that is
the significance of this one hot true
all right and then we can check how the
data is uh looking by displaying the the
data and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not really see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and uh this tells you how many
images are there in each set so the
training there are 55,000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10,000 and then validation there are
5,000 so altogether there are 70,000
images all right so let's uh move on and
we can view the actual image by uh using
the matplot clip library and this is how
you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in Gray
scale so the cmap is what tells in what
way we want to view it and what are the
maximum values and the minimum values of
the pixel values so these are the Max
and minimum values so of the pixel
values so maximum is one because this is
a scaled value so one means it is uh
White and zero means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white and the way to train the
model there is a certain way in which
you write your tensorflow code and um
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and um
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and uh then of
course you will have variables which are
your remember these are your we
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
7 84 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
78 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with a weight and then that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a a matrix of
784 values for each of the neurons and
uh so it is like a 10x 784 Matrix
because there are 10 neurons and uh
similarly there are biases now remember
I mentioned biases only one per neuron
so it is not one per input unlike the
weights so therefore there are only 10
biases because there are only 10 neurons
in this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensor flow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in tens
oflow you have three different types
placeholders variables and constants and
then you create what is known as a graph
so tensorflow programming consists of
graphs and tensors as I mentioned
earlier so this can be considered
ultimately as a tensor and then the
graph tells how to execute the whole
implement ation so that the execution is
stored in the form of a graph and in
this case what we are doing is we are
doing a multiplication TF you remember
this TF was created as a tensorflow
object here one more level one more so
TF is available here now tensor flow has
what is known as a matrix multiplication
or matal function so that is what is
being used here in this case so we are
using the matrix multiplication of
tensor flow so that you multiply your
input values x with W right this is what
we were doing x w + B you just adding B
and this is in very similar to one of
the earlier slides where we saw Sigma XI
wi so that's what we are doing here
matrix multiplication is multiplying all
the input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to Define what is our loss function and
and what is our Optimizer so in this
case we again use the tensor flows apis
so TF do NN softmax cross entropy with
logits is the uh API that we will use
and reduce mean is what is like the
mechanism whereby which says that you
reduce the error and Optimizer for doing
deduction of the error what Optimizer
are we using so we are using gradi
descent Optimizer we discussed about
this in couple of slides uh earlier and
for that you need to specify the
learning rate you remember we saw that
there was a a slide somewhat like this
and then you define what should be the
learning rate how fast you need to come
down that is the learning rate and this
again needs to be tested and tried and
to find out the optimum level of this
learning rate it shouldn't be very high
in which case it will not converge or
shouldn't be very low because it will in
that case it will take very long so you
define the optimizer and then you call
the method minimize for that Optimizer
and that will Kickstart the training
process and so far we've been creating
the graph and in order to actually
execute that graph we create what is
known as a session and then we run that
session and once the training is
completed we specify how many times how
many iterations we want it to run so for
example in this case we are saying th000
steps so that is a exit strategy in a
way so you specify the exit condition so
training will run for 1,000 iterations
and once that is done we can then
evaluate the model using some of the
techniques shown here so let us get into
the code quickly and see how it works so
this is our Cloud environment now you
can install tensorflow on your local
machine as well I'm showing this demo on
on our existing Cloud but you can also
install denslow on your local machine
and uh there is a separate video on how
to set up your tsor flow environment you
can watch that if you want to install
your local environment or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
Google Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of
these you can use and U run and try the
code okay so it has got started
we will log
in all right so this is our deep
learning tutorial uh code and uh this is
our tensorflow
environment and uh so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that the one hot
is encoding is set to True one hot
encoding right as I explained earlier so
in this casee the label values will be
shown appropriately and if we just check
what is the type of the data so you can
see that this is a data sets python data
sets and if we check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float 32
similarly the number if you want to see
what is the number
of training images there are 55,000 then
there are test images 10,000 and then
validation images 5,000 now let's take a
quick look at the data itself
visualization so we will use um matte
plot clip for this and um if we take a
look at the shape now shape gives us
like the dimension of the tensors or or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55,000
and 55,000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see what is the the
first image and see what is the shape so
again size obviously it is only 784
similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how which it shows so
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine in the image
only certain areas are written rest is U
black so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between 0er and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros so that
is how the data is stored and loaded if
we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image if you
want to view it this is how you view it
so you create like do this reshape and
um matplot lib has this um feature to
show you these images so we will
actually use the function called um IM
am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now I
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say if I want to see what is
there in maybe I
,000 right
so 5,000 has three similarly you can
just say five what is in five five as
eight what is in
50 again eight so basically by the way
if you're wondering uh how I'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with jupyter notebooks shift
enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you want to to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all so that is
how this code gets executed and um here
again we can check what is the maximum
value and what is the minimum value of
this pixel values as I mentioned this is
it is scaled so therefore it is between
the values lie between 1 and zero now
this is where we create our
model the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
actual values okay so one for this 10 is
for each neuron there are 10 neurons and
784 is for the pixel values inputs that
are given which is 28 into 28 and the
biases as I mentioned one for each
neuron so there will be 10 biases they
are stored in a variable by the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and Yore true as a second placeholder
and this will have values in the form of
uh 10 digigit 10 digit uh arrays and uh
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the label for that particular
number all right then we have cross
entropy which is nothing but the loss
loss function and we have the optimizer
we have chosen gradient descent as our
Optimizer then the training process
itself so the training process is
nothing but to minimize the cross
entropy which is again nothing but the
loss function so we Define all of this
in the form of a graph so this up to
here remember what we have done is we
have not exactly executed any tensorflow
code till now we are just preparing the
graph the execution plan that's how the
tensorflow code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs needs quite a
bit of practice so you may want to view
this uh video also maybe a couple of
times to understand this flow because
the way tensorflow programming is done
is slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done uh maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this um but even in spark the
the programming the code itself is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the ex execution happens slightly
differently but in tens oflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed uh in the same way as you have
written so that that's something you
need to understand and a little bit of
practice is needed for this so so far
what we have done up to here is creating
the variables and feeding the variables
and um or rather not feeding but setting
up the variables and uh the graph that's
all different defining maybe the uh what
kind of a network you want to use for
example we want to use softmax and so on
so you have created the variables have
to load the data loaded the data viewed
the data and prepared everything but you
have not yet executed anything in tens
of flow now the next step is the
execution in tens of flow so the first
step for doing any execution in tensor
flow is to initialize the variable so
anytime you have any variables defined
in your code you have to run this piece
of code always so you need to basically
create what is known as a a node for
initializing so this is a node you still
are not yet executing anything here you
just created a node for the
initialization so let us go ahead and
create that and here onwards is where
you will actually execute your code uh
intensive flow and in order to execute
the code what what you will need is a
session tensor flow session so TF do
session will give you a session and
there are a couple of different ways in
which you can do this but one of the
most common methods of doing this is
with what is known as a withd loop so
you have a with tf. session as SS and
with a uh colon here and this is like a
block starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and this session is valid till this
block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf. session as SS you say cs. run in it
now cs. run will execute a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying cs. run cess is basic
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf. session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that cess and
then we run a node within that one of
the nodes in the graph so one of the
nodes here is in it so we say run that
particular node and that is when the
initialization of the variables happens
now what this does is if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have W is a variable and B is a variable
so any variables that we created you
have to run this code you have to run
the initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then we within this width block we
specify a for Loop and we are saying we
want the system to iterate for thousand
steps and perform the training
that's what this for Loop does run
training for thousand
iterations and what it is doing
basically is it is fetching the data or
these images remember there are about
50,000 images but it cannot get all the
images in one shot because it will take
up a lot of memory and performance
issues will be there so this is a very
common way of Performing deep learning
training you always do in batches so we
have maybe 50,000 images but you always
do it in batches of 100 or maybe 500
depending on the size of your system and
so on and so forth so in this case we
are saying okay get me 100 uh images at
a time and get me only the training
images remember we use only the training
data for training purpose and then we
use test data for test purpose you must
be familiar with machine learning so you
must be aware of this but in case you
are not in machine learning also not
this is not specific to deep learning
but in machine learning in general you
have what is known as training data set
and test data set your available data
typically you will be splitting into two
parts and using the training data set
for training purpose and then to see how
well the model has been trained you use
the test data set to check or test the
validity or the accuracy of the model so
that's what we are doing here and You
observe here that we are actually
calling an mnist function here so we are
saying mnist train. nextt batch right so
this is the advantage of using mes
database because they have provided some
very nice helper functions which are
readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using amness database and that's why
we use this for the initial your
learning phase okay so when we say fetch
what it will do is it will fetch the
images into X and the labels into Y and
then you use this batch of 100 images
and you run the training so cs. run
basically what we are doing here is we
are running the training mechanism which
is nothing but it passes this through
the neural network passes the images
through the neural network finds out
what is the output and if the output
obviously the initially it will be wrong
so all that feedback is given back to
the neural network and thereby all the
W's and Bs get updated till it reaches
thousand iterations in this case the
exit criteria is th000 but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
thousand iterations and typically by the
end of this thousand iterations the
model would have learned to recognize
these hand images obviously it will not
be 100% accurate okay so once that is
done after so this happens for thousand
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensor flow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and uh you're trying to find
out what is the actual value and what is
the predicted value and seeing whether
they are equal or not TF do equal right
and how many of them are correct and so
on and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is uh calculated as well so
this is the accuracy and uh that is what
we are trying to see how accurate the
model is in predicting these uh numbers
or these digits okay so let us run this
this entire thing is in one cell so we
will have to just run it in one shot it
may take a little while let us see
and uh not bad so it has finished the
thousand iterations and what we see here
as an output is the accuracy so we see
that the accuracy of this model is
around
91% okay now which is pretty good for
such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90% accuracy however
in real life this is probably not
sufficient so there are other ways in to
increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyperparameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and uh so that
this accuracy can be increased Beyond
90% hello and welcome to the tensorflow
object detection API tutorial in this
video I will walk you through the
tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically you're
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example lumpi
we need image IO datetime and pill and
so on and so forth and of course matplot
lib so we import all these libraries and
then there are a bunch of variables
which have some paths for the files and
folders so this is regular stuff let's
keep moving then we import the Mac plot
lib and make it in line and uh a few
more Imports all right and then these
are some warnings we can just ignore
them so if I run this code once again
it'll go away all right and then here
onwards we do the model preparation now
what we're going to do is we're going to
use an existing neural network model so
we are not going to train a new one
because that really will uh take a long
time and uh it needs a lot of uh
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the SSD with mobile net
that's the model that we are going to
use and uh this model is trained to
detect objects and uh it is readily
available as open source so we can
actually use this and if you want to use
other models there are a few more models
available so you can click on this link
here and uh let me just take you there
there are a few more models but we have
chosen this particular one because this
is faster it may not be very accurate
but that is one of the faster models but
on this link you will see a lot of other
models that are readily available these
are trained models some of them would
take a little longer but they may be
more accurate and so on so you can
probably play around with these other
models okay so we will be using that
model so this piece of code this line is
basically importing that model and this
is also known as uh Frozen model the
term we use is frozen model so we import
download and import that and then we
will actually use that model in our code
all right so these two cells we have
downloaded and imported the model and
then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so we are loading this into memory
and uh you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is usually a number
so we need to map that to a text so for
example if the network predicts that the
output is five we know that five means
it is an airplane things like that so
this mapping is done in this next cell
all right so let's keep moving and then
we have a helper code which will
basically load the data or load the
images and transform into numpy arrays
this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is this is where the
actual detection starts so here this is
the path for where the images are stored
so this is here once again we are
reusing the code which we wrote for
detecting objects in an image so this is
the path where the images were stored
and this is the extension and this was
done for about two or three images so we
will continue to use this and uh we go
down I'll skip this section so this is
the cell where we are actually loading
the video and converting it into frames
and then using frame by frame we are
detecting the objects in the image so in
this code what we are doing basically is
there a few lines of code what they do
is basically once they find an object a
box will be drawn around those uh each
of those objects and the input file the
name of the input video file is uh
traffic it is the extension is MP4 and
uh we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is is basically
part of this class called image IO so we
can read and write videos using that and
uh the video that we are going to use is
traffic. MP4 you can use any mp4 file
but in our case I picked up video which
has uh like car so let me just show you
so this is in this object detection
folder I have this mp4 file I'll just
quickly play this video it's a little
slow yeah okay so here we go this is the
video it's a short one relatively small
video so that for this particular demo
and what it will do is once we run our
code it will detect each of these cars
and it will annotate them as cars so in
this particular video we only have cars
we can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this uh traffic video so let me go back
so we will be reading this frame by
frame and um no actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic annotated and um we will see the
annotated video so let's go back and run
through this piece of code and then we
will come back and see the annotated uh
video this might take a little while so
I will pause the video after running
this particular cell and then come back
to show you the results all right so
let's go ahead and run it so it is
running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
writer. close all right so I'll pause
and then I'll come back okay so I will
see you in a little bit all right so now
as you can see here the processing is
done the r Glass has disappeared that
means the video has been processed so
let's go back and check the annotated
video we go back to my file manager so
this was the original traffic. MP4 and
now you have here traffic uncore
annotated MP4 for so let's go and run
this and see how it
looks you see here it has got each of
these cars are getting detected let me
pause and show you so we pause here it
says car 70% let us allow it to go a
little further it detects something on
top what is that truck okay so I think
because of the board on top it somehow
thinks there is a truck let's lay some
more and see if it detects anything else
so this is again a car looks like so let
us yeah so this is a car and it has
confidence level of 69% okay this is
again a car all right so basically till
the end it goes and detects each and
every car that is passing by now we can
quickly repeat this process for another
video let me just show you the other
video which is a cat again there is uh
this cat is not really moving or
anything but it is just standing there
staring and moving a little slowly and
uh our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and uh even
when the cat moves a little bit in the
other direction it'll continue to detect
and show that it is a cat Okay so yeah
so this is how the original video is
let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our Network detects this cat close this
here we go and I'll go back my code all
we need to do is change this traffic to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video uncore reader has a a
neat little feature or interface whereby
you can say for frame in video reader so
it will basically provide frame by frame
so you are in a loop frame by frame and
then you take that each frame frame that
is given to you you take it and analyze
it as if it is an image individual image
so that's the way it works so it is very
easy to handle this all right so now
let's once again run just this cell rest
of the stuff Remains the Same so I will
run this cell again it will take a
little while so the our classes come
back I will pause and then come back in
a little while all right so the
processing is done let's go and check
the annotated video go here so we have
cat annotated MP4 let's play this all
right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here let's see
yes so what is it trying to show here
it's too small not able to see but uh it
is trying to detect something I think it
is saying it is a car I don't know all
right okay so in this video the there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just in a little bit that's
going to happen and we will see there we
go and in spite of turning the other way
I think our network is able to detect
that it is a cat so let me freeze and
then show here it is actually still
continues to detect it as a cat all
right so that's pretty much it I think
that's the only object that it detects
in this particular video okay so close
this so that's pretty much it thank you
very much for watching this video and
you have a great day and in case you
have any questions please uh put them
below the video here and we will be more
than happy to get back to you and make
sure you put your email ID so that we
can contact you in case you have any
questions thank you once again bye-bye
today we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial do
you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very Central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a uh hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image um don't worry
we're going to get into the details so
we have our input layer accepts the
pixels of the image as input in the form
of arrays and you can see up here where
they've actually um labeled each block
of the bird in different arrays so we'll
dive into deep as to how that looks like
and how those matrixes are set up your
hidden layer carry out feature
extraction by performing certain
calculations and man ulation so this is
the part that kind of reorganizes that
picture multiple ways until we get some
data that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer real U is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used pooling
layer also uses multiple filters to
detect edges corners eyes feathers beak
Etc and just like the term says pooling
is pulling information together and
we'll look into that a lot closer here
so if you're if it's a little confusing
now we'll dig in deep and try to get you
uh squared away with that and then
finally there is a fully connected layer
that identifies the object in the image
so we have these different layers coming
through in the hidden layers and they
come into the final area and that's
where we have a one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird what's in it for you we're
going to cover an introduction to the
CNN what is convolution neural network
how CNN recognizes images we're going to
dig deeper into that and really look at
the individual layers in the
convolutional neural network and finally
we do a use case implementation using
the CNN we'll begin our introduction to
the CNN by introducing a pioneer of
convolutional neural network Yan leun he
was the director of Facebook AI research
group built the first convolutional
neural network called lenette in
1988 so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits imagine processing mail and
automating that process CNN is a feed
forward neural network that is generally
used to analyze visual images by
producing data with a grid-like topology
a CNN is also known as a convet and very
key to this is we are looking at images
that was what this was designed for and
you'll see the different layers as we
dig in Mirror some of the other some of
them are actually now used since we're
using uh tensorflow and carass in our
code later on you'll see that some of
those layers appear in a lot of your
other neural network Frameworks uh but
in this case this is very Central to
processing images and doing so in a
variety that captures multiple images
and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers of two varieties Orchid
and a rose I think the Orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful I have a couple
rose bushes in my yard uh they go into
the input layer that data is then sent
to all the different nodes in the next
layer of one of the Hidden layers based
on its different weights and its setup
it then comes out and gives those a new
value those values then are multiplied
by their weights and go to the next
hidden layer and so on and then you have
the output layer and one of those notes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how was well it was
trained what separates the CNN or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms the basis of any
convolutional neural network in a CNN
every image is represented in the form
of arrays of pixel values so here we
have a real image of the digit 8 uh that
then gets put onto its pixel values
represented in the form of an array
array in this case you have a
two-dimensional array and then you can
see in the final in form we transform
the digit 8 into its representational
form of pixels of zeros and one where
the ones represent in this case the
black part of the eight and the zeros
represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation Works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes and this
case we're going to simplify it we're
going to take two matrices A and B of
one dimension now kind of separate this
from your thinking as we learn that you
want to focus just on the Matrix aspect
of this and then we'll bring that back
together and see what that looks like
when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have uh in this case
there a single Dimension Matrix and we
have a = 5
37597 and we have Bal 1 23 so in the
convolution as it comes in there it's
going to look at these two and we're
going to start by doing multiplying them
a * B and so we multiply the arrays
element wise and we get 5
66 where five is the 5 * 1 6 is 3 * 2
and then the other six is 2 * 3 and
since the two arrays aren't the same
size they're not the same setup we're
going to just truncate the first one and
we're going to look at the second array
multiplied just by the first three
elements of the first array now that's
going to be a little confusing remember
a computer gets to repeat these
processes hundreds of times so we're not
going to just forget those other numbers
later on we'll see we'll bring those
back in and then we have the sum of the
product in this case 5 + 6 + 6 = 17 so
in our a * B our very first digit in
that Matrix of a * B is 17 and if you
remember I said we're not going to
forget the other digits so we now have
325 we move one set over and we take 325
and we multiply that times B and you'll
see that 3 * 1 is 3 2 * 2 is 4 and so on
and so on we it up so now we have the
second digit of our a * B product in The
Matrix and we continue on with that same
thing so on and so on so then we would
go from uh 375 to 759 to 597 this short
Matrix that we have for a we've now
covered all the different entities in a
that match three different levels of B
now in a little bit we're going to cover
where we use this math at this
multiplying of matrixes and how that
works uh but it's important to
understand that we're going through the
Matrix and multiplying the different
parts to it to match the smaller Matrix
with the larger Matrix I know a lot of
people get lost at is you know what's
going on here with these matrixes uh oh
scary math not really that scary when
you break it down we're looking at a
section of a and we're comparing it to B
so when you break that down your mind
like that you realize okay so I'm I'm
just taking these two matrixes and
comparing them and I'm bringing the
value down into one Matrix a Time B
we're producing that information in a
way that will help the computer see
different aspects let's go ahead and
flip over again back to our images and
here we are back to our images talking
about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the back slash the above image is
processed and you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so when we click the forward
slash button that flips uh very basic we
have four pixels going in can't get any
more basic than that here we have a
little bit more complicated picture we
take a real image of a smiley face um
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros and ones so where
the other one would have just been a
matrix of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
when we're looking at this we have our
conv vution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images in
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your reu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
reu is an how it Act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that
in a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself it's for
process ing smaller amounts of data
where you use the atom activation
feature for large data coming in now
because we're processing small amounts
of data in each image the reu layer
works great you have your pooling layer
that's where you're pulling the data
together pooling is a neural network
term it's very commonly used I like to
use the term reduce so if you're coming
from the map and reduce side you'll see
that we're mapping all this data through
all these networks and then we're going
to reduce it we're going to pull it
together and then find finally we have
the fully connected layer that's where
our output's going to come out so we
have started to look at matrixes we've
started to look at the convolutional
layer and where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only zero and one now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels uh so we're
sliding the filter Matrix over the image
and Computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter is going to be derived uh later
on we build the filters when we program
or train our model so you don't need to
worry what the filter actually actually
is what you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have many
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two-dimensional Matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here 1 * 1 1 * 0 1 * 1
we multiply those all together then sum
them and we end up with a convolved
feature of four we're going to take that
and sliding the filter Matrix over the
image and Computing the dot product to
detect patterns so we're just going to
slide this over we're going to predict
the first one and slide it over one
notch predict the second one and so on
and so on all the way through until we
have a new Matrix and this Matrix which
is the same size as a filter has reduced
the image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out it's going to be
looking at just those features reduced
down to a smaller uh Matrix so once the
feature maps are extracted the next step
is to move them to the reu layer so the
realu layer The Next Step first is going
to perform an element wise operation so
each of those Maps coming in if there's
negative pixels so it sets all the
negative pixels to zero um and you can
see this nice graph where it just zeros
out the negatives and then you have a
value that goes from zero up to whatever
value is um coming out of the Matrix
this introduces nonlinearity to the
network uh so up until now we have a we
say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature um
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw um you'll
look at that and say okay this feature
has a value from -10 to 10 in this case
um if it was one it say yeah this might
be a beak it might not might be an edge
right there a minus 5 means no we're not
even going to look at it a zero and so
we end up with an output and the output
takes all these feature all these
filtered features remember we're not
just running one filter on this we're
running a number of filters on this
image and so we end up with an rectified
feature map that is looking at just the
features coming through and how they
weigh in from our filters so here we
have an input of a looks like a twocan
bird very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
reu layers for locating features and you
can see up here is tur it into a black
and white image and in this case we're
looking in the upper right hand corner
for a feature and that box scans over a
lot of times it doesn't scan one pixel
at a time a lot of times it will Skip by
two or three or four pixels uh to speed
up the process that's one of the ways
you can compensate if you don't have
enough resources on your compter
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image uh you have multiple filters
have been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new Matrix one more aspect to
note about the reu layer is we're not
just having one reu coming in uh so not
only do we have multiple features going
through but we're generating multiple
reu layers for locating the features
that's very important to note you know
so we have a quite a bundle we have
multiple filters multiple railu uh which
brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map that's all we're trying to
do we're trying to take a huge amount of
information and reduce it down to a
single answer this is a specific kind of
bird this is an iris this is a rose so
you have a rectified feature map and you
see here we have a rectified feature map
coming in um we set the max pooling with
a 2X two filters and a stride of Two And
if you remember correctly I talked about
not going one pixel at a time uh well
that's where the stride comes in we end
up with a 2X two pulled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a we skip a few there we go by two
we skip every other pixel and we just do
every other one um and this reduces our
rectified feature map which as you can
see over here 16x 16 to a 4x4 so we're
continually trying to filter and reduce
our data so that we can get to something
we can manage and over here you see that
we have the Max uh 341 and two and in
the max pooling we're looking for the
max value a little bit different than
what we were looking at before so coming
from the rectified feature we're now
finding the max value and then we're
pulling those features together so
instead of think think of this as image
of the map think of this as how valuable
is a feature in that area how much of a
feature value do we have and we just
want to find the best or the maximum
feature for that area it might be in
this image and says oh this one is rated
as a four we don't want to sum it
together cuz then you know you might
have like five ones and it'll say ah
five but you might have uh four zeros
and one 10 and that 10 says well this is
definitely a beak where the ones will
say probably not a beak a little strange
analogy since we're looking at a bird
but you can see that pulled feature map
comes down and we're just looking for
the max value in each one of those
matrixes pooling layer uses different
filters to identify different parts of
the image like edges corners body
feathers eyes beak Etc um I know I focus
mainly on the beak but obviously uh each
feature could be each a different part
of the bird coming in so let's take a
look at what that looks like structure
of a convolution neural network so far
this is where we're at right now we have
our input image coming in and then we
use our uh filters and there's multiple
filters on there that are being
developed to kind of twist and change
that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a 2X two we multiply it by
each piece of the image and if we step
two then it's every other piece of the
image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have um set up
in there is looking at that data we then
take those convolution layers we run
them through the reu setup up and then
once we've done through the reu setup
and we have multiple reu going on
multiple layers that are reu then we're
going to take those multiple layers and
we're going to be pooling them so now we
have the pooling layers or multiple
poolings going on up until this point
we're dealing with uh sometimes it's
multiple Dimensions you can have three
dimensions some strange data setups that
aren't doing images but looking at other
things they can have four five six seven
dimensions uh so right now we're looking
at 2D image Dimensions coming in into
the pooling layer so the next step is we
want to reduce those Dimensions or
flatten them so flattening flattening is
a process of converting all of the
resultant two-dimensional arrays from
pulled feature map into a single long
continuous linear Vector so over here
you see where we have a pulled feature
map maybe that's the Birdwing and it has
values 6847 and we want to just flatten
this out and turn it into 6847 or a
single linear vector and we we find out
that not only do we do each of the
pulled feature Maps we do all of them
into one long linear Vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done is
taken all those different pooling layers
and we've flattened them out and
combined them into a single linear
Vector going in so after we've done the
flattening we have a just a quick recap
because we've covered so much so it's
important to go back and take a look at
each of the steps we've gone through the
structure of the network so far is we
have our convolution where we twist it
and we filter it and multiply the
matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the reu
to figure out the values going out into
the pooling and you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pulling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're going to
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
into it to most neural network and
you're correct it is so once we have the
flattened Matrix from the pooling layer
that becomes our input so the pooling
layer is fed as an input to the fully
connected layer to classify the image
and so you can see as our flatten Matrix
comes in in this case we have the pixels
from the flatten Matrix fed as an input
back to our twocan or whatever that kind
of bird that is um I need one of these
to identify what kind of bird that is it
comes into our Ford propagation network
uh and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case even though it's not labeled the
final layer there in red is our output
layer our final output layer that says
bird cat or dog so quick recap of
everything we've covered so far we have
our input image which is twisted and
multiply the filters are multiplied
times the uh matri the two matrixes
multiplied all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution ution
layers there's multiple layers in there
because it's all building multiple
layers off the different filters then
goes through the reu as this activation
and that creates our pooling and so once
we get into the pooling layer we then on
the pooling look for who's the best
what's the max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the CNN recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice cuz it's showing
the little pixels and where they're
going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relo for the
pooling the pooling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification and the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps uh we have 1 two 3 four five
different steps going on here with
substeps in there we're going to break
that down and walk through that in code
so in our use case implementation using
the CNN we'll be using the cfr1 data set
from Canadian Institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and very Cutting Edge as far as
what's coming out in the commercial
deployment I mean this is really cool
stuff we're starting to see this just
about everywhere in Industry uh so a
great time to be playing with this and
figuring it all out let's go ahead and
dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script before we go on let's do uh
one more quick look at what we have here
let's just take a look at data batch one
keys and remember in Jupiter notebook I
can get by with not doing the print
statement if I put a variable down there
it'll just display the variable and you
can see under data batch one for the
keys since this is a dictionary we have
the batch one label data and file names
uh so you can actually see how it's
broken up in our data set so for the
next step or step four as we're calling
it uh we want to display the image using
Matt plot Library there's many ways to
display the images you could even uh
well there's other ways to drill into it
but M plot library is really good for
this and we'll also look at our first
reshape uh setup or shaping the data so
you can have a little glimpse into what
that means uh so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since I am doing jupyter not notbook I
need to do the map plot inline command
so it shows up on my page so here we go
we're going to import matplot library.
pyplot is PLT and if you remember M plot
Library the PIP plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign map plot library in line
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as NP for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set u x
equals to data batch one so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data uh we need to
go a little bit of reshaping so in here
we have to go ahead and reshape the data
we have 10,000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to I had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32x32
picture and let me do this let me go go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here uh so
we have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
I don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take uh the shape we're
going to take the data which is just a
long stream of information and we're
going to break it up into 10,000 pieces
and those 10,000 pieces then are broken
into three pieces each and those three
pieces then are 32x 32 you could look at
this like an oldfashioned projector
where they have the red screen or the
red projector the blue projector and the
green projector and they add them all
together and each one of those is a 32x
32 bit so that's probably how this was
originally formatted within that kind of
Ideal things have changed so we're going
to transpose it and we're going to take
the three which was here and we're going
to put it at the end so the first part
is reshaping the data from a single line
bit data or whatever format it is into
10,000 x 3X 32x 32 and then we're going
to transpose the color factor to the
last place so it's the image then the 32
by 32 in the middle that's this part
right here and then finally we're going
to take this uh which is three bits of
data and put it at the end so it's more
like we do we process images now and
then as type this is really important
that we're going to use an integer 8 you
can come come in here and you'll see a
lot of these they'll try to do this with
a float or float 64 what you got to
remember though is a float uses a lot of
memory so once you switch this into uh
something that's not integer 8 which is
goes up to 128 you are just going to the
the amount of ram let just put that in
here is going to go way up the amount of
ram that it loads uh so you want to go
ahead and use this you can try the other
ones and see what happens if you have a
lot of RAM on your computer but for this
EX size this will work just fine and
let's go ahead and take that and run
this so now our X variable is all loaded
and it has all the images in it from the
batch one data batch one and just to
show we were talking about with the as
type on there if we go ahead and take x0
and just look for its max value let me
go ahead and run that uh you'll see it
doesn't oops I said 128 it's 255 uh
you'll see it doesn't go over 255
because it's an basically an asky
character is what we're keeping that
down to we're keeping those values down
so they're only 255 0 to 255 versus a
float value which would bring this up um
exponentially in size and since we're
using the map plot Library we can do um
oops that's not what I wanted since
we're using the map plot Library we can
take our canvas and just do a PLT do IM
for image show and let's just take a
look at what x0 looks like and it comes
in I'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image uh
broken down to the minimal pixels on
there and if we did the same thing oh
let's do uh let's see what one looks
like hopefully it's a little easier to
see run on there not enter let's hit the
run on that uh and we can see this is
probably a semi that's a good guess on
there and I can just go back up here
instead of typing the same line in over
and over and we'll look at three uh that
looks like a dump truck unloading uh and
so on you can do any of the 10,000
images we can just jump to 55 uh looks
like some kind of animal looking at us
there probably a dog and just for fun
let's do just one more uh uh run on
there and we can see a nice car for
image number four uh so you can see we
past through all the different images
and it's very easy to look at them and
they've been reshaped to fit our view
and what the uh map plot Library uses
for its format so the next step is we're
going to start creating some helper
functions we'll start by a one hot
encoder to help us we're processing the
data remember that your labels they
can't just be words they have to switch
it and we use the one hot encoder to do
that and then we'll also create a uh
class uh CFR helper so it's going to
have a knit and a setup for the images
and then finally we'll go ahead and run
that code so you can see what that looks
like and then we get into the fun part
where we're actually going to start
creating our model our actual neural
network model so let's start by creating
our one hot encoder we're going to
create our own here uh and it's going to
return and out and we'll have our Vector
coming in and our values equal 10 what
this means is that we have the 10 values
the 10 possible labels and remember we
don't look at the labels as a number cuz
a car isn't one more than a horse that'd
be just kind of bizarre to have horse
equals zero car equals 1 plane equals 2
cat equals three so a cat plus a car
equals what uh so instead we create a
numpy array of zeros and there's going
to be 10 values so we have 10 different
values in there so you have uh zero or
one one means it's a cat zero means it's
not a cat um in the next line it might
be that uh one means it's a car zero
means it's not a car so instead of
having one output with a value of 0 to
10 you have 10 outputs with the values
of 0 to one that's what the one hot
encoder is doing here and we're going to
utilize this in code in just a minute so
let's go ahead and take a look at the
next helpers we have a few of these
helper functions we're going to build
and when you're working with a very
complicated python project dividing it
up into into separate definitions in
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper uh which is a class and this
is's a lot in this class so we we'll
break it down here let's just start UHS
we put a space right in there there we
go that look a little bit more readable
at a second space so we're going to
create our class the cipher Helper and
we'll start by initializing it now
there's a lot going on in here so let's
start with the uh nit part uh self.
equals 0 that'll come in in a little bit
we'll come back to that in the lower
part we want to initialize our training
batches so when we went through this
there was like a meta batch we don't
need the meta batch but we do need the
data batch 1 2 3 4 five and we do not
want the testing batch in here this is
just the self all train batches so we're
going to come make an array of of all
those different images and then of
course we left the test batch out so we
have our self. test batch uh we're going
to initialize the training images and
the training labels and also the test
images and the test labels so these are
just this is just to initialize these
variables in here then we create another
definition down here and this is going
to set up the images let's just take a
look and see what's going on in there
now we could have all just put this as
part of the uh init part uh since this
is all just helper stuff but breaking it
up again makes it easier to read it also
makes it easier when we start executing
the different pieces to see what's going
on so that way we have a nice print
statement to say hey we're now running
this and this is what's going on in here
we're going to set up these
self-training images at this point and
that's going to go to a numpy array
vstack and in there we're going to load
up uh in this case the data for D in all
train batches again that points right up
to here so we're going to go through
each one of these uh files or each one
of these data sets CU they're not a file
anymore we've brought them in data batch
one points to the actual data and so our
self-training images is going to stack
them all into our into a numpy array and
then it's always nice to get the
training length and that's just a total
number of uh self-training images in
there and then we're going to take the
selft trining images let me switch
marker colors cuz I am getting a little
too much on the markers up here oops
there we go bring down our marker change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well we wanted to
uh uh look at this above and we want to
look at the images in the matplot
library we had to reshape it so we're
doing the same thing here we're taking
our self-training images and uh based on
the training length total number of
images because we stacked them all
together so now it's just one large file
of images we're going to take and look
at it as our our three video cameras
that are each displaying uh 32x 32 we're
going to switch that around so that now
we have um each of our images that stays
the same place and then we have our 32 2
by 32 and then by our three our last our
three different values for the color and
of course we want to go ahead and uh
they run this where you say divide by
255 that was from earlier it just brings
all the data into 0 to one that's what
this is doing so we're turning this into
a 0 to one array which is uh all the
pictures 32x 32 by 3 and then we're
going to take the self-training labels
and we're going to pump those through
our one hot encoder we just made and
we're going to stack them together and
uh again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals 1 dog equals 2 and
then horse plus dog would equal three
which would be cat no it's going to be
you know an array of 10 where each one
is 0er to one then we want to go ahead
and set up our test images and labels
and uh when we're doing this you're
going to see it's the same thing we just
did with the rest of let me just change
colors right here this is no different
than what we were doing up here with our
training Set uh we're going to stack the
different uh images uh we're going to
get the length of them so we know how
many images are in there uh you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches cuz
this is really important to understand
tends to throw me for a little Loop when
I'm working with tensor flow or carass
or a lot of these we have our data
coming in if you remember we had like
10,000 photos let me just put 10,000
down here we don't want to run all
10,000 at once so we want to break this
up into batch sizes and you also
remember that we had the number of
photos so in this case uh length of test
or whatever number is in there uh we
also have 32 by 32 by3 so when we're
looking at the batch size we want to
change this from 10,000 to um a batch of
in this case I think we're going to do
batches of 100 so we want to look at
just 100 the first 100 of the photos and
if you remember we set selfi equal to
zero uh so what we're looking at here is
we're going to create X we're going to
get the next batch from the very
initialized we've already initialized it
for zero so we're going to look at X
from 0er to batch size which we set to
100 so just the first 100 images and
then we're going to reshape that into uh
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100x 32x 32x
3 now we've already formatted it to the
32x 32x 3 this just sets everything up
correctly so that X has the data in
there in the correct order and the
correct shape and then the Y just like
the X x uh is our labels so our training
labels again they go from zero to batch
size in this case they do selfi plus bat
size because the selfi is going to keep
changing and then finally we increment
the selfi because we have zero so we so
the next time we call it we're going to
get the next batch size and so basically
we have X and Y X being the photograph
data coming in and Y being the label and
that of course is labeled through one
hot encoder so if you remember correctly
if it was say horse equal to zero it
would be um uh one for the zero position
since this is the horse and then
everything else would be zero in here
let me just put lines through there
there we go there's our array hard to
see that array so let's go ahead and
take that and uh we're going to finish
loading it since this is our class and
now we're armed with all this um uh our
setup over here let's go ahead and load
that up and so we're going to create a
variable CH with the CFR helper in it
and then we're going to do ch. setup
images uh now we could have just put all
the setup images under the init but by
breaking this up into two parts it makes
it much more readable and um also if
you're doing other work there's reasons
to do that as far as the setup let's go
ahead and run that and you can see where
it says uh setting up training images
and labels setting up test images and
that's one of the reasons we broke it up
is so that if you're testing this out
you can actually have print statements
in there telling you what's going on
which is really nice uh they did a good
job with this setup I like the way that
it was broken up in the back and then
one quick note you want to remember that
batch to set up the next batch since we
have to run uh batch equals CH next
batch of 100 because we're going to use
the 100 size uh but we'll come back to
that we're going to use that just
remember that that's part of our code
we're going to be using in a minute from
the definition we just made so now we're
ready to create our model first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tensor flow as TF I'll just go ahead and
run that so it's loaded up and you can
see we got a a warning here uh that's
because they're making some changes it's
always growing and they're going to be
depreciating one of the uh values from
float 64 to float type or as treated as
an NP float 64 uh nothing to really
worry about cuz this doesn't even affect
what we're working on because we've set
all of our stuff to a 255 value or 0 to
one and do keep in mind that 0 to one
value that we converted to 255 is still
a float value uh but it'll easily work
with either the uh numpy float 64 or the
numpy dtype float it doesn't matter
which one it goes through through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensor flow uh
we'll go ahead let me just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals TF placeholder TF
float 32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float 32 more
than a significant number of decimals
for what we're working with and since
it's a placeholder we're going to set
the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none cuz at this point we're
just holding the place on there we'll be
setting up as we run the batches that's
what that first value is and then 32x
32x 3 that's what we reshaped our data
to fit in and then we have our y true
equals placeholder T of float 32 and the
shape equals none comma 10 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10 and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this a hold
prop or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call Dropout
if you remember from our Theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a a placeholder for
that also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensor flow when you use carass it
does some of this automatically but
we're in tensorflow direct sits on
tensor flow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each uh layer
has to have a bias going in we're going
to go ahead and work on our our
conversional 2D our Max pool so we have
our pooling layer our convolutional
layer and then our normal full layer so
we're going to go ahead and put those
all into definitions and let's see what
that looks like in code and you can also
grab some of these helper functions from
the MN the uh nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the tensor
flow so a lot of these are already in
there but we're going to go ahead and do
our own and we're going to create our a
nit weights and one of the reasons we're
doing this is so that you can actually
start thinking about what's going on in
the back end so even though there's ways
to do this with an automation sometimes
these have to be tweaked and you have to
put in your own setup in here uh now
we're not going to be doing that we're
just going to recreate them for our code
and let's take a look at this we have
our weights and so what comes in is
going to be the shape and what comes
comes out is going to be uh random
numbers so we're going to go ahead and
just knit some random numbers based on
the shape with a standard deviation of
0.1 kind of a fun way to do that and
then the TF variable uh init random
distribution so we're just creating a
random distribution on there that's all
that is for the weights now you might
change that you might have a a higher
standard deviation in some cases you
actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weight configure with each other uh now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant uh in this case we're using 0
one a lot of times the bias is just put
in as one and then you have your weights
to add on to that uh but we're going to
set this as 0.1 uh so we want to return
a convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on with the con 2D is
we're taking our data coming in uh we're
going to filter it strides if if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as
32 by
32 by 3 and we want to change this so
that it's just this is three dimensions
and it's going to reformat this as just
two dimensions so it's going to take
this number here and combine it with the
32x 32 so this is a very important layer
here CU it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down I'm just going to jump down one
here uh it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
pre formatting and the setup and then
you have your actual convolution layer
that goes through on there and you can
see here we have a knit weights by the
shape a knit bias shape of three because
we have the three different uh here's
our three again and then we return the
tfnn value with the convention 2D so
this convolutional uh has this feeding
into it right there it's using that as
part of it and of course the input is
the XY plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2D coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling uh so after each time
we run it through the convectional layer
we want to pull the data uh if you
remember ly on the on the pool side and
let me just get rid of all my marks it's
getting a little crazy there and in fact
let's go ahead and jump back to that
slide let's just take a look at that
slide over here uh so we have our image
coming in we create our convolutional
layer with all the filters remember the
filters go um you know the filters
coming in here and it looks at these
four boxes and then if it's a step let's
say step two it then goes to these four
boxes and then the next step and so on
uh so we have our convolutional layer
that we generate or convolutional layers
they use the uh reu function um there's
other functions out there for this
though the reu is the uh most the one
that works the best at least so far I'm
sure that will change then we have our
pooling now if you remember correctly
the pooling was Max uh so if we had the
filter coming in and they did the
multiplication on there and we have a
one and maybe a two here and another one
here and a three here three is the max
and so out of all of these you then
create an array that would be three if
the max is over here two or whatever it
is that's what goes into the pooling of
what's going on in our pooling uh so
again we're reducing that data down
reducing it down as small as we can and
then finally we're going to flatten it
out into a single array and that goes
into our fully connected layer and you
can see that here in the code right here
we're going to create our normal full
layer um so at some point we're going to
take from our pooling layer this will go
into some kind of flattening process and
then that will be fed into the full the
different layers going in down here um
and so we have our input size you'll see
our input layer get shape which is just
going to get the shape for whatever is
coming in uh and then input size initial
weights is also based on uh the input
layer coming in and the input size down
here is based on the input layer shape
so we're just going to already use the
shape and already have our size coming
in and of course uh you have to make
sure you init the bias always put your
bias on there and we'll do that based on
the side eyes so this will return tf.
matmo input layer w+b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and uh create the layers
let's see what that looks like now that
we've done all the heavy lifting and
everything uh we get to do all the easy
part let's go ahead and create our
layers we'll create a convolution layer
one and two two different convolutional
layers and then we'll take that and
we'll flatten that out create a a
reshape pooling in there for our reshape
and then we'll have our full uh layer at
the end so let's start by creating our
first uh convolutional layer then we
come in here and let me just run that
real quick and I want you to notice on
here the three and the 32 this is
important because coming into this
convolutional layer we have three
different channels and 32 pixels each uh
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 44 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing and for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
shape based on what's coming in so here
we have Max two 2x two and we put in the
convolutional one that we just created
the convolutional layer we just created
goes right back into it and that right
up here as you can see is the X it's
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up so it matches
and we went ahead and ran this already I
think I ran let me go and run it again
and if we're going to do one layer let's
go ahead and do a second layer down here
and it's uh we'll call convo 2 it's also
convolutional layer on this and you'll
see that we're feeding convolutional one
in the pooling so it goes from
convolutional one into convolutional one
pooling from convolutional one pooling
into convolutional two and then from
convolutional 2 into convolutional 2
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flatten
layer uh let's go ahead and we'll do uh
since we have 64 coming out of here and
we have a 4x4 going in let's do 8X 8X 64
so let's do
4,096 this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our uh
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the convo two pooling and then
we're going to set it up as a single
layer that's 4,096 in size that's what
that means there we'll go ahead and run
this so we've now created this variable
the convo 2 flat and then we have our
first full layer this is the final uh
neural network where we the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the uh reu for our uh setup on there on
a neural network for evaluation and
you'll notice that we're going to create
our first full layer our normal full
layer that's our definition so we
created that that's creating the normal
full layer and our input for the data
comes right here from the this goes
right into it uh the convo to flat so
this tells it how big the data is is and
we're going to have it come out it's
going to have uh 1024 that's how big the
layer is coming out we'll go ahead and
run this so now we have our full layer
one and with the full layer one we want
to also Define the full one Dropout to
go with that so our full layer one comes
in uh keep probability equals whole
probability remember we created that
earlier and the full layer one is what's
coming into it and this is going
backwards and training the data we're
not training every weight we're only
training a percentage of them each time
which helps get rid of the bias so let
me go ahead and run that and uh finally
we'll go ahead and create a y predict
which is going to equal the normal full
one Dropout and 10 because we have 10
labels in there now in this neural
network we could have added additional
layers that would be another option to
play with you can also play with instead
of 1024 you can use other numbers for
the way that sets up and what's coming
out and going into the next one we're
only going to do just the one layer and
the one layer Dropout and you can see if
we did another layer it' be really easy
just to feed in the full one Dropout
into full layer two and then full Layer
Two Dropout would have full Layer Two
feed into it and then you'd switch that
here for the Y prediction for right now
this is great this particular data set
is tried and true and we know that this
will work on it and if we just type in y
predict and we run that uh we'll see
that this is a tensor object uh shape
question mark 10 dtype 32 a quick way to
double check what we're working on so
now we've got all of our uh we've done a
setup all the way to the Y predict which
we just did uh we want to go ahead and
apply the loss function and make sure
that's set up in there uh create the
optimizer and then uh train our
Optimizer and create a variable to
initialize all the global TF variables
so before we dive into the um loss
function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehap over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups um we
pointed out up here we can change the 44
and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
um possibly a better fit you might
overfit and if you lower that number
you'll use less resources and generally
you want to use this in um the
exponential growth an exponential being
2 4 8 16 and in this case the next one
down would be 512 you can use any number
there but those would be the ideal
numbers uh when you look at this data so
the next step in all this is we need to
also create uh a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it uh we're
going to feed it our labels and we have
our true labels and our prediction
labels uh so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy uh in
information Theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these um are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this and so the next step is
we're going to take the error we want to
know our cross entropy or our loss
function how much loss we have that's
going to be part of how we train the
model so when you know what the loss is
and we're training it you feed that back
into the back propagation setup and so
we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our Optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an atom
Optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most popular used uh so our
Optimizer is going to equal the TF Trin
atom Optimizer if you don't remember
what the learning rate is let me just
pop this back into here here's our
learning rate when you have your weights
you have all your weights in your
different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out um and has
all its weights and then the error is
being prop sent back through in reverse
on our neural network so we take this
error and we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want it change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by 0.001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our Delta
W is only 0.001 of the actual Delta W of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training uh uh variable or
function and this is going to equal our
Optimizer minimize cross entropy and we
make sure we go ahead and run this so
it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more um variable in here and we're going
to create a variable to initialize all
the global TF variables and when we look
at this um the TF Global variable
initializer this is a tensor flow um
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensor flow and
then initializes those variables uh so
it's kind of like a magic wand because
it's all hidden in the back end of
tensor flow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation um and you have to run that
once you have your setup going so we'll
go ahead and run this piece of code and
then we're going to go ahead and train
our data so let me run this so it's
loaded up there and so now we're going
to go ahead and run the model by
creating a graph session graph session
is a tensorflow term so you'll see that
coming up it's one of the things that
throws me because I always think of
graphx and Spark and graph as just
general graphing uh but they talk about
a graph session so we're going to go
Ahad and run the model and let's go
ahead and walk through this uh what's
going on here and let's paste this data
in here and here we go so we're going to
start off with the with a TF session as
cess so that's our actual TF session
that we've created uh so we're right
here with the TF uh session our session
we're creating we're going to run TF
Global variable initializer so right off
the bat we're initializing our variables
here uh and then we have for I in range
500 so what's going on here remember 500
we're going to break the data up and
we're going to batch it in at 500 points
each each we've created our session run
so we're going to do with TF session as
session right here we've created our
variable session uh and then we're going
to run and we're going to go ahead and
initialize it so we have our TF Global
variables initializer that we created um
that initializes our our session in here
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go for I in range of 500
batch equals ch. nextext batch so if you
remember correctly this is loading up um
100 pictures at a time and uh this is
going to Loop through that 500 times so
we are literally doing uh what is that
uh 500 time 100 is uh 50,000 so that's
50,000 pictures we're going to process
right there in the first process is
we're going to do a session run we're
going to take our train we created our
train variable or Optimizer in there
we're going to feed it the dictionary uh
we had our feed dictionary that we
created and we have x equals batch 0o
coming in y true batch one hold the
probability ility .5 and then just so
that we can keep track of what's going
on we're going to every 100 steps we're
going to run a print So currently onstep
format C accuracy is um and we're going
to look at matches equals tf. equal TF
argument y prediction one tf. AR Max y
true comma one so we're going to look at
this is how many matches it has and here
our ACC uh all we're doing here is we're
going to take the matches how many match
as they have it creates it generates a
chart we're going to convert that to
float that's what the TF cast does and
then we just want to know the average we
just want to know the average of the um
accuracy and then we'll go ahead and
print that out uh print session run
accuracy feed dictionary so it takes all
this and it prints out our accuracy on
there so let's go ahead and take this
oops screens there let's go ahead and
take this and let's run it and this is
going to take a little bit to run uh so
let's see what happens on my old laptop
and we'll see here that we have have our
current uh we're currently on Step Zero
it takes a little bit to get through the
accuracy and this will take just a
moment to run we can see that on our
Step Zero it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0.128 um and as it's running we'll go
ahead you don't need to watch it run all
the way but uh this accuracy is going to
change a little bit up and down so we've
actually lost some accuracy during our
step
two um but we'll see how that comes out
let's come back after we run it all the
way through and see how the different
steps come out I was actually reading
that backwards the way this works is the
closer we get to one the more accuracy
we have uh so you can see here we've
gone from a0 one to a 39 um and we'll go
ahead and pause this and come back and
see what happens when we're done with
the full run all right now that we've uh
prepared the meal got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
youve ever watched uh any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things first first we've defined
accuracy um the reason I got it
backwards before is you have uh loss or
accuracy and with loss you'll get a
graph that looks like this it goes oops
that's an S by the way there we go you
get a graph that curves down like this
and with accuracy you get a graph that
curves up this is how good it's doing
now in this case uh one is supposed to
be really good accuracy that means it
gets close to one but it never crosses
one so if you have an accuracy of one
that is phenomenal um that's pretty much
un you know unheard of and the same
thing with loss if you have a loss of
zero that's also unheard of the zero is
actually on this this axis right here as
we go in there so how do we interpret
that because you know if I was looking
at this and I go oh 0. 51 that's uh 51%
you're doing 50/50 no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is not percentage uh this is log
rithmic what that means is that 0 2 is
twice as good as 0.1 and uh when we see
04 that's twice as good as 0. 2 real way
to convert this into a percentage you
really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this as uh 50% we're just guessing
equals .1 and if 50% roughly equals 0.1
that's where we started up here at the
top remember at the top here here's our
1028 the accuracy of 50% then 75% is
about2 and so on and so on don't quote
those numbers because it doesn't work
that way they say that if you have
.95 that's pretty much saying 100% And
if you have uh anywhere between you'd
have to go look this up let me go and
remove all my drawings there uh so the
magic number is 0.5 we really want to be
over a 05 in this whole thing and we
have uh both 0.504 remember this is
accuracy if we were looking at loss then
we'd be looking the other way but 0.0
you know instead of how high it is we
want how low it is uh but with accuracy
being over a 0.5 is pretty valid that
means this is pretty solid and if you
get to a 0.95 then it's a direct
correlation that's what we're looking
for here in these numbers you can see we
finished with this model at 0 5135 so
still good um and if we look at uh when
they ran this in the other end remember
there's a lot of Randomness that goes
into it when we see the weights uh they
got
05251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on uh just that Randomness and
so we've gone through the whole model
we've created we trained the model and
we've also gone through on every 100th
run to test the model to see how
accurate it is welcome to the RNN
tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any and to
the output nodes there are no Cycles or
Loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer I was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer it connects to
the output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output and the refer to the
input as x a lot of times and the output
as y decisions are based on current
input no memory about the past no future
scope why recurrent neural network
issues in feed forward neural network so
one of the biggest issues is because it
doesn't have a scope of memory or time a
feed forward neural network doesn't know
how to handle sequential data uh it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever I put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this this is what's
coming in and it cannot memorize
previous inputs so it doesn't have that
list of inputs coming in solution to
feed forward neural network you'll see
here where it says recurrent neural
network and we have our X on the bottom
going to H going to Y that's your feed
forward uh but right in the middle it
has a value C so it's a whole another
process it's memorizing what's going on
in the hidden layers and the hidden
layers as they produce data feed into
the next one so your hidden layer might
have an output that goes off to Y uh but
that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at General drawings
and um Solutions we should also look at
applications of the RNN image captioning
RNN is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair uh that's
very tough I mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and they image of a ball but it's able
to add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using RNN and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the New York Stock
Exchange in the US produces somewhere in
the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second um it's like three terabytes
a day of data so we're to look at one
stock just analyzing One stock is really
tricky in here we'll give you a little
jump on that so that's exciting but
don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
RNN is natural language processing text
Mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using RNN for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together together is very
different than I if I said processing
language natural Le so the time series
is very important when we're analyzing
sentiments it can change the whole value
of a sentence just by switching the
words around or if you're just counting
the words you might get one sentiment
where if you actually look at the order
they're in you get a completely
different sentiment when it rains look
for rainbows when it's dark look for
stars both of these are positive
sentiments and they're based upon the
order of which the sentence is going in
machine translation given an input in
one language RNN can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output I myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking English you would say
big cat and if you're speaking Spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in English and
getting trans translated and you can see
here a person is speaking in English in
this little diagram I guess that's
denoted by the flags I have a flag I own
it no um but they're speaking in English
and it's getting translated into Chinese
Italian French German and Spanish
languages some of the tools coming out
are just so cool so somebody like myself
who's very linguistically challenged I
can now travel into Worlds I would never
think of because I can have something
translate my English back and forth
readily and I'm not stuck with a
communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our X comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into Y and they
usually draw very simplified X to H with
c as a loop a to Y where a B and C are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the H and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the C goes in and then the X
goes in so the x is going Upward Bound
and C is going to the right a is going
out and C is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn uh CN and then we have y out and
C out and C is based on HT minus1 so our
value is based on the Y and the H value
are connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because H can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of T equals a function of C where H of T
minus one that's the last H output and x
a t going in so it's the last output of
H combined with the new input of x uh
where HT is the new State FC is a
function with the parameter C that's a
common way of denoting it uh HT minus
one is the Old State coming out and then
X is an input Vector at time of Step T
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a onetoone
single output one toone neural network
is usually known as a vanilla neural
network used for regular machine
learning problems why because vanilla is
usually considered kind of a just a real
basic flavor but because it's a very
basic a lot of times they'll call it the
vanilla neural network uh which is not
the common term but it is you know kind
of a slang term people will know what
you're talking about usually if you say
that then we run one to mini so you have
a single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case uh image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a dog
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have Min to1 Network takes in a
sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you were just adding up the words in
there and then of course if you're going
to do a one to one many to one one to
many there's many to many networks takes
in a sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in English and then
going out in the different languages uh
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called The Vanishing gradient
problem while training an RNN your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as Vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice uh image loss
of information through time so if you're
pushing not enough information forward
that information is lost and then when
you go to train it you start losing the
third word in the sentence or something
like that or it doesn't quite follow the
full logic of what you're working on
exploding gradient problem Oh this is
one that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem long training
time poor performance bad accuracy and
I'll add one more in there uh your
computer if you're on a lower-end
computer testing out a model will lock
up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence the person who took my bike and
blank a thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from Asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from Asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the RNN must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun
so was a thief is singular the student
who got into engineering well in order
to understand what would be the next
word in the sequence the RNN must
memorize the previous context whether
the subject was singular noun or a
plural noun and so you can see here the
students who got into engineering with
blank were from Asia it might be
sometimes difficult for the eror to back
propagate to the beginning of the
sequence to predict what should be the
output so when you run into the gradient
problem we need a solution the solution
to the GR gradient problem first we're
going to look at exploding gradient
where we have three different solutions
depending on what's going on one is
identity initialization so the first
thing we want to do is see if we can
find a way to minimize the identities
coming in instead of having it identify
everything just the important
information we're looking at next is to
truncate the back propagation so instead
of having uh whatever information it's
sending to the next series we can
truncate what it's sending we can lower
that particular
uh set of layers make those smaller and
finally is a gradient clipping so when
we're training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a Vanishing gradient the OPA
problem uh we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation functions so we'll
look at that just minimally uh there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short-term memory
networks the
lstms and we can make adjustments to
that so just like we can clip the
gradient as it comes out we can also um
expand on that we can increase the
memory Network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call longterm dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
Sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text I have been staying in
Spain for the last 10 years I can speak
fluent maybe you said Portuguese or
French no you probably said Spanish the
word we predict will depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of Spain to predict the
last word in the text it's possible that
the gap between between the relevant
information and the point where it is
needed to become very large
lstm help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default Behavior All recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent H
layer lstm s's also have a chain-like
structure but the repeating module has a
different structure instead of having a
single neural network layer there are
four interacting layers communicating in
a very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default Behavior LST
tms's also have a chain-like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs kit in here I
want you to note that you have X of T
minus one coming in you have x a t
coming in and you have x a t + one and
you have H of T minus one and H of T
coming in and H of T +1 going out and of
course on the other side is the output a
um in the middle we have our tangent h
but it occurs in two different places so
not only when we're Computing the x of t
+ one are we getting the tangent H from
X of T but we're also getting that value
coming in from the X of T minus one so
the short of it is as you look at these
layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes uh but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address the
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long shortterm
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing processing in the lstms that
we look at the first one is we want to
forget irrelevant parts of the previous
state you know a lot of times like you
know is as in a unless we're trying to
look at whether it's a plural noun or
not they don't really play a huge part
in the language so we want to get rid of
them then selectively update cell State
values so we only want to update the
cell State values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like uh so step one decides how much of
the past it should remember first step
in the lstm is to decide which
information to be omitted in from the
cell in that particular time step it is
decided by the sigmoid function it looks
at the previous state h of T minus one
and the current input X of T and
computes the function so you can see
over here we have a function of T equals
the sigmoid function of the weight of f
the H at T minus one and then x a t plus
of course you have a bias in there with
any of our neural networks so we have a
bias function so F of T equals forget
gate decides which information to delete
that is not important from the previous
time step considering an L STM is fed
with the following inputs from the
previous and present time step Alice is
good in physics JN on the other hand is
good in chemistry so previous output JN
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the First
full stop Compares with the current
input sentence of exit so we're looking
at that full stop and then Compares it
with the input of the new sentence the
next sentence talks about John so the
information on Alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with John then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to John and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only passing information on
John since that's now the new topic so
step two is then to decide how much
should this unit add to the current
state in the second layer there are two
parts one is the sigmoid function and
the other is the tangent H in the
sigmoid function it decides which values
to let through zero or 1 tangent H
function gives the weightage to the
values which are passed deciding their
level of importance minus one to one and
you can see the two formulas that come
up uh the I of T equals the sigmoid of
the weight of i a h of t minus1 x of t
plus the bias of I and the C of T equals
the tangent of H of the weight of C of H
of T Min - One X of t plus the bias of C
so our I of T equals the input gate
determines which information to let
through based on its significance in the
current time step if this seems a little
complicated don't worry because a lot of
the programming is already done when we
get to the case study understanding
though that this is part of the program
is important when you're trying to
figure out these what to set your
settings at you should also note when
you're looking at this it should have
some semblance to your forward
propagation neural networks where we
have a value assigned to a weight plus a
bias very important steps than any of
the neural network layers whether we're
propagating into them the information
from one to the next or we're just doing
a straightforward neural network
propagation let's take a quick look at
this what it looks like from the human
standpoint um as I step out in my suit
again consider the current input at X
oft John plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our input input
gate analysis the important information
John plays football and he was a captain
of his college team is important he told
me over the phone yesterday is less
important hence it is forgotten this
process of adding some new information
can be done via the input gate now this
example is as a human form and we'll
look at training this stuff in just a
minute uh but as a human being if I
wanted to get this information
from a conversation maybe it's a Google
Voice listening in on you or something
like that um how do we weed out the
information that he was talking to me on
the phone yesterday well I don't want to
memorize that he talked to me on the
phone yesterday or maybe that is
important but in this case it's not I
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team I want to know that he
sered I want to know that John plays
football and he was the captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that I want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human Viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell State makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell State make it to the output
then we put the cell State through the
tangent H to push the values to be
between minus one and one and multiply
it by the output of the sigmoid gate so
when we talk about the output of T we
set that equal to the sigmoid of the
weight of zero of the H of T minus one
you back One Step in Time by the x of t
plus of course the bias the H of T
equals the out of T times the tangent of
the tangent h of C so our o equals the
output gate allows the past in
information to impact the output in the
current time step let's consider the
example to predicting the next word in
the sentence John played tremendously
well against the opponent and one for
his team for his contributions Brave
blank was awarded player of the match
there could be a lot of choices for the
empty space current input Brave is an
adjective adjectives describe a noun JN
could be the best output after Brave
thumbs up for John awarded player of the
match and if you were to pull just the
nouns out of the sentence team doesn't
look right because that's not really the
subject we're talking about
contributions you know Brave
contributions or Brave team Brave player
Brave match um so you look at this and
you can start to train this these this
neural network so starts looking at and
goes oh no JN is what we're talking
about so brave is an adjective Jon's
going to be the best output and we give
John a big thumbs up and then of course
we jump into my favorite part the case
study use case implementation of lstm
let's predict the prices of stocks using
the lstm network based on the stock
price data between 2012 2016 we're going
to try to predict the stock prices of
201 17 and this will be a narrow set of
data we're not going to do the whole
stock market it turns out that the New
York Stock Exchange generates roughly
three terabytes of data per day that's
all the different trades up and down of
all the different stocks going on and
each individual one uh second to second
or nanc to nanc uh but we're going to
limit that to just some very basic
fundamental information so don't think
you're going to get rich off this today
but at least you can give an a you can
give a step forward in how to start
processing something like stock prices a
very valid use for machine learning in
today's markets use case implementation
of
LSM let's dive in we're going to import
our libraries we're going to import the
training set and uh get the scaling
going U now if you watch any of our
other tutorials a lot of these pieces
just start to look very familiar CU it's
very similar setup uh but let's take a
look at that and um just a reminder
we're going to be using Anaconda the
Jupiter notebook so here I have have my
anaconda Navigator when we go under
environments I've actually set up a
carass python 36 I'm in Python 36 and U
nice thing about Anaconda especially the
newer version remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python and different
environments um Anaconda now has a nice
interface um and I have this installed
both on a Ubuntu Linux machine and on
window so it works fine on there and you
can go in here and open a terminal
window and then in here once you're in
the terminal window this is you're going
to start uh installing using pip to
install your different modules and
everything now we've already
pre-installed them so we don't need to
do that in here uh but if you don't have
them installed on your particular
environment you'll need to do that and
of course you don't need to use the
anaconda or the Jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python ID you like I'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine I have specifically
installed one for carass since we're
going to be working with carass under
tensor flow when we go back to home I
gone up here to application and that's
the environment I've loaded on here and
then we'll click on the launch Jupiter
notebook now I've already in my Jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh Martha Stewarts in the old cooking
shows we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and uh if we go up here
to where it says new you can see where
you can um create a new Python 3 that's
what we did here underneath the setup so
it already has all the modules installed
on it and I'm actually rename this if
you go under file you can rename it we
I'm calling it RNN stock and let's just
take a look at start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine uh let's start
putting that code in there and seeing
what those Imports and uploading
everything looks like now first half is
kind of boring when we hit the rum
button because we're going to be
importing numpy as NP that's uh uh the
number python which is your numpy array
and the matap plot Library cuz we're
going to do some plotting at the end and
our pandas for our data set our pandas
is PD and when I hit run it really
doesn't do anything except for load
those modules just a quick note let me
just do a quick uh draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if I was to divide this
up oops I'm going to actually U let's
overlap these here we
go uh this first part that we're going
to do
is our data
prep a lot of prepping
involved um in fact depending on what
your system and since we're using carass
I put an overlap here uh but you'll find
that almost maybe even half of the code
we do is all about the data prep and the
reason I overlapped this with uh carass
let me just put that down because that's
what we're working in uh is because
carass has like their own preset stuff
so it's already pre-built in which is
really nice so there's a couple Steps A
lot of times that are in the Kass setup
uh we'll take a look at that to see what
comes up in our code as we go through
and look at stock and then the last part
is to evaluate and if you're working
with um shareholders or uh you know
classroom whatever it is you're working
with uh the valuate is the next biggest
piece um so the actual code here crossed
is a little bit more but when you're
working with uh some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your pre-processing in your data since
Cor has is is Cutting Edge and you load
the individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and cross
is a little bit more robust and then you
spend a lot of times uh like I said with
the evaluate you want to have something
you present to everybody else to say hey
this is what I did this is what it looks
like so let's go through those steps
this is like a kind of just general
overview and let's just take a look and
see what the next set of code looks like
and in here we have a data set train and
it's going to be read using the PD or
pandas read CSV and it's a Google stock
pric train.csv and so under this we have
training set equals data set train.
iocation and we've kind of sorted out
part of that so what's going on here
let's just take a look at let's let's
look at the actual file and see what's
going on there now if we look at this
ignore all the extra files on this um I
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take 20 % of the data out so
we can test it and then we train the
rest of it that's what we use to create
our neural network that way we can find
out how good it is uh but let's go ahead
and just take a look and see what that
looks like as far as the file itself and
I went ahead and just opened this up in
a basic word pad text editor just so we
can take a look at it certainly you can
open up an Excel or any other kind of
spreadsheet um and we note that this is
a comma separated variables we have a
date uh open high low close volume this
is a standard stuff that we import into
our stock one the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download um in this
case we downloaded it from uh Google
that's why we call it the Google stock
price um and it specifically is Google
this is the Google stock values from uh
you see can see here we started off at
20102 so when we look at this first
setup up here uh we have a data set
train equals pdor CSV and if you noticed
on the original frame uh let me just go
back there they had it set to home
Ubuntu downloads Google stock price
train I went ahead and change that
because we're in the same file where I'm
running the code so I've saved this
particular python code and I don't need
to go through any special paths or have
the full path on there and then of
course we want to take out um certain
values in here and you're going to
notice that we're using um our data set
and we're now in pandas uh so pandas
basically looks like a spreadsheet um
and in this case we're going to do I
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we always start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open and high which would be one and
two
I'll just label that right there so you
can see now when you go back and do this
you certainly can extrapolate and do
this on all the columns um but for the
example let's just limit a little bit
here so that we can focus on just some
key aspects of
stock and then we'll go up here and run
the code and uh again I said the first
half is very boring whenever you hit the
Run button it doesn't do anything
because we're still just loading the
data and setting it up now that we've
loaded our data we want to go ahead and
scale it we want to do what they call
feature scaling and in here we're going
to pull it up from the sklearn or the SK
kit pre-processing import min max scaler
and when you look at this you got to
remember that um biases in our data we
want to get rid of that so if you have
something that's like a really high
value U let's just draw a quick graph
and I have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value One stock has a
value of 100 and another stock has a
value of
five um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100's going to
be the Max and five is going to be the
Min and then everything else goes and
then we change this so we just squish it
down I like the word squish so it's
between one and zero so 100 equals 1 or
1al 100 and 0al 5 and you can just
multiply it's usually just a simple
multiplication we're using uh
multiplication so it's going to be uh
minus5 and then 100 divided or 95
divided by 1 so or whatever value is is
divided by
95 and uh once we've actually created
our scale we've toing it's going to be
from 0 to one we want to take our
training set and we're going to create a
training set scaled and we're going to
use our scaler SC and we're going to fit
we're going to fit and transform the
training Set uh so we can now use the SC
this this particular object we use it
later on our testing set CU remember we
have to also scale that when we go to
test our uh model and see how it works
and we'll go ahead and click on the run
again uh it's not going to have any
output yet because we're just setting up
all the
variables okay so we pasted the data in
here and we're going to create the data
structure with the 60 time steps and
output first note we're running 60 time
steps and that is where this value here
also comes in so the first thing we do
is we create our X train and Y train
variables we set them to an empty python
array very important to remember what
kind of array we're in and what we're
working with and then we're going to
come in here we're going to go for I in
range 60 to 1258 there's our 60 60 time
steps and the reason we want to do this
is as we're adding the data in there
there's nothing below the 60 so if we're
going to use 60 time steps uh we have to
start at Point 60 because it includes
everything underneath of it otherwise
you'll get a pointer error and then
we're going to take our X train and
we're going to append training set
scaled this is a scaled value between
0er and one and then as I is equal to 60
this value is going to be um 60 minus 60
is 0o so this actually is 0 to I so it's
going to be 0 to 60 1 to 61 let me just
circle this part right here 1 to 61 uh 2
to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember I said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not not count remember
it starts at zero so this is a count of
60 so it's actually 59 important to
remember that as we're looking at this
and then the second part of this that
we're looking at so if you remember
correctly here we go we go from uh 0 to
59 of I and then we have a comma a zero
right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now I
know we did put it in there for 1 to two
um if you remember correctly it doesn't
count the second one so it's just the
open value we're looking at just open
um and then finally we have y train.
append training set I to zero and if you
remember correctly I to or I comma 0 if
you remember correctly this is 0 to 59
so there's 60 values in it uh so when we
do I down here this is number 60 so
we're going to do this is we're creating
an array and we have 0 to
59 and over here we have number 60 which
is going into the Y train it's being
being appended on there and then this
just goes all the way up so this is down
here is uh uh 0 to 59 and we'll call it
60 since that's the value over here and
it goes all the way up to 12 58 that's
where this value here comes in that's
the length of the data we're loading so
we've loaded two arrays we've loaded one
array that has uh which is filled with
arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded one
array which is just the value and what
we're looking at you want to think about
this is a Time sequence uh here's my
open open open open open open what's the
next one in the series so we're looking
at the Google stock and each time it
opens we want to know what the next one
uh 0 through 59 what's 60 1 through 60
what's 61 2 through 62 what's 62 and so
on and so on going up and then once
we've loaded those in our for Loop we go
ahead and take X train and Y train
equals np. array XT tr. NP array YT
train we're just converting this back
back into a numpy array that way we can
use all the cool tools that we get with
numpy array including reshaping so if we
take a look and see what's going on here
we're going to take our X
train we're going to reshape it wow what
the heck does reshape mean uh that means
we have an array if you remember
correctly um so many numbers by
60 that's how wide it is and so we're
when you when you do xtrain do shape
that gets one of the shapes and you get
um XT train. shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um in this case where's that value 60
by
1199 1258 - 60 1199 and we're making
sure that that is shaped correctly so
the data is grouped into uh 11 99 by 60
different arrays and then the one on the
end just means at the end because this
when you're deal dealing with shapes and
numpy they look at this as layers and so
the in layer needs to be one value
that's like the leaf of a tree where
this is the branch and then it branches
out some more um and then you get the
Leaf np. reshaped comes from and using
the existing shapes to form it we'll go
ahead and run this piece of code again
there's no real output and then we'll
import our different carass modules that
we need so from carass Models we're
going to import the sequential mod model
dealing with sequential data we have our
dense layers we have actually three
layers we're going to bring in our dense
our lstm which is what we're focusing on
and our Dropout and we'll discuss these
three layers more in just a moment but
you do need the with the lstm you do
need the Dropout and then the final
layer will be the dents but let's go
ahead and run this and that'll bring
Port our modules and you'll see we get
an error on here and if you read it
closer it's not actually an error it's a
warning what does this warning mean
these things come up all the time when
you're working with such cutting Cutting
Edge modules that are completely being
updated all the time we're not going to
worry too much about the warning all
it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of carass is
going to be updated at some point and uh
if you're running new stuff on carass
and you start updating your carass
system you better make sure that your H5
Pi is updated too otherwise you're going
to have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the H5 Pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and I said we're going to jump in
and start looking at what those layers
mean I meant that and uh we're going to
start off with initializing the RNN and
then we'll start adding those layers in
and you'll see that we have the lstm and
then the Dropout lstm then Dropout lstm
then Dropout what the heck is that doing
so let's explore that we'll start by
initializing the RNN regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
Dropout regularization and right there
should be the que Dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the Dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amount of data through um
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and uh add this in
I'll go ahead and run this and we had
three of them so let me goe and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go and put two more in I meant
to I said one more in but it's actually
two more in and then let's add one more
after that and as you can see each time
I run these they don't actually have an
output so let's take a closer look and
see what's going on here so we're going
to add our first lstm layer in here
we're going to have units 50 the units
is the positive integer and it's the
dimensionality of the output space this
is what's going out into the next layer
so we might have 60 coming in but we
have 50 going out we have a return
sequence because it is a sequence data
so we want to keep that true and then
you have to tell it what shape it's in
well we already know the shape by just
going in here and looking at xtrain
shape so input shape equals the xtrain
shape of one comma 1 makes it really
easy you don't have to remember all the
numbers that put in 60 or whatever else
is in there you just let it tell the
regressor what model to use and so we
follow our STM with a Dropout layer now
understanding the Dropout layer is kind
of exciting because one of the things
that Happ happens is we can overtrain
our Network that means that our neural
network will memorize such specific data
that it has trouble predicting anything
that's not in that specific realm to fix
for that each time we run through the
training mode we're going to take 0 2 or
20% of our neurons and just turn them
off so we're only going to train on the
other ones and it's going to be random
that way each time we pass through this
we don't overtrain these nodes come back
in in the next training cycle we
randomly pick a different 20 and finally
they see a big difference as we go from
the first to the second and third and
fourth the first thing is we don't have
to input the shape because the shape's
already the output units is 50 here this
Auto The Next Step automatically knows
this layer is putting out 50 and because
it's the next layer it automatically
sets that and says oh 50 is coming out
from our last layer it's coming out you
know goes into the regressor and of
course we have our Dropout and that's
what's coming into this one and so on
and so on and so the next three layers
we don't have to let it know what the
shape is it automatically understands
that and we're going to keep the units
the same we're still going to do 50
units it's still a sequence coming
through 50 units and a sequence now the
next piece of code is what brings it all
together let's go ahead and take a look
at that and we come in here we put the
output layer the dense layer and if you
remember up here we had the three layers
we had uh lstm Dropout and dense uh
dense just says we're going to bring
this all down into one output instead of
putting out a sequence we just know want
to know the answer at this point and
let's go ahead and run that and so in
here you notice all we're doing is
setting things up one step at a time so
far we've brought in our uh way up here
we brought in our data we brought in our
different modules we formatted the data
for training it we've set it up you know
we have our y x train and our y train we
have our source of data and the answers
we're we know so far that we're going to
put in there we've reshaped that we've
come in and built our carass we've
imported our different layers and we
have in here if you look we have what uh
five total layers now carass is a little
different than a lot of other systems
because a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in carass is Cutting Edge for this
reason so even though there's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from carass so we brought in our den we
have our full model put together our Reg
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and I can go ahead and run that and
uh if you've been looking at any of our
other tutorials on neural networks
you'll see we're going to use the
optimizer atom atom is optimize for Big
Data there's a couple other optimizers
out there uh beyond the scope of this
tutorial but certainly add will work
pretty good for this and loss equals
mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error where
we're going to use the mean squared
value for our error and the atom
Optimizer for its differential equations
you don't have to know the math behind
them but certainly it helps to know what
they're doing and where they fit into
the bigger models and then finally we're
going to do our fit fitting the RN into
the training set we have the regressor
do fit xtrain y train epics and batch
size so we know where this is this this
is our data coming in for the X train
our y train is the answer we're looking
for of our data our sequential input
epic is how many times we're going to go
over the whole data set we created a
whole data set of X train so this is
each each of those rows which includes a
Time sequence of 60 and badge size
another one of those things where carass
really shines is if you were pulling
this save from a large file instead of
trying to load it all into RAM it can
now pick smaller batches up and load
those indirectly we're not worried about
pulling them off a file today cuz this
isn't big enough to uh cause the
computer too much of a problem to run
not too straining on the resources but
as we run this you can imagine what
would happen if I was doing a lot more
than just one column in one set of stock
in this case Google stock imagine if I
was doing this across all the stocks and
I had instead of just the open I had
open close high low and you can actually
find yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 because it's a Time
sequence suddenly you find yourself with
a gig of memory you're loading into your
RAM which will just completely you know
if it's just if you're not on multiple
computers or cluster you're going to
start running into resource problems but
for this we don't have to worry about
that so let's go ahead and run this and
this will actually take a little bit on
my computer it's an older laptop and
give it a second to kick in there there
we go all right so we have epic so this
is going to tell me it's running the
first run through all the data and as
it's going through it's batching them in
32 pieces so 32 uh lines each time and
there's 1198 I think I said 1199 earlier
but it's 1198 I was off by one and each
one of these is 13 seconds so you can
imagine this is roughly 20 to 30 minutes
runtime on this computer like I said
it's an older laptop running at uh 0.9
GHz on a dual processor and that's fine
what we'll do is I'll go ahead and stop
go get a drink of coffee and come back
and let's see what happens at the end
and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show I've kind of gotten my
latte I also had some other stuff
running in the background so you'll see
see these numbers jumped up to like 19
seconds 15 seconds which you can scroll
through and you can see we've run it
through 100 steps or 100 epics so the
question is what does all this mean one
of the first things you'll notice is
that our loss is over here it kind of
stopped at 0.0014 but you can see it
kind of goes down until we hit about
0.0014 three times in a row so we
guessed our epic pretty close since our
loss has remain the same on there so def
find out we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet
and real stock price data set test
iocation this is the same thing we did
when we prepped the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and you see we've labeled it
part three making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing we need to do is go ahead and read
the data in from our test CSV and you
see I've changed the path on it for my
computer and uh then we'll call it the
real stock price and again we're doing
just the one column here and the values
from ication so it's all the rows and
just the values from these that one
location that's the open Stock open and
let's go ahead and run that so that's
loaded in there and then let's go ahead
and uh create we have our inputs we're
going to create inputs here and this
should all look familiar this is the
same thing we did before we're going to
take our data set total we're going to
do a little Panda concap from the data
set train now remember the end of the
data set train is part of the data going
in and let's just visualize that just a
little bit here's our train data let me
just put TR for train and it went up to
this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns so
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data so to find out we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and uh real stock
price data set test iocation this is is
the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test CSV and you see I've
changed the path on it for my computer
and uh then we'll call it the real stock
price and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from ication
so it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open Stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and uh create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar this
is the same thing we did before we're
going to take our data set total we're
going to do a little Panda concat from
the data set train now remember the end
of the data set train is part of the
data going in and let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put TR for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data cuz that's
part of the next data or it's actually
the top 59 so that's what this first
setup is over here is we're going in
we're doing the real stock price and
we're going to just take the data set
test and we're going to load that in and
then the real stock price is our data
test. location so we're just looking at
that first uh column the open price and
then our data set total we're going to
take pandas and we're going to concat
and we're going to take our data set
train for the open and our data set test
open and this is one way you can
reference these columns we've referenced
them a couple different ways we
referenced them up here with the one two
but we know it's labeled as a panda set
is open so pandas is great that way lots
of Versatility there and we'll go ahead
and go back up here and run this there
we go and uh you'll notice this is the
same as what we did before we have our
open open data set we pended our two
different or concatenated our two data
sets together we have our inputs equals
data set total length data set total
minus length of data set minus test
minus 60 values so we're going to run
this over all of them and you'll see why
this works because normally when you're
running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs. reshapes
or reshaping like we did before we're
Transforming Our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally want to go ahead
and take our X test and we're going to
create that X test and for I in range 60
to 80 so here's our X test and we're
pending our inputs I to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and I comma 0 on the
other side so that's just the First
Column which is our open column and uh
once again we take our X test we convert
it to a numpy array we do the same
reshape we did before and uh then we get
get down to the final two lines and here
we have something new right here on
these last two lines let me just
highlight those or or mark them
predicted stock price equals regressor
do predicts X test so we're predicting
all the stock including both the
training and the testing model here and
then we want to take this prediction and
we want to inverse the transform so
remember we put them between zero and
one well that's not going to mean very
much to me to look at a at a float
number between Z one I want the dollar
amounts I want to know what the cash
value is and we'll go ahead and run this
and you'll see it runs much quicker than
the training that's what's so wonderful
about these neural networks once you put
them together it takes just a second to
run the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train ahead and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
what the Google stock actually did so
let's go ahead and take a look at that
in code and let's uh pull this code up
so we have our PLT that's our uh oh if
you remember from the very beginning let
me just go back up to the top we have
our matplot library. pyplot as PLT
that's where that comes in and we come
down here we're going to plot let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and PLT is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when I'm doing
graphs in Python because I always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case PLT is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done HTML 5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be a bright red we're
going to label it real Google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your H graph especially if you're
going to present this to somebody you
know to your shareholders in the office
and uh the X label is going to be time
because it's a Time series and we didn't
actually put the actual date and times
on here but that's fine we just know
they're incremented by time and then of
course the w label is the actual stock
price pt. Legend tells us to build the
legend on here so that the color red and
and real Google stock price show up on
there and then the plot shows us that
actual graph so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and
you can see here we have a nice graph
and let's talk just a little bit about
this graph before we wrap it up here's
our Legend I was telling you about
that's why we have the legend to showed
the prices we have our title and
everything and you'll notice on the
bottom we have a Time sequence we didn't
put the actual time in here now we could
have we could have gone ahead and um
plotted the X since we know what the the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know it's only the last piece of
data that we're looking at so last piece
of data which ends somewhere probably
around here on the graph I think it's
like about 20% of the data probably less
than that we have the Google price and
the Google price has this little up jump
and then down and you'll see that the
actual Google instead of a a turn down
here just didn't go up as high and
didn't low go uh down so our prediction
has the same pattern but the overall
value is pretty far off as far as um
stock but then again we're only looking
at one column we're only looking at the
open price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like I was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's whether uh I mean volume shares
then there's the adjusted open adjusted
High adjusted low adjusted clothes they
have a special formula to predict
exactly what it would really be worth
based on the value of the stock and then
from there there's all kinds of other
stuff you can put in here so we're only
looking at one small aspect the opening
price of the stock and as you can see
here we did a pretty good job this curve
follows the curve pretty well it has
like a you know little jumps on it bends
they don't quite match up so this Bend
here does not quite match up with that
bin there but it's pretty darn close we
have the basic shape of it and the
prediction isn't too far off and you can
imagine that as we add more data in and
look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if I was running it across all
those different variables might take a
little bit longer to train the data not
so good for doing a quick tutorial like
this so we're going to dive right into
what is carass we'll also uh go all the
way through this into a couple of
tutorials because that's where you
really learn a lot is when you roll up
your sleeves so we talk about what is
carass carass is a highlevel deep
learning API written in Python for easy
impl implementation of neural networks
uses deep learning Frameworks such as
tensor flow pytorch Etc is back in to
make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a programmer there is so much stuff
out there and it's evolving so fast it
can get confusing and having some kind
of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks uh is
really powerful it's really powerful to
to um uh have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going so
cross works by using complex deep
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch um mlpl Etc as a back end for
fast computation while providing a
userfriendly and easy tolearn
front end and you can see here we have
the carass API uh specifications and
under that you'd have like TF carass for
tensor flow thano coros and so on and
then you have your tensorflow workflow
that this is all sitting on top
of and this is like I said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensor flow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to um dig as deeply into the
heavy-end stuff while still having a
very robust package you can get up and
running rather quickly and it doesn't
distract from the processing time
because all the heavy lifting is done by
packages like tensor flow this is the
organization on top of it so the working
principle of
carass uh the working principle of
carass is carass uses computational
graphs to express and evaluate
mathematical
Expressions you can see here we put them
in blue they have the expression um
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators uh where we have like the
percentage or in this case in Python
that's usually your uh left your um
remainder or multiplication uh you might
have the operator of x uh to the power
of3 and it us is useful for calculating
derivatives by using uh back propagation
so if we're doing with neural networks
when we send the error back up to figure
out how to change it uh this makes it
really easy to do that without really
having not banging your head and having
to hand write everything it's easier to
implement distributed computation and
for solving complex problems uh specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are
connected and so this is really nice as
you come in through is that um as your
layers are going in there you can get
some very complicated uh different
setups nowadays which we'll look at in
just a second and this just makes it
really easy to start spinning this stuff
up and trying out the different models
so when we look at caros models uh caros
model we have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next
layer and this if you've done anything
else even like the sklearn with their
neural networks and propagation and any
of these setups this should look
familiar you should have your input
layer it goes into your layer one layer
two and then to the output layer and
it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models and you you can see down
here we have the model equals a coros
sequential and this is the actual code
you can see how easy it is uh we have a
layer that's dense your layer one has an
activation they're using the railu in
this particular example and then you
have your name layer one layer dense
Rayo name Layer Two and so forth uh and
they just feed right into each other so
it's really easy just to stack them as
you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your carass
or you'll find yourself running this um
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release and he uses
multi-input and multi-output model the
complex model which Forks into two or
more branches and you can see here we
have our image inputs equals your coros
input shape equals 32x 32 by three you
have your dense layers dense 64
activation railu this looks similar to
what you already saw before uh but if
you look at the graph on the right it's
going to be a lot easier to see what's
going on you have two different
inputs uh and one way you could think of
this is maybe one of those is a small
image and one of those is a full-sized
image and that feedback goes into you
might feed both of them into one note
because it's looking for one thing and
then only into one node for the other
one and so you can start to get kind of
an idea that there's a lot of use for
this kind of split and this kind of
setup uh where we have multiple
information coming in but the
information's very different even though
it overlaps and you don't want it to
send it through the same neural network
um and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the date up
and and how you Fork the models coming
down and so in here we do have the two
complex uh models coming in uh we have
our image inputs which is a 32x 32 by3
your three channels or four if you're
having an alpha channel uh you have your
dense your layers dense is 64 activation
using the railu very common uh x equals
dense inputs X layers dense x64
activation equals Rao X outputs equals
layers dense 10 X model equals coros
model inputs equals inputs outputs
equals outputs name equals n
model uh so we add a little name on
there and again this is this kind of
split here this is setting us up to um
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at corus
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex maical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer and you can see here
we have the really standard graph input
layer a hidden layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data
pre-processing uh so we always have to
touch base on that with the neural
network like many of these models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in you train it and you
test it and see how good it was and you
have to pre-process that data because
bad data in is uh bad outputs so in data
pre-processing we will create our own
data examples set with carass the data
consists of a clinical trial conducted
on 2100 patients ranging from ages 13 to
100 with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age we want
to find the possibility of a patient
experiencing side effects due to their
age and you can think of this in today's
world with uh covid uh what's going to
happen on there and we're going to go
ahead and do an example of that in our
uh live Hands-On like I said most of
this you really need to have handson to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and uh open that up and
open up a Jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your uh setups I just like
those for doing demos and uh showing
people especially share holders it
really helps CU it's a nice visual so
let me go and flip over to our anaconda
and the Anaconda has a lot of cool to
tools they just added datal lore and IBM
Watson Studio clad into the Anaconda
framework but we'll be in the Jupiter
lab or Jupiter notebook um I'm going to
do Jupiter notebook for this because I
use the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces cuz has multiple tabs
where the notebook will work fine for
what we're doing and this opens up in
our browser window because that's how
Jupiter notebook sorry Jupiter notebook
is set to run and we'll go under new
create a new Python 3 and uh it creates
an Untitled python we'll go ahead and
give this a title and we'll just call
this uh
cross
tutorial and let's change that to
Capital there we go we go and just
rename that and the first thing we want
to go ahead and do is uh get some
pre-processing tools involved and so we
need to go ahead and import some stuff
for that like our numpy do some random
number
Generation Um I mentioned sklearn or
your s kit if you're installing sklearn
the sklearn stuff it's a s kit you want
to look
up that should be a tool of anybody who
is um doing data science if if you're
not if you're not familiar with the
sklearn
toolkit it's huge uh but there's so many
things in there that we always go back
to and we want to go ahead and create
some train labels and train samples uh
for training our
data and then just a note of what we're
we're actually doing in here uh let me
go ahead and change this this is kind of
a fun thing you can do we can change the
code to
markdown and then markdown code is nice
for doing examples once you've already
built this uh our example data we're
going to do
experimental there we go experimental
drug was tested on 2100 individuals
between 13 to 100 years of age half the
participants are under 65 and 95% of
participants are under 65 experien no
side effects well 95% of participants
over 65 um experience side effects so
that's kind of where we're starting at
um and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more uh complicated
information uh and so we want to go
ahead and
generate our setup uh so we want to do
for I in range and we want to go ahead
and create if you look here we have
random
integers train the labels of pin so
we're just creating some random
data uh let me go ahead and just run
that and so once we've cre our random
data and if you if I mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from Simply learn they'll send you a
copy of this or you can zoom in on the
video and see how we went ahead and did
our train samples a pin um and we're
just using this I do this kind of stuff
all the time I was running a thing on uh
that had to do with errors following a
bell-shaped curve on uh a standard
distribution error and so what do I do I
generate the data on a standard
distribution error to see what it looks
like and how my code processes it since
that was the Baseline I was looking for
in this we're just doing uh uh
generating random data for our setup on
here and uh we could actually go in uh
print some of the data up let's just do
this
print um we'll do
[Music]
train
samples and we'll just do the first um
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like and you can see the
first five pie pieces of data in our
train samples is 49 85 41 68 19 just
random numbers generated in there that's
all that is uh and we generated
significantly more than that um let's
see 50 up here 1,000 yeah so there's
1,000 here 1,00 numbers we generated and
we could also if we wanted to find that
out we could do a quick uh print the
length of
it and so or you could do a shape kind
of thing and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in
there and then we want to go ahead and
take our labels oh that was our train
labels we also did samples didn't
we uh so we could also print do the same
thing oh
labels um and let's change this
to
labels and
[Music]
labels and run that just to double check
and sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one Z one0 one0 I guess that's
if they have symptoms or not one
symptoms uh zero none and so we want to
go ahead and take our train labels and
we'll convert it into a numpy array and
the same thing with our samples and
let's go ahead and run that
and we also Shuffle uh this is just a
neat feature you can do in uh numpy
right here put my drawing thing on which
I didn't have on earlier um I can take
the data and I can Shuffle it uh so we
have our so it's it just randomizes it
that's all that's doing um we've already
randomized it so it's kind of an
Overkill it's not really
necessary but if you're doing uh a
larger package where the data is coming
in and a lot of times it's organized
somehow and you want to randomize it
just to make sure that that you know the
input doesn't follow a certain pattern
uh that might create a bias in your
model and we go ahead and create a
scaler uh the scaler range uh minimum
Max scaler feature range 0 to one uh
then we go ahead and scale the uh scaled
train samples we're going to go ahead
and fit and transform the data uh so
it's nice and scaled and that is the age
uh so you can see up here we have 498
541 we're just moving that so it's going
to be uh between zero and one and so
this is true with any of your neural
networks you really want to convert the
data uh to zero and one otherwise you
create a bias uh so if you have like a
100 creates a bias
versus the math behind it gets really
complicated um if you actually start
multiplying stuff there a lot of
multiplication addition going on in
there that higher end value will
eventually multiply down and it will
have a huge bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupyter Notebook is that if you have
a variable and you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line it
will automatically
print um and we're just going to look at
the first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go uh 9 95 791
so everything's between zero and one and
that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good uh it really
helps a lot to do these kind of print
UPS halfway through uh you never know
what's going to go on
there I don't know how many times I've
gotten down and found out that the data
sent to me that I thought was scaled was
not and then I have to go back and track
it down and figure it out on
there uh so let's go ahead and create
our artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensor flow and
carass uh tensor
flow if you don't know the history of
tensor
flow it helps to uh jump into we'll just
use
Wikipedia careful don't quote Wikipedia
on these things because you get in
trouble uh but it's a good place to
start uh back in 2011 Google brain built
disbelief as a proprietary machine
learning setup to tensor flow became the
open source for it uh so tensor flow was
a Google product and then it became uh
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defos when it comes
for neural networks as far as where
we're at uh so when you see the
tensorflow
setup it it's got like a huge following
there are some other setups like a um
the S kit under the sklearn has her own
little neural network uh but the tensor
flow is the most Rob robust one out
there right now and carass sitting on
top of it makes it a very powerful tool
so we can leverage both the carass uh
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup on top of tensor
flow and so in here we're going to go
ahead and do our input of tensor flow uh
and then we have the rest of this is all
carass here from number two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the coros uh connection and then you
have your tensor flow cross models
import sequential it's a specific kind
of model we'll look at that in just a
second if you remember from the files
that means it goes from one layer to the
next layer to the next layer there's no
funky splits or anything like
that uh and then we have from tenser
flow cross layers we're going to import
our activation and our dense
layer and we have our Optimizer atom um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize
uh your data when you first do it atom's
as good as any atom is usually uh
there's a number of Optimizer out there
there's about uh there's a couple main
ons but atom is usually assigned to
bigger data uh it works fine usually the
lower data does it just F but atom is
probably the mostly used but there are
some more out there and depending on
what you're doing with your layers your
different layers might have different
activations on them and then finally
down here you'll see um our setup where
we want to go ahead and use the
metrics and we're going to use the
tensorflow cross metrics um for
categorical cross entropy uh so we can
see how everything performs when we're
done that's all that is um a lot of
times you'll see us go back and forth
between tensor flow and then pyit has a
lot of really good metrics also for
measuring these things um again it's the
end of the you know at the end of the
story how good does your model do and
we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part um I actually
like to spend hours messing with these
things and uh four lines of code you're
like ah you're G to spend hours on four
lines of code um no we don't spend hours
on four lines of code that's not what
we're talking about when I say spend
hours on four lines of code uh what we
have here I'm going to explain that in
just a second we have a model and it's a
sequential model if you remember
correctly we mentioned the sequential up
here where it goes from one layer to the
next and and our first layer is going to
be our
input it's going to be uh what they call
D which is um usually it's just dents
and then you have your input and your
activation um how many units are coming
in we have 16 uh what's the shape What's
the activation and this is where it gets
interesting um because we have in here
uh
railu on two of these and soft Max
activation on one of these
there are so many different options for
what these mean um and how they function
how does the ru how does the softmax
function and they do a lot of different
things um we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different
activations um and just some of it is
just U um almost like you're playing
with it like an artist you start start
getting a fill for like a uh inverse
tangent activation or the tan H
activation takes up a huge processing
amount uh so you don't see it a lot yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing Word documents and
you're tokenizing the words and so
you'll see the shift from one to the
other because you're both trying to
build a better model and if you're
working on a huge data set
um it'll crash the system it'll just
take too long to process um and then you
see things like soft Max uh soft Max
generates an interesting um
setup where a lot of these when you talk
about rayu oops let me do this uh rayu
there we go rayu has um a setup where if
it's less than zero it's zero and then
it goes up um and then you might have
what they call lazy uh setup where it
has a slight negative to it so that the
errors can translate better same thing
with softmax it has a slight laziness to
it so that errors translate better all
these little
details make a huge different on your
model um so one of the really cool
things about data science that I like is
you build your uh what they call you
build def fail and it's an interesting
uh design setup oops I forgot the end of
my code
here the concept of build a fail is you
want the model as a whole to work so you
can test your model
out so what you can do uh you can get to
the end and you can do your let's see
where was it overshot down here you can
test your test out the quality of your
setup on there and see where did I do my
tensor FL oh here we go I did it was
right above me here we go we start doing
your cross entropy and stuff like that
is you need a a full functional set of
code so that when you run
it you can then test your model out and
say hey it's either this model works
better than this model and this is why
um and then you can start swapping in
these models and so when I say I spend a
huge amount of time on pre-processing
data is probably 80% of your programming
time um well between those two it's like
8020 you'll spend a lot of time on the
models once you get the model down once
you get the whole code and the flow down
uh that depending on your data your
models get more and more robust as you
start experimenting with different
inputs different data streams and all
kinds of things and we can do a simple
model summary
here uh here's our sequential here's our
layer our output our
parameter this is one of the nice things
about carass is you just you can see
right here here's our sequential one
model boom boom boom boom everything's
set and clear and easy to read so once
we have our model built uh the next
thing we're going to want to do is we're
want to go ahead and uh train that
model and so the next step is of course
model
training and when we come in here this a
lot of times is just paired with the
model because it's so straightforward
it's nice to print out the model setup
so you can have a
tracking but here's our model uh the
keyword in Cross is
compile optimize are atom learning rate
another term right there that we're just
skipping right over that really becomes
the meat of um the setup is your
learning rate uh so whoops I forgot that
I had an arrow but I'll just underline
it a lot of times the learning rate set
to 0.0 uh set to 0.01 uh depending on
what you're doing this learning rate um
can overfit and underfit uh so you'd
want to look up I know we have a number
of tutorials out on overfitting and
underfitting that are really worth
reading once you get to that point in
understanding and we have our loss um
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell carass how far to go
until it stops and then we're looking
for metrics of accuracy so we'll go
ahead and run that and now that we've
compiled our model we want to go ahead
and um run it fit it so here's our model
fit um we have our scaled train
samples our train labels our validation
split um in this case we're going to use
10% of the data for
validation uh batch size another number
you kind of play with not a huge
difference as far as how it works but it
does affect how long it takes to run and
it can also affect the bias a little bit
uh most of the time though a batch size
is between 10 to 100 um depending on
just how much data you're process
processing in there we want to go ahead
and Shuffle it uh we're going to go
through 30 epics and uh put a verbose of
two let me just go and run this and you
can see right here here's our epic
here's our training um here's our loss
now if you remember correctly up here we
set the loss let's see where was it um
compiled our
data there we go loss uh so it's looking
at the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the um
error go down uh is the best way to look
at that and you can see here the lower
the number the better it just keeps
going down and vice versa accuracy we
want let's see where's my
accuracy value accuracy at the end uh
and you can see 619 69. 74 it's going up
we want the accuracy would be ideal if
it made it all the way to one but we
also the loss is more important because
it's a balance um you can have 100%
accuracy and your model doesn't work
because it's overfitted uh again you
won't look up overfitting and
underfitting
models we went ahead and went through uh
30 epics it's always fun to kind of
watch your code going um to be honest I
usually uh um the first time I run it
I'm like Ah that's cool I get to see
what it does and after the second time
of running it I'm like I like to just
not see that and you can repress those
of course in your code uh repress the
warnings in the
printing and so the next step is going
to be building a test set and predicting
it now uh so here we go we want to go
ahead and build our test set and we have
just like we did our training
set a lot of times you just split your
your initial setup uh but we'll go ahead
and do a separate set on here and this
is just what we did above uh there's no
difference as far as
um the randomness that we're using to
build this set on here uh the only
difference is
that we already uh did our scaler up
here well that doesn't matter because
the the data is going to be across the
same thing but this should just be just
transform down here instead of fit
transform uh because you don't want to
refit your data um on your testing
data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data um easy mistake to make
especially on an example like this where
we're not doing um you know we're
randomizing the data anyway so it
doesn't matter too much because we're
not expecting something
weird and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
xcal data batch size 10 verbose and now
we have our predictions in here and we
could go ahead and do a um oh we'll
print
predictions and then I guess I could
just put down predictions and five so we
can look at the first five of the
predictions and what we have here is we
have our age and uh the prediction on
this age versus on what what we think
it's going to be what what we think is
going to they going to have uh symptoms
or not and the first thing we notice is
that's hard to read because we really
want to yes no answer uh so we'll go
ahead and just uh round off the
predictions using the argmax um the
numpy argmax uh for prediction so it
just goes to
a01 and if you remember this is a
Jupiter notebook so I don't have to put
the print I can just put in uh rounded
predictions and we'll just do the first
five and you you can see here 0 1 0 0 0
so that's what the predictions are that
we have coming out of this um is no
symptoms symptoms no symptoms symptoms
no symptoms and just as uh we were
talking about at the beginning we want
to go ahead and um take a look at this
there we go confusion matrixes for
accuracy check um most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the S kit um the SK learn metrics uh s
kit being where that comes from import
confusion Matrix uh some iteration tools
and of course a nice map plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
um have a nice graph to look at u
pictures worth a thousand
words um and then we'll go ahead call it
CM for confusion Matrix y true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions and we'll go ahead and load
in our
cm and I'm not going to spend too much
time on the plotting um going over the
different plotting
code um you can spend uh like whole we
have whole tutorials on how to do your
different plotting on there uh but we do
have here is we're going to do a plot
confusion Matrix there's our CM our
classes normally false title confusion
Matrix cmap is going to be in
blues and you can see here we have uh to
the nearest cmap titles all the
different pieces whether you put tick
marks or not the marks the classes the
color bar um so a lot of different
information on here as far as how we're
doing the printing of the of the
confusion Matrix you can also just dump
the confusion Matrix um into a caborn
and real quick get an output it's worth
knowing how to do all this uh when
you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders you don't want to do this
on the Fly you want to take the time to
make it look really nice uh like our
guys in the back did and uh let's go
ahead and do this forgot to put together
our CM plot labels we'll go and run
that and then we'll go ahead and call
the little the
definition for our
mapping and you can see here plot
confusion Matrix that's are the the
little script we just wrote and we're
going to dump our data into it um so our
confusion Matrix our classes um title
confusion Matrix and let's just go ahead
and run
that and you can see here we have our
basic setup uh no side effects
195 had side effects uh 200 no side
effects that had side effects so we
predicted the 10 of them who actually
had side effects and that's pretty good
I mean I I don't know about you but you
know that's 5% error on this and this is
because there's 200 here that's where I
get 5% is uh divide these both by by two
and you get five out of a 100 uh you can
do the same kind of math up here not as
quick on the flight it's 15 and 195 not
an easily rounded number but you can see
here where they have 15
people who predicted to have no uh with
the no side effects but had side effects
kind of setup on there and these
confusion Matrix are so important at the
end of the day this is really where
where you show uh whatever you're
working on comes up and you can actually
show them hey this is how good we are or
not how messed up it
is so this was a uh I spent a lot of
time on some of the parts uh but you can
see here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model
summary and we just have the layers on
here that we built with our model on
this and then we went ahead and trained
it and ran the prediction now we can get
a lot more complicated uh let me flip
back on over here because we're going to
do another uh demo so that was our basic
introduction to it we talked about the
uh oops here we go okay so implementing
a neural network with carass after
creating our samples and labels we need
to create our carass neural network
model we will be working with a
sequential model which has three layers
and this is what we did we had our input
layer our hidden layers our output
layers and you can see the input layer
uh coming in uh was the age Factor we
had our hidden layer and then we had the
output are you going to have symptoms or
not so we're going to go ahead and go
with something a little bit more
complicated um training our model is a
two-step process we first compile our
model and then we train it in our
training data set uh so we have
compiling compiling converts the code
into a form of understandable by
Machine we used the atom in the last
example a gradient descent algorithm to
optimize a model and then we trained our
model which means it let it uh learn on
training data
uh and I actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
um here's our model that we
created
summarized uh we come down here and we
compile it so it tells it hey we're
ready to build this model and use it it
uh and then we train it and this is the
part where we go ahead and fit our model
and and put that information in here and
it goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
Matrix with
coros um as we are performing
classifications on our data we need a
confusion Matrix to check the results a
confusion Matrix breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the
accuracy um and so you can see here this
is what we did with the true positive
false positive true negative false
negative and that is what we went over
let me just scroll down
here on the end we printed it out and
you can see we have a nice print out of
our confusion Matrix uh with the true
positive false positive false negative
true negative and so the blue ones uh we
want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then uh we have our false predictions on
here uh as far as this one so it had no
side effects but we predicted let's see
no side effects predicting side effects
in vice versa if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scaleup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now uh saving
and loading models with carass we're
going to dive into a more complicated
demo um and you're going to say oh well
that was a lot of complication before
well if you broke it it down we
randomized some data we created the um
carass setup we compiled it we trained
it we predicted and we ran our Matrix uh
so we're going to dive into something a
lot a little bit more fun is we're going
to do a face mask detection with carass
uh so we're going to build a cross model
to check if a person is wearing a mask
or not in real time and this might be
important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
um might be very useful as far as some
of our you know making sure people are
safe uh and so we're going to look at
mask and no mask and let's start with a
little bit on the
data and so in my data I have with a
mask you can see they just have a number
of images showing the people in masks
and again if you want some of this
information uh contact simply learn and
they can send you some of the
information as far as people with and
without masks so you can try it on your
own and this is just such a wonderful
example of this setup on here so before
I dive into the mass detection uh
talking about being in the current with
h covid and seeing people are wearing
masks this particular example I had to
go ahead and update to a python 3.8
version uh it might run in a 37 I'm not
sure I I kind of skipped 37 and
installed
38 uh so I'll be running in a three
python 38 um and then you also want to
make sure your tensor flow is up to date
because the um they call
functional uh layers that's where they
split if you remember correctly from
back uh oh let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them uh very powerful
tool very popular right now in the edge
of where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so I've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and go through uh
our next example which includes uh
multiple layers um programming it to
recognize whether someone wears a mask
or not and then uh saving that model so
we can use it in real time so we're
actually almost a full um end to end
development of a product here uh of
course this is a very simplified version
and there'd be a lot more to it you'd
also have to do like uh recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this so
let's go ahead and jump into that code
and we'll open up a new Python 3 oops
Python 3 it's working on it there we
go um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train
mask and we want to go ahead and train
mask and save it uh so it's it's uh it's
save mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face and then from the cross standpoint
we got a lot of imports to do here and
I'm not going to dig too deep on the
Imports uh we're just going to go ahead
and notice a few of them uh so we have
in here go alt D there we go have
something to draw with a little bit here
we have our
uh image
processing and the image processing
right here me underline that uh deals
with how do we bring images in because
most images are like a a square grid and
then each value in there has three
values for the three different colors uh
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of uh working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listing and
figuring out what's going to go on uh
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2D
um this again is how do we deal with the
images and pulling them uh dropout's a
cool thing worth looking up if you
haven't when as you get more and more
into carass and tensor flow uh it'll
Auto drop out certain nodes that way
you'll get a better um the notes just
kind of die uh they find that they
actually create more of a bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them um and then we have our
flatten that's where you take that huge
array with the three different colors
and you find a way to flatten it so it's
just a one-dimensional array instead of
a 2X two
by3 uh D input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar oops there we go our input um
our model again these are things we had
on the last one here's our Optimizer
with our
atom um we have some pre-processing on
the input that goes along with bringing
in the data in uh more pre-processing
with image to array loading the image um
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing um and we're going to be
working with the setting something to
categorical again that's just a
conversion from a number to a category
uh 0 one doesn't really mean anything
it's like true false um
label bizer the same thing uh we're
changing our labels around and then
there's our train test split
classification report um our IM
utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these this
is something a little different going on
down here this is not part of the uh
tensor flow or the SK learn this is the
pyit setup and tensor flow above uh the
path this is part of um open SE CV and
we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the open CV so if you
want to know more about Open CV you'll
get a glance on it in uh this software
especially the ne the second piece when
we reload up the data and hook it up to
a video camera we're going to do that on
this round um but this is part of the
open CV thing and you'll see CV2 is
usually how that's referenced um but the
IM utilities has to do with how do you
rotate pictures around and stuff like
that uh and resize them and then the map
plot l liary for plotting because it's
nice to have a graph tells us how good
we're doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight OS
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like I said I'm not going to spend I
spent a little time going through them
uh but we didn't want to go too much
into
them and then I'm going to create um
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate uh to
to the4
.001 um a lot of times it's 0.001 or
0.001 usually it's in that uh variation
depending on what you're doing and how
many epics and they kind of play with
the epics the epics is how many times
are we going to go through all the
data now I have it as two um the actual
setup is for 20 and 20 works great the
reason I have it for two is it takes a
long time to process one of the downs
sides of
Jupiter is that Jupiter isolates it to a
single kernel so even though I'm on an 8
core processor uh with 16 dedicated
threads only one thread is running on
this no matter what so it doesn't matter
uh so it takes a lot longer to run even
though um tensor flow really scales up
nicely and the batch size is how many
pictures do we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to
run uh and this just has images of mass
and not
masks and if we go in here you'll see
data
set um and you have pictures with masks
they're just images of people with mask
on their face uh and then we have the
opposite me go back up here without
masks so it's pretty straightforward
they look kind of a skew because they
tried to format them into very similar
uh setup on there so they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here and that's
kind of an important thing to do on a
lot of these data sets get them as close
as you can to each other and we'll we
actually will run in the in this
processing of images up here and the
cross uh layers and importing and and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these and a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with uh so you have a couple things
going on there and so uh we're now going
to be this is now loading the um images
and let me see and we'll go ahead and uh
create data and labels here's our um uh
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out and then for categories in our
list directory directory and if you
remember I just flashed that at you it
had uh uh face mask or or no face mask
those are the two options and we're just
going to load into that we're going to
pin the image itself and the labels so
we're just create a huge array uh and
you can see right now this could be an
issue if you had more data at some point
um thankfully I have a a 32 gig hard
drive or U
Ram even that does you could do with a
lot less of that probably under 16 or
even eight gigs would easily load all
this stuff um and there's a conversion
going on in here I told you about how we
are going to convert the size of the
image so it resizes all the images and
that way our data is all identical the
way it comes
in and you can see here with our labels
we have without mask without mask
without mask uh the other one would be
with mask those are the two that we have
going in
there uh and then we need to change it
to the one not hot
encoding and this is going to take our
um um up here we had was it labels and
data uh we want the labels uh to be
categorical so we're going to take
labels and change it to categorical and
our labels then equal a categorical list
uh we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because um minus 10 to the end there we
go just so we can see what the other
side looks like we now have one that
means they have a mask one Zer one zero
so
on uh one being they have a mask and
zero no mask and if we did this in
Reverse I just realized that this might
not make sense if you've never done this
before let me run this
01 so zero is uh do they have a mask on
zero do they not have a mask on one so
this is the same as what we saw up here
without mask one equals um the second
value is without mask so with mask
without mask uh and then that's just a
with any of your data
processing we can't really a zero if you
have a 01
output uh it causes issues as far as
training and setting it up so we always
want to use a one hot encoder if the
values are not actual uh linear value or
regression values they not actual
numbers if they represent a
thing and so now we need to go ahead and
do our train X test X train y test y um
trains split test data and we'll go
ahead and make sure it's going to be uh
random and we'll take 20% of it for
testing and the rest for um setting it
up as far as training their model this
is something that's become so cool when
they're training these Set uh they
realize we can augment the data what
does augment mean well if I rotate the
data around and I zoom in I zoom out I
rotate it um share it a little bit flip
it hor
horizontally um fill mode as I do all
these different things to the data it um
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples I have uh so if I
have all these perfect samples what
happens when we only have part of the
face or the face is tilted sideways or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator um which is
going to rotate Zoom zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has um a
lot of times I'll the first time through
my models I'll leave that out so I want
to make sure there's a thing we call
build def fail which is just cool to
know you build the whole process and
then you start adding these different
things in uh so you can better train
your model and so we go and run this and
then we're going to load um and then we
need to go ahead and you probably would
have gotten an error if you hadn't put
this piece in right here um I haven't
run it myself cuz the guys in the back
did this uh we take our base model and
one of the things we want to do is we
want to do a mobile net
V2 um and this what we this is a big
thing right here include the top equals
false a lot of data comes in with a
label on the top row uh so we want to
make sure that that is not the case uh
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model uh we want to go ahead
and and set that
up and you'll see a warning here I'm
kind of ignoring the warning because it
has to do with the uh size of the
pictures and the weights for input shape
um so they'll it'll switch things to
defaults to saying hey we're going to
Auto shape some of this stuff for you
you should be aware of that with this
kind of imagery we're already augmenting
it by moving it around and flipping it
and doing all kinds of things to it uh
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if working in a
different
domain and so we're going to go back
here and we're going to have we have our
base model we're going to do our head
model equals our base model
output um and what we got here is we
have an average pooling 2D pool size 77
head model um head model flatten so
we're flattening the data uh so this is
all processing and flattening the images
and the pooling has to do with some of
the ways it can process some of the data
we'll look at that a little bit when we
get down to the lower level on this
processing it um and then we have our
dents we've already talked a little bit
about a DSE just what you think about
and then the head model has a Dropout of
0.5 uh what we can do with a
Dropout the Dropout says that we're
going to drop out a certain amount of
nodes while training uh so when you
actually use the model it will use all
the notes but this drops certain ones
out and it helps
stop biases from up forming uh so it's
really a cool feature on here they
discovered this a while back uh we have
another dense mode and this time we're
using soft Max activation lots of
different activation options here soft
Max is a real popular one for a lot of
things U so is
Ru and you know there we could do a
whole talk on activation formulas uh and
why what their different uses are and
how they work when you first start out
you'll you'll use mostly the ru and the
softmax for a lot of them uh just
because they're they're some of the
basic setups it's a good place to
start uh and then we have our model
equals model inputs equals base model.
input outputs equals head model so again
we're still building our model here
we'll go ahead and run
that and then we're going to Loop over
all the layers in the base model and
freeze them so they will not be updated
during the first training
process uh so for layer and BAS model
layers layers. trainable equals False A
lot of times when you go through your
data um you want to kind of jump in
partway through um I I'm not sure why in
the back they did this for this
particular example um but I do this a
lot when I'm working with series and and
specifically in stock data I want it to
iterate through the first set of 30 Data
before it does
anything um I would have to look deeper
to see why they froze it on this
particular one and then we're going to
compile our model uh so compiling the
model
atom AIT layer Decay um initial learning
rate over epics and we go ahead and
compile our loss is going to be the
binary cross entropy which will have
that print out Optimizer for opt metrics
is accuracy same thing we had before not
a huge jump as far as um the previous
code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model uh so train the
head of the network print info training
head
run now I skipped a little time because
it you'll see the run time here is um at
80 seconds per epic takes a couple
minutes for it to get through on a
single
kernel one of the things I want you to
notice on here while we're while it's
finishing the
processing is that we have up here our
augment going on so anytime the train X
and train y go in there's some
Randomness going on there and is
jiggling it around what's going into our
setup uh of course we're batch sizing it
uh so it's going through whatever we set
for the batch values how many we process
at a time and then we have the steps per
epic uh the train X the batch size
validation data here's our test X and
Test Y where we're sending that in
uh and this again it's validation one of
the important things to know about
validation is our um when both our
training data and our test data have
about the same accuracy that's when you
want to stop that means that our model
isn't biased if you have a higher
accuracy on your uh testing you know
you've trained it and your accuracy is
higher on your actual test data then
something in there is probably uh has a
bias and just overfitted uh so that's
what this is really about right here
with the validation data and validation
steps so it looks like it's let me go
ahead and see if it's done processing
looks like we've gone ahead and gone
through two epics again you could run
this through about 20 with this amount
of data and it would give you a nice
refined uh model at the end we're going
to stop at two because I really don't
want to sit around all afternoon and I'm
running this on a single thread so now
that we've done this we're going to need
to evaluate our model and see how good
it is and to do that we need to go ahead
and make our
predictions um these are predictions on
our test X to see what it thinks are
going to be uh so now it's going to be
evaluating the network and then we'll go
ahead and go down here and we want to
need to uh turn the index in remember
it's it's either zero or one it's uh 01
01 so you have two outputs uh not
wearing uh wearing a mask not wearing a
a mask and so we need to go ahead and
take that argument at the end and change
those predictions to a zero or one
coming out uh and then to finish that
off we want to go ahead and let me just
put this right in here and do it all in
one shot we want to show a nicely
formatted classification report so we
can see what that looks like on here and
there we have it we have our Precision
uh it's 97% with a mask there's our F1
score support without mask
97% um so that's pretty high high setup
on there you know three people are going
to sneak into the store who are without
a mask and that thinks they have a mask
and there's going to be three people
with a mask that's going to flag the
person at the front to go oh hey look at
this person you might not have a mask um
if I guess it's a set up in front of a
store um so there there you have it and
of course one of the other cool things
about this is if someone's walking into
the store and you take multiple pictures
of them um um you know this is just an
it it would be a way of flagging and
then you can take that average of those
pictures and make sure they match or
don't match if you're on the back end
and this is an important step because
we're g to this is just cool I love
doing this stuff uh so we're going to go
ahead and take our model and we're going
to save it uh so model save Mass
detector. model we're going to give it a
name uh we're going to save the format
um in this case we're going to use the
H5
format and so this model we just
programmed has just been saved uh so now
I can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say I want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well I just
saved the model they upload the model
now they can use it for whatever and
then if I get more information uh and we
start working with that at some
point I might want to update this model
um make a better model and this is true
of so many things where I take this
model and maybe I'm uh running a
prediction on uh making money for a
company and as my model gets
better I want to keep updating it and
then it's really easy just to push that
out to the actual end user uh and here
we have a nice graph you can see the
training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics uh we only did the you
know only shows just the one Epic coming
in here but you can see right here as
the uh um value loss train accuracy and
value
accuracy starts switch and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're um I
know when I work in the S kit with
sklearn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why I'd run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't converged all the
way uh so that would be a cue for me to
keep going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new Python
program and we just did our train mask
so now we're going to go ahead and
import that and use it and show you in a
live action um get a view of uh both
myself in the afternoon along with my
background of an office which is in the
middle still of reconstruction for
another
month and we'll call this
uh
mask
detector and then we're going to grab a
bunch of um a few items coming
in uh we have our um mob net V2 import
pre-processing input so we're still
going to need that um we still have our
tensor floral image to array we have our
load model that's where most of the
stuff's going on this is our CV2 or open
CV again I'm not going to dig too deep
into that we're going to flash a little
open CV code at you uh and we actually
have a tutorial on that coming out um
our numpy array our IM utilities which
is part of the open CV or CV2
setup uh and then we have of course time
and just our operating system so those
are the things we're going to go ahead
and set up on here and then we're going
to create this takes just a
moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy
lifting uh so we're going to detect and
predict a mask we have frame face net
Mass net these are going to be generated
by our open CV we have our frame coming
in and then we want to go ahead and and
create a mask around the face it's going
to try to detect the face and then set
that up so we know what we're going to
be processing through our
model
um and then there's a frame shape here
this is just our height versus width
that's all HW stands for um they've
called it blob which is a CV2 DNN blob
form image frame so this is reformatting
this Frame that's going to be coming in
literally from my camera and we'll show
you that in a minute that little piece
of code that shoots that in here uh and
we're going to pass the blob through the
network and obtain the face
detections uh so faet do set inport blob
detections face net forward print
detections
shape uh so these is this is what's
going on here this is that model we just
created we're going to send that in
there and I'll show you in a second
where that is but it's going to be under
face
net uh and then we go ahead and
initialize our list of faces their
corresponding locations and the list of
predictions from our face mask
Network we're going to Loop over the
detections and this is a little bit more
work than you think um as far as looking
for different faces what happens if you
have a fa a crowd of faces um so We're
looping through the detections and the
shapes going through here and
probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections we're going to filter out
weak detection by ensuring the
confidence is greater than the minimum
confidence uh so we've said it remember
zero to one so 0 five would be our
minimal confidence probably is pretty
good uh um and then we're going to put
in compute bounding boxes for the object
if I'm zipping through this it's because
we're going to do an open CV and I
really want to stick to just the carass
part and so I'm I'm just kind of jumping
through all this code you can get a copy
of this code from Simply learn and take
it apart or look for the open CV coming
out and we'll create a box uh the box
sets it around the
image ensure the bounding box fall
within dimensions of the
frame uh so we create a box around
what's going to we hope it's going to be
the face extract the face Roi convert it
from BGR to RGB
Channel again this is an open CV issue
not really an issue but it has to do
with the order um I don't know how many
times I've forgotten to check the order
colors when working with open CV because
it's all kinds of fun things when red
becomes blue and blue becomes red uh
then we're going to go ahead and resize
it process it frame it uh face frame
setup again the face the CBT color we're
going to convert it uh we're going to
resize it image to array pre-process the
input uh pin the face locate face. x.y
and x boy that was just a huge amount
and I skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face and that box because the
open CV does a decent job of finding the
face and that box is going to go in
there and see hey does this person have
a mask on
it uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals mass net. predict
faces batch size
32 uh so these different images of where
we're guessing where the face is are
then going to go through an generate an
array of faces if you will and we're
going to look through and say does this
face have a mask on it and that's what's
going right here is our prediction
that's the big thing that we're working
for and then we return the locations and
the predictions the locations just tells
where on the picture it is and then the
um prediction tells us what it is is it
a mask or is it not a mask all right so
we've loaded that all up so we're going
to load our serialized face detector
model from dis um and we have our the
path that it was saved in obviously
you're going to put it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it uh and then we have our
weights path um and so finally our face
net here it is equals CB2 dn. read net
uh Proto text path weights path and
we're going to load that up on here so
let me go ahead and run
that and then we also need to I'll just
put it right down here I always hate
separating these things in there um and
then we're going to load the actual mass
detector model from dis this is the the
the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling in all the different pieces
we need for our model and then the next
part is we're going to create open up
our video uh and this is just kind of
fun because it's all part of the open
CV video
setup and let me just put this all in as
one there we go uh so we're going to go
ahead and open up our video we're going
to start it and we're going to run it
until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what I like working about with
images and videos is that when you start
working with images and videos it's all
like right there in front of you it's
Visual and you can see what's going on
uh so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream Source zero start uh that means
it's C grabbing my main camera I have
hooked up um and then you know starting
video you're going to print it out
here's our video Source equals z start
Loop over the frames from the video
stream oops a little redundancy there um
let me
close I'll just leave it that's how they
had it in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
uh from our visual uh stream we're going
to resize it
and then we have a returning remember we
returned from the our procedure the
location and the prediction so detect
and predict mask we're sending it the
frame we're sending it the face net and
the MK net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on
here and then it returns our location
and predictions and then for our box in
predictions in the location and
predictions um and the box is is again
this is an open CV set that says hey
this is a box coming in from the
location um because you have the two
different points on there and then we're
going to unpack the box and predictions
and we're going to go ahead and do mask
without a mask equals
prediction we're going to create our
label no mask we create color if the
label equals mask l0 225 and you know
this is going to make a lot more sense
when I hit the Run button here uh but we
have the probability of the label we're
going to display the label bounding box
rectangle on the output
frame uh and then we're going to go
ahead and show the output from the frame
CV2 IM show frame frame and then the key
equals CV2 weit key1 we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our
feed and we're going to do this until we
hit the stop button pretty much so are
you ready for this let's see if it works
we've distributed our uh our model we've
loaded it up into our distributed uh
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run
it and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
popup and there I am in my office with
my funky headset
on uh and you can see in the background
my unfinished wall and it says up here
no mask oh no I don't have a mask on uh
I wonder if I cover my mouth what would
happen uh you can see my no
mask goes down a little bit I wish I'd
brought a mask into my office it's up at
the house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98% chance
that I don't have a mask on and it's
true I don't have a mask on right now
and this could be distributed this is
actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat uh
setup saying hey do you have a mask on
when you enter a store or public
transportation or whatever it is or the
required to wear a mask uh let me go aad
and stop
that now if you want a copy of this uh
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into open CV in another one so
I skipped a lot of the open CV um code
in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the carass uh saving
the model uploading the model and then
processing a streaming video through it
so you can see that the model works we
actually have this working model that
hooks into the video
camera which is just pretty cool and a
lot of
fun so I told you we're going to dive in
and really Roll Up Our Sleeve and do a
lot of coating today uh we did the basic
uh demo up above for just pulling in a
carass and then we went into a cross
model uh where we pulled in data to see
whether someone was wearing a mask or
not so very useful in today's world as
far as a fully running
application and we're going to take a
look at image classification using
carass and the basic setup we'll
actually look at two different demos on
here uh what's in it for you today what
is image
classification Intel image
classification data creating neural
networks with carass and the vgg16
model what is image
classification the process of image
classification refers to assigning
classes to an entire ire image images
can be classified based on different
categories like whether it is a
nighttime or daytime shot what the image
represents Etc and you can see here we
have uh mountains looking for mountains
we'll actually be doing some uh uh
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classifies them based on these
features and you can see here where it
says like what computer sees and this
say oh yeah we see mostly Forest maybe a
little bit of mountains because the way
the image is um and this is really where
one of the areas that neural networks
really shines um if you try to run this
stuff through uh more like a linear
regression model you'll still get
results uh but the results kind of miss
a lot of things as they as the neural
networks get better and better at what
they do with different tools we have out
there uh so Intel image classification
data
the data being used is the Intel image
classification data set which consists
of images of six types of land areas and
so we have Forest building glaciers and
mountains sea and Street uh and you can
see here there's a couple of the images
out of there as a setup in in the um uh
Intel image classification data that
they
use and then we're going to go into
creating a neural networks with
carass the convolution neural network
that we are creating from scratch looks
uh as showing
below you'll see here we have our input
layer
um they have a listed Max pulling uh so
you have as you're coming in with the
input layer and this the input layer is
actually um before this but the first
layer that it's going to go into it's
going to be a convolutional neural
network uh then you have a Max pooling
that pulls those the the convolutional
neural networks return
uh in this case they have two of those
that is very standard with convolutional
neural networks uh one of the ones that
I was looking at earlier that was
standard being used by um I want one of
the larger companies I can't remember
which one for doing a large amount of
identification had two convolutional
neural networks each with their Max
pooling and then about 17 dense layers
after it we're not going to do that
heavy duty of a of a code but we'll get
you a head in the right direction and
that gives you an idea of which you're
actually going to be looking at when we
look at the flattened part and then the
dense we're talking like 17 dense layers
afterwards uh I find that a lot of the
stuff I've been working on I end up
maxing it out right around nine dense
layers it really depends on what you
have going in and what you're working
with and the vgg16
model uh vgg16 is a pre-trained CNN
model which is used for image
classification it is trained on a large
very data set and F tune to fit image
classification data sets with
ease and you can see down here we have
the input coming in uh the convolutional
neural network 1: one 1:2 and then
pooling and then we do 2: one 2:2
convolutional neural network then
pooling 3 to2 and you can see there's
just this huge layering of convolutional
neural networks and in this case they
have five such layers going in and then
three dents going out or uh more now
when they took this setup this actually
won an award uh back in 2019 for this
particular
setup uh and it does it does really good
except that again um we only show the
three dense layers here and if you find
out depending on your data going in and
what you have set up uh that really
isn't enough on one of these setups and
I'm going to show you why we restricted
it because it does take up a lot of
processing power in some of these things
so let's go ahead and roll up our
sleeves and we're going to look at both
the setups we're going to start with the
um the first
classification um and then we'll go into
the vgg16 and show you how that's set up
now I'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like now I'm
running in the Anaconda here uh you'll
see that I've set up a main python uh 38
I always put that in there this is where
I'm doing like most of my kind of
playing around uh this is done in Python
version 3.8 we're not going to dig too
much into versions uh at this point you
should already have carass installed on
there usually carass takes a number of
extra
steps and then our usual um uh setup is
the numpy the pandas uh your SK your s
kit which is going to be the sklearn
your caborn and I'll I'll show you those
in just a minute um and then I'm just
going to be in the Jupiter lab where
I've created a new um notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook now I'm there's a couple cool
things to note in here is that um one I
used the the um Anaconda Jupiter
notebook setup because it keeps
everything separate uh except for carass
uh carass is actually running separately
in the back I believe it's a a c program
uh what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multiprocessors on the
computer and I'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the
code and when we look in here uh a
couple things to note is here's our uh
um oops I thought I grabbed the other
drawing thing uh but here's our numpy
and our pandas right here and our
operating system this is our SII kit you
always import it as sklearn for the
classification report uh we're going to
be using using well usually import like
Seaborn brings in all of your pip plot
Library
also kind of nice to throw that in there
I can't remember if we're actually using
caborn if they just the people in the
back just threw that together um and
then we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our map plot
library that the caborn is pretty much
built on um CV2 if you're not familiar
with that that is our image um module
for importing the image and then of
course we have our tensor flow down here
which is what we're really working
with and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
um if you're doing a demo and you're
working with uh the partners or the
shareholders uh this tqdm is really kind
of cool it's an extensible progress bar
for Python and I I'll show you that too
remember data science is not I mean you
know most of this code when I'm looking
through this code I'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody I'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works uh so we need to go ahead and
import those different um uh setup on
there and then the next thing is we're
going to go ahead and set up our
classes uh now we remember if we had
Mountain streak Glacier building sea and
Forest those were the different images
that we have coming
in and we're going to go ahead and just
do class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of I for I
class name uh equals the class names so
our labels are going to match the names
up
here uh and then we have the number of
uh
classes and print the class names and
the labels and we'll go ahead and set
the image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you're
remember with neural
networks they take one size data coming
in and so when you're working with
images you really want to make sure
they're all resized to same uh setup it
might squish them it might stretch them
that generally does not cause a problem
in these uh in some of the other tricks
you can do with if you if you need more
data um and this is one that's used
regularly we're not going to do it in
here is you can also take these images
and not only resize them but you can
tilt them one way or the other crop
parts of them um so they process
slightly differently and it'll actually
increase your accuracy of some of these
predictions uh and so you can see here
we have Mountain equals zero that's what
this class name label is Street equals 1
Glacier equals 2 buildings equals 3 C4
Forest equals
5 now we did this as an enumerator so
each one is 0 through five uh a lot of
times we do this instead as um uh uh 0
one 0 1 01 you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out so
the next thing we really want to do is
we want to go ahead and load the data up
and just put a label in there loading
data just just so you know what we're
doing we're going to put in the loading
data down here uh make sure it's well
labeled uh and we'll create a definition
for
this and this is all part of your
preprocessing at this point you could
replace this with all kinds of different
things depending on what you're working
on and if you once you download you can
go download this data set uh send a note
to the simply learned team here in
YouTube um and they'll be happy to
direct you in the right direction and
make sure you get this path here um so
you have the right whatever wherever you
saved it a lot of times I'll just
abbreviate the path or put it as a sub
thing and just get rid of the directory
um but again double check your paths um
we're going to separate this into a
segment for training and a segment for
testing and that's actually how it is in
the folder let me just show you what
that looks
like so when I have my uh lengthy path
here where I keep all my programming
simply learned this particular setup
we're working on image classification
and image classification clearly you
probably wouldn't have that lengthy of a
list and when we go in here uh you'll
see sequence train sequence test they've
already split this up this is what we're
going to train the data in and again you
can see buildings Forest Glacier
Mountain SE Street uh and if we double
click let's go under Forest you can see
all these different Forest uh Imes
and and there's a lot of variety here I
mean we have wintertime we have
summertime um so it's kind of
interesting you know here's like a
Fallen Tree versus um a road going down
the middle that's really hard to train
and if you look at the
buildings A lot of these buildings
you're looking up a skyscraper we're
looking down the
setup here's some trees with one I want
to highlight this one it has trees in it
uh let me just open that up so you can
see it a little closer
the reason I want to highlight this is I
want you to think about this we have
trees growing is this the city or a
forest um so this kind of imagery makes
it really hard for a classifier and if
you start looking at these you'll see a
lot of these images do have trees and
other things in the foreground weird
angles really a hard thing for a
computer to sort out and figure out
whether it's going to be a forest or a
um
city and so in our loading of data uh
one we have to have the path the
directory we're going to come in here we
have our images and our labels so we're
going to load the images in one section
the labels in another
um and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders uh in
fact let me do this let
me there we go uh as we look at this
we're just going to Loop through the
three the six different folders that
have the different Landscapes and then
we're going to go through and pull each
file
out and each label uh so we set the
label we set the folder for file and
list uh here's our image path join the
paths this is all kind of n General
stuff um so I'm kind of skipping through
it really
quick and here's our image setup uh if
you remember we're talking about the
images we have our CV2 reader so it
reads the the image in uh it's going to
go ahead and take the image and convert
it to from blue green red to red green
green blue this is a CV2 thing um almost
all the time it Imports it and instead
of importing it as a standard this used
just about everywhere it Imports it with
the BGR versus RGB um RGB is pretty much
a standard in here you have to remember
that was CV2 uh and then we're going to
go ahead and resize it this is the
important part right here we've set it
we've decided what the size is and we
want to make sure all the images have
the same size on
them and then we just take our images
and we're just going to pin the image
pin the label um and then the images is
going to turn into a numpy array this
just makes it easier to process and
manipulate and then the labels is also a
numpy array and then we just return the
output append images and labels and we
return the output down
here
so we've loaded these all into memory uh
we haven't talked to much there'd be a
different setup in there because there
is ways to feed the files directly into
your cross model uh but we want to go
ahead and just load them all it's
really for today's processing and that
what our computers can handle that's not
a big
deal and then we go ahead and set the uh
train images train labels test images
test labels and that's going to be
returned in our output a pinned and you
can see here we did um uh images and
labels set up in there and it just loads
them in there so we'll have these four
different categories let me just go
ahead and run
that
uh so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on
there and then if you remember from
before uh we imported just go back up
there Shuffle here we go here's our
sklearn utilities import Shuffle and so
we want to take these labels and shuffle
them around a little bit um just mix
them up so it's not having the same if
you run the same process over and over
uh then you might run into some problems
on
there and just real quick let's go ahead
and do uh um a plot so we just you know
we we've looked at them as far as from
outside of our code we pulled up the
files and I showed you what that was
going on on we can go and just display
them here too and I tell you when you're
working with different
people this should be highlighted right
here um this thing is like when I'm
working on code and I'm looking at this
data and I'm trying to figure out what
I'm doing I skip this process the second
I get into a meeting and I'm showing
what's going on to other people I skip
everything we just did so and go right
to here where we want to go ahead and
display some images and take a look at
it and in this display um I've taken
them and I've resized the images to 20
by
20 that's pretty small uh so we're going
to lose just a massive amount of detail
and you can see here these nice
pixelated images um I might even just
stick with the folder showing them what
images we're
processing uh again this is you got to
be a little careful of this maybe recy
izing it was a bad idea um in fact let
me try it without resizing it and see
what happens oops so I took out the
image size and then we put this straight
in here one of the things again this is
um put the D there we go one of the
things again that we want to
know whenever we're working on these
things uh is the
CV2 there are so many different uh image
classification setups it's really a
powerful package when you're doing
images
but you do need to switch it around so
that it works with the p plot and so
make sure you take your numpy array and
change it to a u integer 8 format uh
because it comes in as a float otherwise
you'll get some weird images down there
um and so this is just basically we
split up or we've created a plot we went
ahead and did the plot 20 by 20 um or
the plot figure size is 20 by 20 um and
then we're doing 25 so a 5x5 subplot um
nothing really going on here too
exciting but you can see here where we
get the images and really when you're
showing people what's going on this is
what they want to see uh so you skip
over all the code and you have your
meeting you say okay here's our images
of the
building um don't get caught up in how
much work you do get caught up in what
they want to see so if you want to work
in data science that's really important
to
know and this is where we're going to
start uh having fun uh here's our model
this is where it gets exciting when
you're digging into these models and you
have here uh let me
get there we
go when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
uh
2D and uh 2D is an image you have two
different dimensions x y and even though
there's three colors it's still
considered 2D if you're running a video
you'd be com Evolution naral Network 3D
if you're doing a series going across um
a Time series it might be
1D and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional n network if you
look here there's a lot of really cool
settings going on to dig into um we have
our input shape so everything's been set
to 150 by 150 uh and it has of course
three different color schemes in it
that's important to notice um activation
default is railu uh this is small
amounts of data being processed on a
bunch of little um neural
networks and right here is the 32 that's
how many of these convolutional null
networks are being strung up on here and
then the
3X3 uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at uh a little 3x3
Square on each image and so that's
what's going on here and with
convolutional Norm networks the window
floats across and adds up all these
numbers going across on this data and
then eventually it comes up with 30 in
this case 32 different feature options
uh that it's looking for and of course
you can change that 32 you can change
the 3X3 so you might have a larger setup
and you know if you're going across
150 um by 150 that's a lot of steps so
we might run this as 15 by 15 uh there's
all kinds of different things you can do
here we're just putting this together
again that would be something you would
play with to find out which ones are
going to work better on this setup um
and there's a lot of play
involved that's really where becomes an
art form is guessing at what that's
going to be the second part I mentioned
earlier and I I can only begin to
highlight this um when you get to these
dense layers one is the activation is a
Ru they use a and a softmax here um it's
a whole whole uh setup just explaining
why these are different um and how
they're different because there's also
an exponential there's a tangent in fact
uh there's just a ton of these and you
can build your own custom activations
depending on what you're doing a lot of
different things go into these
activations uh there are two or three
major thoughts on these activations and
Ru and softmax are uh
well Ru uh you're really looking at just
the number you're adding all the numbers
together and you're looking at ukian
geometry um ax plus b X2 plus
cx3 plus a bias with softmax this
belongs to the party of um it's
activated or it's not except it's they
call it softmax because when you get to
the to zero instead of it just being
zero uh it's actually slightly a little
bit less than zero so that when it
trains it doesn't get lost um there's a
whole series of these activations
another activation is the
tangent um where it just drops off and
you have like a very narrow area where
you have from minus one to one or
exponential which is 0 to one so there's
a lot of different ways to do the
activation again we can do that'd be a
whole separate lesson on here we're
looking at the convolutional neural
network um and we're doing the two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional neural networks sted on
top of each other each with its own Max
pull underneath and let's go ahead and
run that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
um compile the model so let's go ahead
and do
that uh we are going to use the atom uh
Optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on on there there's some
other Optimizer but I think Adam's a
default um I don't really play with the
optimizer too much that's like the if
once you get a model that works really
good you might try some different
optimizers uh but adom is usually the
most and then we're looking at a
loss pretty standard we want to minimize
our Lo we want
to maximize the loss of error and then
we're going to look at accuracy um
everybody likes say accuracy I'm going
to tell you right now I start talking to
people and like okay what's what's the
loss on this and that and as a data
science yeah I want to know how the LW
what what's going on with that and we'll
show you why in a minute but everybody
wants to see accuracy they want to know
how accurate this is uh and then we're
going to run the fit and I wanted to do
this just so I can show you even though
we're in uh python setup in here where
jupyter notebook is using only a single
processor I'm going to bring over my
little CPU Tool uh this is eight cores
on 16 dedicated threats so it shows up
as 16
processors and actually I got to run
this and then move it over so we're
going to run this and hopefully it
doesn't destroy my
mic uh and as it comes in you can see
it's starting to do go through the epics
we said I set it for five epics and then
this is really nice because carass uses
all the different uh threads available
so it does a really good job of doing
that uh this is going to take a while if
you look at here it's um ETA 2 minutes
and 25 seconds 24 seconds so this is
roughly two and a half minutes per epic
uh and we're doing five epics so this is
going to be done in roughly 15 minutes I
don't know about you but I don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching The Green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run and
there we we go uh there was our 15
minutes it's actually less than that uh
because I did when I went in here
realized that uh H where was
it here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip uh fit and here's
our epics uh so I did four epics so a
little bit better more like 10 to 11
minutes instead of uh uh doing the full
uh 15 and when we look at this here's
our model we did we talked about the
compiler uh here's our history we're
going to um history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a
minute and what we're looking at is we
have our epics um here's our validation
split so as we train it uh we're
weighing the accuracy versus you kind of
pull some data off to the side uh while
you're training it and the reason we do
that is that um you don't want to
overfit and we'll look at that chart in
just a
minute uh here's batch
size this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time the larger the
batch it actually increases the
processing speed um and there's reasons
to go up or down on the batch size
because of the U the the smaller the
batch there's a certain point where um
you get too large of a batch and it's
trying to fit everything at once uh so I
128 is kind of big U depends on the
computer you're on what it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images and our train labels going in
telling it what we're going to train
on and then we look at our four epics
here uh here's our accuracy we want the
accuracy to go up and we get all the way
up to 83 or
83% now this is actual percentage based
pretty much and we can see over here our
loss we want our loss to go down really
fluctuates 55 1.2
7748 uh so we have a lot of things going
on there let's go ahead and graph
those turn that off and our our team in
the back did a wonderful job of putting
together um this basic plot setup um
here's our subplot coming in we're going
to be looking at um uh from the history
we're going to send it the accuracy and
the value
accuracy labels and set up on there um
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss so you can see what this
looks like what's really interesting
about this setup and let me let me just
go ahead and show you because uh without
actually seeing the plots it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense uh it's just
basic plotting of uh of the data using
the PIP plot library and I want you to
look at this this is really interesting
um when I ran this the first time I had
very different
results um and they they veryy greatly
and you can see here our accuracy
continues to
climb um and there's a crossover
here put it in here right here's our
crossover and I point that out because
as we get to the right of that crossover
where our
accuracy U and we're like oh yeah I got
8%
we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
um as our value um as a training set
versus the value um accuracy stays the
same and so that this is the one we're
actually really want to be aware of and
where it
crosses is kind of where you want to
stop at um and we can see that also with
the train loss versus the value loss
right here we did one Epic and look how
it just flat lines right there with our
loss
Lo so really one Epic is probably
enough and you're going to say wow okay
0.8% um certainly if I was working with
the shareholders um telling them that it
has an 80% accuracy isn't quite true and
and we'll look at that a little deeper
it really comes out here that the
accuracy of our actual values is closer
to0 41% right here um even after for
running it this number of times and so
you really want to stop right here at
that crossover one Epic would have been
enough um so the data is a little
overfitted on this when we do four
epics and uh oops there we are
okay my drawing won't go away um let me
see if I can get there we
go uh for some reason I've killed my
drawing ability and my
recorder all right took a couple extra
clicks uh so let's go ahead and take a
look at our actual test loss um so you
see where a cross is over that's where
I'm looking at that's where we start
overfitting the model and this is where
if uh we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model we would
start taking a look at the images and
start rotating them uh we might start
playing with the convolutional neural
network instead of doing the 3x3 window
um we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things um so let's go
ahead and take a click at our uh our
test loss now remember we had our
training data now we're going to look at
our test images and our test
labels for our test loss here and this
is just model evaluate uh just like we
did fit up here where was it um one more
model fit with our trending data going
in now we're going to evalate valuated
on the and and this data has not been
touched yet so this model's never seen
this data this is on uh completely new
information as far as the model is
concerned of course we already know what
it is from the labels we
have and this is what I was talking
about here's the actual accuracy right
here 0
48 uh or
4847 so this 49% of the Time guesses
what the image is
uh and I mean really that's a bottom
dollar uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49% work do we need to
upgrade the model more um in some cases
this might be uh oh what was I doing I
was working on uh stock
evaluations and we were looking at what
stocks were the top performers well if I
get that 50% correct on top performers
uh I'm good with that um that's actually
pretty good for stock evaluation in fact
the number I had for stock was more like
U um 30 something percent as far as
being a top performer stock much harder
to predict um but at that point you're
like well I'm you'll make money off of
that so again this number right here
depends a lot on the domain you're
working
on then we want to go ahead and bring
this home a little bit more uh as far as
looking at the different setup in here
and one of the uh from SK learn if you
remember actually let's go back to the
top uh we had the classification report
and this came in from our sklearn or S
kit setup and that's right here you can
see it right here on the
um see there we go uh classification
report right here uh sklearn metrics
import classification report that's
we're going to look at
next
a lot of this stuff uh depends on who
you're working with so when we start
looking at um
Precision you know this is like for each
value I can't remember what 111 was
probably mountains so if 44% is not good
enough if if you're doing like um you're
in the medical department and you're
doing cancer is it is this cancerous or
not and I'm only 44% accurate not a good
deal you know I would not go with that
um so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for Facebook you know 44%
I'm guessing the right person I would
hope it does a little bit better than
that um but here's our main accuracy
this is what almost everybody looks at
they say oh 48% that's what's important
um again it depends on what domain
you're in and what you're working
with and now we're going to do the same
model o somehow I got my there it goes I
thought I was going to get stuck on
there again uh this time we're going to
be using the
vgg16 and remember this one is uh all
those layers going into it so it's
basically a bunch of convolutional n
networks getting smaller and smaller on
here uh and so we need to go ahead and
um import all our different stuff from
carass uh we're importing the main one
is the V g16 set up on there just aim
that there we go
um there's kind of a pre-processing
images um applications pre-process input
this is all part of the VG g16 setup on
there uh and once we have all those we
need to go ahead and create our
model and we're just going to create a
vgg16 model in here um inputs model
inputs outputs model inputs I'm not
going to spend as much time as I did on
the other one uh we're going to go
through it really quickly one of the
first things I would do is if you
remember in carass you can trate treat a
model like you would a
layer um and so at this point I would
probably add a lot of dense layers on
after the vgg16 model and create a new
model with all those things in there and
we'll go ahead and uh run this uh
because here's our model coming in and
our setup and it'll take it just a
moment to compile
that what's funny about this is I'm I'm
waiting for it to download the um
package since I prean this um it takes
it a couple minutes to download the
vgg16 model into here um and so we want
to go ahead and train features for the
model we're going to predict the we're
going to predict the train images and
we're going to test features on the
predict test images on
here and then I told you I was going to
create another model too and the people
in the back uh did not disappoint me
they went ahead and did just that and
this is really an important part um this
is worth stopping for I told you I was
going to go through this really quick so
here's our
uh we we have our model
2 um coming in and we we've created a
model up here with the vgg16 model
equals model inputs model inputs and so
we have our
vgg16 this has already been
pre-programmed
uh and then we come down here I want you
to notice on this um right here layer
model two layers minus 4 to1 x layer X
um we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff onto it and so uh
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing by using model up here as
a layer um we could have had the input
go to this this model and then have that
go down here so we've added on this
whole setup this whole block of code
from 13 to 17 has been added on to our
vgg16 model and we have a new model uh
with the layer input and X down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it and that was a lot to go through
right there uh when you're building
these models this is the part that gets
so
complicated that you get stuck playing
in and yet it's so fun uh it's like a
puzzle how can I Loop these models
together and in this case you can see
right here that the layers uh we're just
copying layers over and adding each
layer in um this is one way to build a
new model and we'll go ahead and run
that like I said the other way is you
can actually use the model as a layer I
had a little trouble playing with it uh
sometimes when you're using the Straight
model
over you run into issues
um it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on uh the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come
up let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it uh again
here's our metrics accuracy sparse
categorical loss uh pretty
straightforward just like we did before
you got to compile the
model and just like before we're going
to take our create a history uh the
history is going to be uh new model fit
train
128 and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff we're
going to have to go ahead and it's going
to light up our uh setup on here and
this is going to take a little bit to
get us all set up uh it's not going to
just happen in a couple minutes so let
me go a and pause the video and run it
and then we'll talk about what
happened okay now when I ran that these
actually took about six minutes each um
so it's a good thing I put it on hold we
did four epics uh I actually had to stop
it at 10 switch it to four cuz I didn't
want to wait an
hour and you can see here our
accuracy um and our loss numbers going
down and just at a
glance it actually performed if you look
at the
accuracy
2658 um so our accuracy is going down or
you know
26% um 34% 35% and you can see here at
some point it just kind of K a bucket
again this is
overfitting that's always an issue when
you're running on uh programming these
different neural
networks and then we're going to go
ahead and plot the accuracy um history
we built that nice little sub routine up
above so we might as well use it and you
can see it right
here um there's that crossover
again and if you look at this look how
the how the um uh the red shifts up how
the uh our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're overfitting after one
Epic um we're
clearly not helping the problem or doing
better um we're just going to it's just
going to Baseline this one actually
shows with the training versus the
loss um value loss maybe second epic so
on here we're now talking more between
the first and the SE second epic and
that also shows kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts overfitting
and right about now you should be saying
uhoh uh something went wrong there I
thought that um when we went up here and
ran this look at this we have the
accuracy up here is hitting that
48% and we're down here
um you look at the score down here that
looks closer to 20% not nearly anywhere
in the ballpark of what we're looking
for and we'll we go ahead and run it
through the uh the actual test features
here and and there it is um we actually
run this on the Unseen data and
everything8 or
18% um I don't know about you but I
wouldn't want you know at 18% this did a
lot worse than the other one I thought
this is supposed to be the super model
the model that beats all models the
vgg16 that won the awards and everything
well the reason is is that um one we're
not pre-processing the data uh so it
needs to be more there needs to be more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here um and that would
actually greatly change the outcome on
here and then we went up here we only
added a couple dense layers um we added
a couple convolutional neural
networks this here huge pre-trained
setup is looking for a lot more
information coming in as far as how it's
going to train and so uh this is one of
those things where I thought it would
have done better and I had to go back
and research it and look at it and say
why didn't this work why am I getting
only uh 18% here instead of 44% or
better and that would be wise it doesn't
have enough training data coming in uh
and again you can make your own training
data so it's not that we have a shortage
of data it's that that some of that has
to be switched around and moved around a
little bit and this is interesting right
here too if you look at the
Precision we're getting it on number two
and yet we had zero on everything else
so for some reason is not
seeing uh the different variables in
here so it'd be something else to look
in and try to find track down um and
that probably has to do with the input
but you can see right here we have a
really good solid 0 48 up here uh and
that's where I'd really go with is is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in um where's the setup
on there and that is the art of data
science right there is finding out which
models work better and
why so sequential models uh so what
makes this a sequential model sequential
models are linear stacks of layers where
one layer leads to the next it is simple
and easy to implement and you just have
to make sure that the previous layer is
the input to the next layer so uh you
have used for plain stack of layers
where each layer has one input and one
output tensor and this is what tensor
flow is named after is um each one of
these layers is like a tensor each each
node is a tensor and then the layer is
also considered a tensor of
values and it's used for simple
classifier declassify models you can
it's also used for regression models too
so it's not just about uh this is
something this is a teapot this is a cat
this is a dog um it's also used for
generating um uh reget the actual values
you know this is worth $10 that's worth
$30 uh the weather's going to be 90° out
or whatever it is so you can use it for
both classifier and declassify uh
models and one more note when we talk
about sequential models the term
sequential is used a lot and it's used
in different areas and different
notations when you're in data science so
when we talk about time series we'll
talk about sequential that is something
very different uh sequential in this
case means it goes from the input to
layer one to Layer Two to the output so
it's very directional it's important to
note this because if you have a
sequential model can you have a
non-sequential model and the answer is
yes uh if you master the basics of a
sequential model you can just as easily
have another model that shares layers um
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of uh nodes maybe they're doing
a yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output um
that's what they call a cross uh the
cross
API so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential
model so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do a and do a demo on here
uh today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and carass and we'll
use our model to classify between five
different types of
flowers now for for this demo and you
can do this demo on whatever platform
you want or whatever um user interface
for developing python um I'm actually
using anaconda and then I'm using
Jupiter notebooks to develop in and if
you're not familiar with this um you can
go under environment once you've created
environment you can come in here to open
a terminal window and if you don't have
the different modules in here you can do
your cond install or whatever module it
is um just happen that this particular
setup didn't have a Seaborn in it which
I already installed
uh so here's our anaconda and then I'm
going to go
back and start up my Jupiter
notebook where I already created a uh
new uh python project Python 3 I'm in
Python 3.8 on this particular one um
sequential model for flowers so lots of
fun there uh so we're going to jump
right into this the first thing is is to
make sure you have all your modules
installed so if you don't have uh numpy
pandas matplot library and Seaborn and
the carass um and sklearn or sidekit
it's not actually sklearn you'll need to
go ahead and install all of those now
having done this for years and having
switched environments and doing
different things um I get all my imports
done and then we just run it and if we
get an error we know we have to go back
and install something um right off the
bat though we have numpy pandas matplot
Library Seaborn these are built on top
of each other pandas the data frame and
built on top of numpy the uh um data
array and then we bring in our SK learn
or S kit this is the scit setup SCI uh
kit even though you use sklearn to bring
it in it's a s kit and then our carass
we have our pre-processing the images
image data generator um our model this
is our basic model or sequential
model uh and then we bring in from coros
layers uh import dents um
optimizers these optimizers a lot of
them already come in these are your
different optimizers and it's almost a
lot of this is so automatic now um atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
uh and then we get our SGD which is uh
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data and I'm not going to go
into all of these uh different
optimizers we didn't even use these in
the actual demo you just have to be
aware that they are different optimizers
and the Digger the more you dig into
these models um you'll hit a point where
you do need to play with these a little
bit but for the most part leave it at
the default when you're first starting
out and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers
dense and then if we come down a little
bit more uh when they put this together
and they're running the dense layers
you'll also see they have dropout they
have flatten they have activation uh
they have the uh convolutional layer 2D
Max pooling 2D batch
normalization what are all these layers
uh and when we get to the model we're
going to talk about them uh a lot of
times when you're just starting you can
just uh uh import cross. layers and then
you have your Dropout your flatten uh
your convolutional uh neural network 2D
and we'll we'll cover what these do in
the actual example when we get down
there uh what I want you to take from
here though is you need to run your
Imports um and load your different
aspects of this and of course your
tensor flow TF because this is all built
on tensor flow and then finally uh
import random is RN just for random
generation and then we get down here we
have our uh
CV2 that is your um open image or your
open CV they call it for processing
images that's what the CV2
is uh we have our
tqdm the tqdm is for um is a progress
bar just a fancy way um of adding when
you're running a process you can view
the bar going across in the Jupiter uh
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have um we want to be able to
shuffle some files uh again these are
all different things pill is another uh
image processor it goes with the CV2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we're got to bring
them all
in and the next thing is to set up our
directories and so when we come into the
directories there's an important thing
to note on here other than we're looking
at a lot of flowers which is
fun uh is we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different uh
files for different flowers are put in
we're noting an X and a z and the x is
the data of the image and the Z is the
tag for it what kind of flower is this
uh and the image size is really
important because we have to resize
everything if you have a neural network
and if you remember from our neural
networks uh let me flip back to that
slide when we look at this slide we have
two input nodes here uh with an image
you have an input node depending on how
you you set it up for each pixel and
that pixel has three different color
schemes usually in it sometimes four so
if you have a picture that's 150 by
150 uh you multiply 150 * 150 * 3 that's
how many nodes input layers coming in I
mean so this is a massive input a lot of
times you think oh yeah it's just a a
small amount of data or something like
that uh no it's a full image coming in
then you have your hidden layers A lot
of times they match what the image size
is coming in in so each one of those is
also just as big and then we get down to
just a single output so that's kind of a
a thing to note in here what's going on
behind the scenes and of course each one
of these layers has a lot of processes
and stuff going
on and then we have our our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so I'm just setting the directories
that's all this is um archive flowers
Daisy sunflower tulip dandelion Rose uh
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
uh and then we want to go ahead and we
need to assign labels remember we
defined x and
z so we're just going to create a uh uh
definition here um and the first thing
is a return flower type
okay just returns it what kind of flower
it is I guess assign label to it uh but
we're going to go ahead and make our
train data and when you look at this
there's a couple things to take away
from here uh the first one is we're just
appending right onto our numpy array the
image we're going to let numpy handle
all that different aspects as far as 150
by 150 by 3 uh we just dump it right
into the numpy which makes it really
easy we don't have to do anything funky
on the processing and we want to leave
it like that and I'm going to talk about
that in a minute uh and then of course
we have to have the string upin the
label on there and I want you to notice
right here uh we're going to read the
image
in and then we're going to size it and
this is important because we're just
changing this to 150 by 150 we're
resizing the image so it's uniform every
image comes in identical to the other
ones uh this is something that's so
important is um when you're resizing or
reformatting your data you really have
to be aware of what's going on with
images it's not not a big deal because
with an image you just resize it so it
looks squishy or spread out or stretched
um the neural network picks up on that
and it doesn't really change how it
processes
it so let's go ahead and run that uh and
now we've got our definition set up on
there and then we want to go ahead and
make our
uh training data uh so make the train
data uh daisy flower daisy directory uh
print length of X so here we go let's go
and run that and we're just loading up
the flower daisy uh so this is going all
in there and it's setting um it's adding
it in to the our setup on there to our x
and z setup and we see we have
769 um and then of course you can see
this nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added uh code in
there that just makes it really cool for
doing demos uh not necessarily When
You're Building build your own model or
something like that but if you're going
to display this to other people adding
that little what was it called
um tqdm I can never remember that uh but
the tqdm module in there is really nice
and we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and
of course you could have just uh created
an array of these um but this has an
interesting problem that's going to come
up and I want to show you something it
doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are at
programming errors are going to come up
and you got to figure out how to handle
them uh and so when we get all the way
down
to the um where is it dandelion here's
our dandelion directory we're going to
build
um Jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with but at the same time you would want
to go back in there depending on how
many times you rerun this how many times
you pull this so when you're finding
errors um going in here there's a couple
things you can do and we're just going
to um oh it wasn't there it is there's
our error I knew there was an error this
processed
1,62 out of
1,65 now I can do a couple things one I
can go back into our definition and I
can just put in here try and so if it
has a bad conversion because this is
where the errors is coming from uh just
skip it that's one way to do it um when
you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay I lost
three points who cares um or you can go
in there and try to delete it um it
really doesn't matter for this
particular demo and so we're just going
to leave that error right alone and skip
over because it's already added all the
other files in there and this is
wonderful thing about Jupiter notebook
is that I can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating is
still uh running and we'll just go right
into the next flower row so all these
flowers are in there
um that's just a cool thing about
Jupiter
notebook uh and then we can go ahead and
just take a quick look and
see what we're dealing with and this is
of course really when you're dealing
with a other people and showing them
stuff this is just kind of fun where we
can display it on the plot Library here
and we're just going to go through and
um let's see what we got here uh looks
like we're going to do like five of each
of them I think is that how they set
this up um plot Library 5x two okay oh I
see how they did it okay so two each so
we have 5x two setup on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these
flowers it's always a good thing to look
at some of your data uh no matter what
you're doing we've reformatted this to
150 by 150 you can see how it really
blurs this one up here on the Tulip that
is that resize to 150 by 150 um and
these are what's actually going in these
are all 150 by 150 images you can check
the dimensions on the side and you can
see uh just a quick sampling of the
flowers we're actually going to process
on here and again like I said at the
beginning most of your work in data
science is
reprocessing this different uh
information so we need to go ahead and
take our
labels uh and run a label encoder on
there and then we're just Le is a label
encoder one of the things we
imported and then we always use the fit
um to categorical y comma 5 uh X here's
our array um X so if you look at this
here's our fit we're going to transform
Z that's our Z array we
created um and then we have Y which
equals that and then we go ahead and do
uh to categorical we want five different
categories and then we create our x uh
in p of x x = x over
255 so what's going on here there's two
different Transformations one we've
turned our categories into 0 1 2 3 4 5
as the output and we have taken our X
array and remember the X array is three
values of your different
colors this is so important to
understand when we do this across a
numpy array this takes every one of
those three colors so we have 150 by 150
pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three um color arrays and those
color arrays ra range from 0 to 250 so
when we take the xal X over
255 I'm sorry range from 0 to 255 this
converts all those pixels to a number
between zero and one and you really want
to do that when you're working with
neural networks uh now if you do a
linear regression model um it doesn't
affect it as much so you don't have to
do that conversion if you're doing
straight numbers but when you're running
neural networks if you don't do this
you're going to create a huge bias and
that means it'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions so now we have our um X and
Y values uh X being the data in y being
our no one
output and with any good setup we want
to divide this data into our training so
we have X train
uh we have our X test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with and of course your y train
corresponds to your X train and your y
test corresponds to your X test the
outputs and this is uh when we do the
train test split this was from the pyit
sklearn we imported train test split and
we're just going to go ahead and do the
test size at about a quarter of the data
0.25 and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool I mean
certainly you can do your own division
um you know you could just take the
first you know 0.25 of the data or
whatever do the length of the data not
real hard to do but this is randomized
so that if you're running this test a
few times you can kind of get an idea
whether it's going to work or
not sometimes what I will do is um I'll
just split the data into three parts and
then I'll test it on two with one being
the U or trained on two of those parts
with one being the test and I rotate it
so I come up with three different
answers which is a good way of finding
just how good your model is uh but for
setting up let's stick with the XT train
X test and the SK learn
package and then we're going to go ahead
and uh do a random
seed uh now a lot of times the cross
actually does this automatically but
we're going to go ahead and set it up on
here and you can see we did an NP random
seed um from 42 and we get a nice RN
number um and then we do TF random we
set the seed so you can set your
Randomness at the beginning of your
tensor flow and that's what the tf.
random. set
is so that's a lot of prep um all this
prep and then we finally get to the
exciting part um this is where you
probably spend once you have the data
prepped and you have your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these
models and so we look at this model one
we're going to designate it sequential
um they have the API which is a cross
the cross tensorflow API versus
sequential sequential means we're going
one layer to the next so we're not going
to split the layer and bring it back
together it looks almost the same with
the exception of um bringing it back
together so it's not a huge step to go
from this to an
API and the first thing we're going to
look at is um our convolutional neural
network in 2D uh so what's going on here
there's a lot of stuff that's going on
here
um the default for well let's start with
the beginning what is a convolutional 2d
Network well convolutional 2D Network
creates a number of small windows and
those small Windows float over the
picture and each one of them is their
own neural network and it's basically U
becomes like a um a categorization and
then it looks at that and it says oh if
we add these numbers up a certain way uh
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things and we have filters 32
so this is actually creating 32 Windows
is what that's
doing and the kernel size is 5x5 so
we're looking at a 5x5 Square remember
it's 150 by 150 so this narrows it down
to a 5x5 it's a 2d so it has your XY
coordinates um and when we look at this
5x5 remember each one of these is is
actually looking at 5x5 by3 uh so we're
actually looking at 15x 15 different um
pixels and padding is just um uh usually
I just ignore that activation by default
is railu we went ahead and put the railu
in
there there's a lot of different
activations railu is for your smaller uh
when you remember I mentioned atom when
you have a lot of data data use an atom
kind of activation or use an processing
we're using the rayu here uh it kind of
gives you a yes or no but it it doesn't
give you a full yes or no it has a um a
zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle very common this the most
common wand and then of course here's
our input shape 150 by 150 by 3
pixels and then we have to pull it so
whenever you have a two convolutional 2D
um uh layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into uh neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat
this uh so we're going to add another
Network here one of the cool things if
you look at this is that it as it comes
in it just kind of automatically assumes
you're going down to the next layer and
so we have another convolutional null
network uh 2D here's our Max pooling
again we're going to do that again Max
pooling uh and we're just going to
filter on down now one of the things
they did on this one is they changed the
kernel size they changed the number of
filters and so each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently and that's kind of cool
because then you get a little added
filtering on there this is where you
start playing with the model you might
be looking at a convolutional null
Network which is great for image
classifications um we get down to here
one of the things we see is flatten so
we had we just flatten it remember this
is 150 by 150 by three well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flatten just puts that
into a 1D array uh so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the the pixels and
everything it's just flat and then the
dense is just another activation on
there um by default it is probably railu
as far as this
activation and then oh yeah here we go
in sequential they actually added the
activation as Ru so this
because this is sequential this
activation is attached to the dents uh
and there's a lot of different
activations but Ru is the most common
one and then we also see a soft Max uh
soft Max is similar but it has its own
kind of variation one of the cool things
you know what let me bring this up
because if we if you don't know about
these activations this doesn't make
sense and I just did a quick Google
search on images of tensorflow
activations um I should probably look at
which website this is but this is the
output of the values uh so as your X as
it adds in all those uh weighted X
values going into the node it's going to
activate it a certain way and that's a
sigmoid activation and you can see it
goes between zero and one and has a nice
curve there this also shows the
derivatives um and if we come down the
seven popular activation functions
nonlinear activations there's a lot of
different options on this let me see if
I can find the
oops let me see I can find this specific
to
railo so this is a leaky
rilu and you can see instead of it just
being zero and then a value between uh
going up it has a little leaky there
otherwise your Ru loses some notes they
just become inactive um but you can see
there's a lot of different options here
here's a good one right here with the
Rayo you can see the raayo function on
the upper on the upper left here and
then the Leaky raayo over here on the
right which is very common commonly used
also one of the things I use with
processing um language is the S is the
exponential one or the tangent H the
hyperbolic tangent because they have
that nice uh funky curve that comes in
that um has a whole different meaning
and captures word use better again these
are very specific to domain and you can
spend a lot of time playing with
different models for our basic model uh
we'll stick to the ru the softmax on
here and we'll go ah and run and build
this
model so now that we've had fun playing
with all these different models that we
can add in there uh we need to go ahead
and have a batch size on here uh
128 epics
10 this means that we're going to send
128 uh rows of data or flowers at a time
to be processed and the Epic 10 that's
how many times we're going to Loop
through all the data
um and then there's all kinds of stuff
you can do again this is now built into
a lot of coros models already by default
um so there's different ways to reduce
um the values and verbose verbose equals
one means that we're going to show
what's going on um value monitor what
we're monitoring we'll see that as we
actually train the model this is what's
what's going to come out of there if you
set the verbos equal to zero um you
don't have to watch it train the model
although it is kind of nice to actually
know what's going on
sometimes and since we're still working
on uh bringing the data in here's our
batch site here's our epics we need to
go ahead and create a data generator uh
this is our image data
generator and it has all the different
settings in here almost all of these are
defaults uh so if you're looking at this
going oh my gosh this is confusing most
of the time you can actually just ignore
most of this
um vertical flip so you can randomly
flip pictures you can randomly
horizontally flip them um you can shift
the picture around this kind of helps
gives you multiple data off of them uh
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that um um setup because we already have
a huge amount of data if you're short
data you can start flipping like a
horizontal picture and it will generate
it's like doubling your data almost
um so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have um
5,000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias uh that is the downside
of
that and so we have our model compile
and this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here we're going to take all this
information as far as how we want it to
go
and we're going to compile it this
actually builds the model and so we're
going to run that and I want you to
notice uh learning
rate very important this is the default
001 um there's there you really don't
this is how slowly it adjusts to find
the right answer and the more data you
have you might actually make this a
smaller number um with larger with you
have a very small sample of data you
might go even larger than that and then
we're we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used and this is uh how
how much it improves the model is
improving is what this number means or
yeah that's that's important on there
and then the accuracy we want to know
just how good our model is on the
accuracy and then uh one of the cool
things to do is if you're in a group of
people who are studying the model if
you're in shareholders you don't want to
do this is you can run the model summary
I do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
um we'll call it history but we want to
do a model fit
generator and so what this history is
doing is this is tracking what's going
on as while it fits the
model now there's a lot of new setups in
here where they just use fit and then
you put the generat in here um we're
going to leave it like this even though
the new default um is a little different
on that doesn't really matter it does
the same thing and we'll go ahead and
just run
that and you can see while it's running
right here uh we're going through the
epics we have one of 10 now we're going
through six of 25 here's our loss we're
printing that out so you can see how
it's improving and our accuracy the
accuracy gets better and better and this
is 6 out of 25 this is going to take a
couple minutes to process uh because we
are training 150 by 150 by 3 pixels
across uh six layers or eight layers
whatever it was that is a huge amount of
processing so this will take a few
minutes to process this is when we talk
about the hardware and the problems that
come up in data science and why it's
only now just exploding being able to do
neural networks this is why this process
takes a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because I did uh uh pause
the recorder to let this go ahead and
run all the way through it's epics let's
go ahead and take a look and see what
these epics are and um if you set the
verbos to uh zero instead of one it
won't show what's going on in the behind
the scenes has is training it so when we
look at this epic 10 epics we went
through all the data 10 times uh if I
remember correctly there's roughly a gig
of data there so that's a lot of data
the first first thing you're going to
notice is the 270 seconds um that's how
much each of those epics took to run and
so if you divide 60 in there you roughly
get about 5 minutes worth of each epic
so if I have 10 epics that's 50 minutes
almost an hour of
runtime that's a big deal when we talk
about processing uh in on this
particular computer um I actually have
what is it uh uh eight cores with 16
dedicated threads so it runs like a 16
core computer it alternates the threads
going in and it still takes it 5 minutes
for each one of these epics so you start
to see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to Fe
find out how good the models are doing
and what model to use and so each of
those models could take all night to run
in fact I have a model I'm running now
that takes over uh takes about a day and
a half to test each model um it takes
four days to do with the whole data uh
so what I do is I actually take a small
piece of the
data test it out to find out uh get an
idea of of how the different setups are
going to do and then I increase that
size of the data and then increase it
again and I can just take that that
curve and kind of say okay if um the
data is doing this then I need to add in
more dense layers or whatever uh so you
can do a small chunks of data then
figure out what it cost to do a large
set of data and what kind of model you
want the L
as we see here continues to go down uh
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a um
userfriendly number other than the more
it Trends down the better and so if you
continue to see the loss going down
eventually get to the point where it
stops going down and it goes up and down
and kind of waivers a little bit that
point you know you've run too many epics
you're you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit the accurac accy just
turns us into something that uh we can
use and so the accuracy is what
percentage of guess is in this case is
categorical this is the percentage of
guesses are correct um value loss is
similar you know it's a minus a value
loss and then you have the value
accuracy and you'll see the value
accuracy is pretty similar to the
accuracy um just rounds it off basically
and so a lot of times you come down here
and you go okay we're doing 0.5
6 7 and that is 70 % accuracy or in this
case 68 uh 59% accuracy that's a very
usable number and it's very important to
have if you're identifying uh flowers
that's probably good enough if you can
get within a close distance and knowing
what flower you're you're identifying uh
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not might want to rethink it a
little bit or uh rekey how you're
building your model so if I'm working
with a uh uh a group of um clients um
shareholders in a company or something
like that you don't really want to show
them this um you don't want to show them
hey you know this is what's going on
with the accuracy these are just numbers
and so we want to go and put the
finishing touches just like when you are
building a house and you put in the
frame and the trim on the house it's
nice to have something a nice view of
what's going on and so we'll go ahead
and do a uh pie plot and we'll just plot
the history of the loss uh the history
of the value loss over here um epics
train and test and so we're just going
to compute these this is really
important uh and what I want you to
notice right here is when we get to
about oh five epics a little more than
five six epics you see a crossover here
and it starts Crossing as far as the um
uh value loss and what's going on here
is you have the loss in your actual
model and your actual data and you had
the value loss where it's testing it
against the the test data the the data
wasn't used to program your model wasn't
used to train your model on and so when
we see this crossing over this is where
the bias is coming in this is becoming
overfitted and so when you put these two
together uh right around five and six
you start to see how it does this this
switch over here and that's really where
you need to stop right around five yeah
six um it's always hard to guess because
at this point the model's kind of a
black box uh see but you know that right
around here if you're saving your model
after each run you want to use the one
that's right around five epics because
that's the one that's going to have the
least amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop uh it also is
you know I don't show people this mess
up here um I show somebody this kind of
model and I say this is where the
training and the testing comes in on
this model uh it just makes it easier to
see and people can understand what's
going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we're able to
classify them uh within about you 68 70%
accuracy whether it's going to be a
dollia sunflower cherry blossom Rose um
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a different tables
to see where the errors are coming from
and what problems are coming
up and that brings us to the end of this
video on artificial intelligence 2022
full course by simply loar I hope you
liked it if you have any queries then
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for
watching hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
[Music]
here